WHEN I GET
TOO FAR BEHIND RADIO STARTED.
OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON. WELCOME TO
TODAY'S HEARING JUST TO THAT
THE SERGEANTS AS IT IS IT LIVE
DOWN THERE. AT THE MIKE SOME
APPROPRIATE SPOT. I THINK. ALL
YEAH OKAY. AND THESE ARE BOTH
ALL RIGHT NOW OKAY. I ASSUME
THAT WE'RE ALL GOOD BUT LET ME
KNOW OTHERWISE SO TODAY'S
TODAY'S MAY REVISE HEARING FOR.
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY'S
HEARING ON K. TWELVE AND EARLY
EDUCATION A FEW THREE TO FOUR.
A FEW THINGS OUT OF THE OUT OF
THE GATE WE ARE GOING TO BREAK
UP THE PRESENTATION FOR K.
TWELVE AND EARLY ADS WILL GET
HAVE THE LA- AND FINANCE AND C.
D. E. PRESENT ON K. TWELVE AND
THEN HAVE. A MEMBER QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS AND THEY WERE
GOING TO GET TO THE EARLY ADD
CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL PIECE
OF THE HEARING WILL THAT MEMBER
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS ALL THAT
PUBLIC COMMENT ON BOTH THE
TOPICS- AT THE VERY END OF THE
HEARING. BUT BEFORE. WE GET TO
THE MEAT OF THE OF THE HEARING
ON A FOCUS ON JUST THE NEW
WORLD WERE FACING HERE ON THE
PROCEDURAL ISSUES AND THE
FORMAT OF THIS HEARING OF
COURSE IS VERY DIFFERENT AND-
THE MOST MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A COUPLE IS ALREADY BUT
SOME POP MEMBERS THE PUBLIC
HAVE NOT. SO I WANT TO READ
SOMETHING THAT ALL THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRS ARE READING-
OF COURSE IS OUR SECOND HEARING
FOR THIS SUBCOMMITTEE IN THE
ERA PHYSICAL DISTANCING
UTILIZING TECHNOLOGY TO MAKE
TESTIMONY FROM PANELISTS-
REMOTE AND AVAILABLE TO HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE AS
WELL. AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF EFFORTS FROM THE SPEAKER
STAFF ASSEMBLY RULES THE
SERGEANTS THE LASER DATACENTER
TO MAKE SURE THIS WORKS AND WE
CAN HAVE A- ENGAGING HEARING
WITH THE MEMBERSBUT ALSO WITH
THE PUBLIC- SOME SPECIFICS
ABOUT THIS ROOM TODAY TODAY WE
ARE IN ROOM FOUR. THIRTY SEVEN
WE ARE HAVING A PHYSICAL-
DISTANT IN PERSON HEARING EVEN
THIS EVEN THOUGH THIS IS ONE OF
THE LARGEST- HEARING ROOMS IN
THE CAPITAL WE CAN ONLY COMMENT
A FEW MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AND
SO WE ARE LETTING THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION HERE TODAY IT'S
WE HAVE OTHER OPTIONS FOR
PEOPLE TO ENGAGE BUT KEEP IN
MIND IF YOU ARE HERE WE ARE
FOCUSING ON THE STRICT. SIX
FEET- IN DISTANCING FOR OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH- WENT PUBLIC
COMMENT BEGINS OF ANY MANNER
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IS IN THE
ROOM AND WISHES TO- TO SPEAK
PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND I WILL
MAKE SURE WE POINT YOU TO THE
MICROPHONE AND WHERE TO GO- WE
ALSO ASK THAT- YOU DON'T TOUCH
THE MICROPHONE. AND THE ROOF
AND REVIEW- ONE REMIND YOU THAT
THERE IS ONE MINUTES PER
INDIVIDUAL IN PA THE COMMENTS
AND AFTER YOU COMMENTS IF WE DO
HAVE CAPACITY ISSUES WILL ASK
YOU TO LEAVE THE HEARING ROOMS
OTHER PEOPLE CAN PARTICIPATE.
ON THE- FOR THE PANELISTS ALL
OUR PANELISTS ARE ARE APPEARING
REMOTELY TODAY FROM A- REMOTE
WITNESS ROOM. WITH THE STAFF
MODERATOR HELPING WITH THE
CONVERSATIONS I WITH THE
MEMBERS HERE TODAY- WE HAVE
REMOTE PUBLIC COMMENTS AS WELL
WILL BE USING THE MODERATE
TELEPHONE SERVICE FOR THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. PORTION WE
DIRECTED OUR STAFF TO MAKE SURE
THAT INSTRUCTIONS FOR THE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION- HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED. IN ADVANCE THE
HEARINGS- IN ADDITION. THE
NUMBER OF COURSE IS ON. THE
SCREEN BUT ALSO AS WELL IT'S
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
WITH THE ACCESS CODE ONE THREE
ONE. FOR FOUR THREE SEVEN.
AGAIN THIS NUMBER WILL BE
POSTED LIVESTREAM BEFOREHAND
YOU CAN FIND OUT THE NUMBER
ALSO AS WELL ON THE ASSEMBLY.
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER TWO
WEBSITES- TO GIVE YOU FURTHER
INSTRUCTIONS AS AS WELL WITH
THE REMOTE- TELEPHONE
PARTICIPATION EACH PERSON WILL
HAVE ONE MINUTE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AND WILL NEED TO.
ENFORCE THIS BECAUSE WE HAVE A-
A HARD SHUT DOWN AT TODAY'S
HEARING SO THEY CAN. CLEAN THE
RUMOR AND PREPARE FOR HEARINGS
TOMORROW. THIS HEARING WILL
HAVE A SLIGHT DELAY FROM THE
FROM THE BROADCAST THE ACTUAL-
ON THE BROADCAST FROM THE
HEARING ROOM TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT SO IF YOU'RE CALLING IN.
THESE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE LIKE YOUR BROADCAST LIVE
STREAM. TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION. YOU CAN ALSO
CONTACT THE COMMITTEE DIRECTLY
ASSEMBLY BUDGET OMMITTEE IF
YOU'RE HAVING PROBLEMS- IN GET
ENGAGING WITH US TODAY OR
HAVING ISSUES. GETTING IN LINE
FOR THE TELEPHONE PUBLIC
COMMENT THAT PHONE NUMBER FOR
THAT COMMITTEE IS 916-319-2099
OKAY AND THEN LASTLY WE'RE
WE'RE NOTING THAT AS ALWAYS WE
DO ACCEPT. ENGAGEMENT AND-
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION VIA EMAIL
AND THAT IS ON THE WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ITS BUDGET SUB TO THE
NUMBER TWO AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOP. ALL RIGHTY THAT WAS A LOT
SO LET'S GET TO THE MAIN THING
WE'RE HERE TALKING ABOUT SKIP
THE MAIN THING THE MAIN THING
AND THAT IS. THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSAL FROM OUR- DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE AND THE LA L. JUST
SOME INTRO COMMENTS BEFORE WE
HEAR FROM. THE LA OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- YOU KNOW
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
FOR OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM. IT'S A HISTORIC TIME
I'M NOT SURE PEOPLE REMEMBER IT
AS A FAVORABLE THE START TIME
I'M SURE SOMETHING THAT NO
ONE'S GONNA FORGET NON OUR KIDS
ARE NEVER GOING TO FORGET THAT.
COVERED NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY-
THIS IS ERA DISTANCE LEARNING
HAS HAS WORKED FOR SOME KIDS IN
SOME FAMILIES AND NOT WILL NOT
WELL FOR OTHERS AND- WE KNOW
THAT IT'S GOING TO BE A REALITY
CHECK FOR MANY. FAMILIES AND
KIDS WHO ARE BEHIND AND WHO OF
MAYBE ALREADY BEEN BEHIND IT
ARE STILL BEHIND SET SOMETHING
WE NEED TO BE MINDFUL ABOUT AS
WE- FINALIZE OUR OUR BUDGET
TODAY. WE KNOW THAT PARENTS ALL
ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE WORKING
EXTRA HARD RIGHT NOW AS OUR
TEACHERS. BUT LET'S FACE IT
THAT MANNY'S FAMILIES OF
PARENTS- ESPECIALLY THE MOM
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA ARE
WORKING OVERTIME TRIPLE TIME.
TO MAKE IT GO AND DOES NOT A
DISEASE I'M NOT ARE. MANY PLANS
DíAS SURE THERE SO STORE WITH
THEIR- OR THEIR THEIR FAMILY.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
CRACKS A KIDS FALLING THROUGH
AND SO ONE OF THE PROPOSALS WE
HEAR TODAY FOR THAT. DISTANCE
LEARNING. SOME AS WELL AS
FOCUSING ON THE LEARNING LOSS-
REALITIES THROUGHOUT OUR-
SCHOOL SYSTEM OF SIX MILLION
CALIFORNIA KIDS IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. YOU KNOW THE BIG
ISSUE WE HAVE TO FACE IS THE
REVENUE PIECE I KNOW THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS- IS
SOMEHOW PER TRAINING THIS IS
HOLDING SCHOOLS HARMLESS AND I
THINK WE NEED TO HAVE A REALITY
CHECK AS FAR AS WHAT THAT MEANS
BECAUSE- WE OPEN UP OR
SCHOOLS- YOU KNOW SCHOOLS AND A
MASTERS IN TEACHERS ARE GOING
TO BE ASKED TO DO MORE.
ESSENTIALLY WOULD LAST AND
THEY'RE GONNA BE TRANSFORM TO
BOTH TEACHERS AS WELL AS FIRST
RESPONDERS AND SO WE NEED TO
HAVE. A TOUGH CONVERSATION AS
FAR AS WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS.
WE KNOW THAT THIS BUDGET IS
PREDICATED ON HAVING ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- BUT WE NEED TO HAVE
A REALITY CHECK ON WHAT THAT
MEANS AS WELL AND IF THAT
DOESN'T COME THROUGH. WHAT IS
TRIGGER- CATS- WILL MEAN FOR
CALIFORNIA IN OUR SCHOOLS FOR
OUR QUE SCHOOLS WELL AS EARLY
EDUCATION. CALIFORNIA AND- AND
ONE THING WE REALLY NEED TO
KEEP ASKING OURSELVES IS AND
THIS IS TO THE GOVERNOR AND
EVERYBODY THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WHAT'S OUR PLAN B. I KNOW THE
LEADERS IN IN THE U. S. SENATE.
ARE NOT TO OP ARE NOT TO-
EXCITED ABOUT HAVING. A SECOND
ROUND OF MONEY'S GOING OUT TO
STATES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. AND
WORK COUNTING ON THIS TO
BALANCE OUR STATE BUDGET BUT IF
THAT. DOESN'T HAPPEN. WHAT'S
OUR PLAN B. AS FAR AS
ADDITIONAL REVENUES THAT MEAN.
AND THE BALLOT MEASURES FOR
TAXES I MEAN. WE DID DURING THE
SORTS **** MINISTRATION A
DEFICIT REVENUE BOND- THE
BOTTOM LINE IS. HAVING THESE-
CONEY THAT'S TO OUR LOOK AT
PATIENTS GEN. FOR IT CAMPER CAN
RECOVERY WE NEED REAL. TAKE
DEBT ON THOSE. WELL AT. I'M
NOT. TALKING TODAY IN WITH THAT.
WE WILL BE. TO HEARING. OKAY SO
I JUST BASED OFF LIKE THIS TO
HAPPEN SO I'M BEING TOLD WE'RE
HAVING A TECHNICAL BREAK DOWN
ON SOON WE NEED TO PAUSE THE
HEARING UNTIL THE ISSUE IS
RESOLVED. SO WERE THINKING IT'S
GOING TO BE A FIVE MINUTE TIME
OUT. OKAY SO WE WILL. THAT WILL
TAKE A BREAK FOR A FEW MINUTES
OKAY.
WE'RE TESTING OR NOT BACK
ALIVE AGAIN WE'RE JUST DOING A
TEST TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
EQUIPMENT IS WORKING. TEST TEST
TEST. ALL GOOD.
OTHER HELLO
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR WE'RE
CHECKING TO SEE IF YOU ARE WITH
US RIGHT NOW. YES I AM. OKAY.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT WE WILL- START
AGAIN WOULD START BY CALLING
THE ROLE. MCCARTY HERE. FROM
HERE GALLAGHER. LIMóN MEDINA
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL. OKAY WE
ARE GOING TO. HAVE A LITTLE IT
OF A DIFFERENT- PRACTICE HERE
WITH THESE HEARINGS AS OPPOSED
TO PRIOR YEARS TO THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS- WE DON'T
HAVE AN AGENDA OF LISTED ITEMS
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. THE LA-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE COVERT GO
OVER THE ENTIRE IN THE REVISED
PROPOSALS AND THEN WE'LL HAVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
THE PHONE- PARTICIPATING IN THE
FUN. AT THE DIVERSITY ACTION IS
IN THE SAME ROOM WITH OKAY THEY
ARE HERE AS WELL- TO BE
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AS WELL.
AND THEN WE WILL HAVE THE
MEMBERS ENGAGE ON THE K. TWELVE
ISSUES- AND THEN WE'LL GET TO
THAT EARLY EDUCATION CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL PIECE- NEXT WITH THAT
WE'RE GONNA ASK EDGAR CABRAL
WITH THE LA GO TO WALK THROUGH
THE GOVERNOR'S TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND MAYBE AS
BUDGET FOR THIS. GOOD
AFTERNOON- THE TERM MEMBER OF
THE GROUP OF ALTERNATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WOULD BE A-
LOT. IF CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN GO AHEAD AT HER. YES THERE
ARE THERE WAS A HAND OUT WE
PARTICULAR HANDOUT THAT I
BELIEVE I WILL SHARE WITH YOU
ALL I'M THAT I USED TO GO OVER
THE MAJOR ELEMENTS OF THE NAY
REVISION FOR KIDS OFTEN EARLY
EDUCATION. AND OF OUR OUR BOTH
OUR PART WITH OUR K. TWELVE
COMMENTS IN A POP AND THEN.
PROCEED OUT GET EDGAR COULD YOU
JUST ONE SECOND WE CAN'T HEAR
YOU TO ALSO NOT SURE IF IT'S
YOU AND YOUR MIKE OR IF IT'S US
THE TO TURN IT UP SO CAN YOU.
THEY BIGELOW CLOSER. AS WELL.
YEAH I MEAN IT LOOKS. OKAY OUT
HOW THE RIGHT NOW. A LITTLE
BETTER. WHAT WILL ASK THAT WE
ADJUST THE VOLUME AS WELL GO
AHEAD. OKAY GREAT SO- I WILL
BEGIN WALKING THROUGH THE HAND
OUT ON COVERING THE K. TWELVE
EDUCATION ISSUES FIRST- MOVING
ON THE ON- PAGE ONE WE HAVE. I
JUST FIRST THE OVERALL CHANGES
IN PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT TO
GIVE YOU SOME- BIG PICTURE
SENSE OF WHAT'S GOING ON FROM
JANUARY TO MAY REVISION- SO YOU
CAN SEE ON ON PAGE WHAT WE HAVE
A CHART KASHER SHOWING THE
JANUARY FUNDING LEVELS POSTED
THE MAYOR VERSION FROM THE
LEVEL. OVERALL THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED DOWN SEVENTEEN POINT
FIVE NIGHT. AT AT YOUR YOU TIME
I REAL. WHERE WERE HAVE. SOME
CHALLENGES WITH THE AUDIO. HAVE
OF PAPER OR SOMETHING LIKE
TALKING. YEAH. IS THERE ANY
BETTER NOW MUCH BETTER. OKAY I
SEE OKAY I THINK AN OLD SCRIPT
OKAY YEAH THERE WAS THERE WAS A
FOR THE GOT STRUCK THE OKAY.
BETTER NOW YEP PERFECT GO HEAD
OKAY. OKAY SO I'M ARE JUST
AGAIN ON PAGE ONE WE WALKED
THROUGH THE THERE ARE SEVENTEEN
AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS- IN
OUR CHANGES IN THE REVISION
OVER THE THREE YEAR PERIOD BUT
THEN THE BUDGET- MOST OF THAT
IS IN THE IS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
AND THIS IS DRIVEN BY CHANGES
IN GENERAL FUND REVENUE
PRIMARILY- GIVEN THAT THE STATE
NOW HAS ENTERED INTO A
RECESSION. THE I WOULD KNOW
ALSO THAT THE ADMINISTRATION-
MAY REVISION INCLUDES BOUT
FOUR AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW REVENUES SO THOSE ALSO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE ABSENT THOSE REVENUES
TO GUARANTEE WOULD BE EVEN
LOWER. SO THAT THAT'S THE
OVERALL PROP NINETY EIGHT
NUMBERS- I KNOW YOU'LL TALK
ABOUT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TOMORROW IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION HEARING. SO WHAT WILL
FOCUS ON THE K. TWELVE-
SPENDING LEVEL RIGHT NOW- PROP
NINETY FUNDING IT DOWN FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS OVER THE THREE
YEAR PERIOD- MOST OF THAT
TWELVE BILLION IS IN OUR IN THE
BUDGET YEAR. AND THAT'S THOSE
ARE VERY BIG REDUCTIONS YEAR
OVER YEAR- AMONG THE BIGGER
REDUCTION PROBABLY THAT WE'VE
EVER SEEN A PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT- THIS YEAR IN THE BUDGET-
THERE ARE A LOT OF OTHER THINGS
OUTSIDE OF PROP NINETY. THAT
ARE- AFFECTING SCHOOL FUNDING
AND SO- I DID WANT TO TALK%
ABOUT SOME OF THOSE TO GIVE A
BIGGER PICTURE SENSE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON- THERE ARE- A COUPLE
MERE VISION
SOME OF THE REDUCTIONS IN
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. THE
FIRST IS THAT. THERE IS
SUBSTANTIAL FEDERAL FUNDING
THOSE FIVE POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING THAT
ARM WILL BE PROVIDED TO. OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT'S
AVAILABLE TO HELP ME TO GET
SOMEBODY'S REDUCTIONS. ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE BILLION OF THOSE
ARE REDUCTIONS THAT ARE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION IF FUNDING
THAT IS PROVIDED FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THROUGH A
FORMULA AND THIS IS ONE OF THE
MANY PARTS OF FUNDING THAT WERE
IN THE FEDERAL. EXACT THIS IS
WHAT AT THE TO BE BECOME A
PROBLEM FOR ME ALSO THERE'S NOT
A LOT OF IF THEY CAN DO TO
CONTROL IT. ON THIS IS FUNDING
THAT THAT THEY'RE RECEIVING ARE
BASED ON THAT FEDERAL- FEDERAL
LAW. BUT THE REMAINING ARM
FUNDING THAT'S IN THE MIRROR
VISION IS THE- CHOICE BY THE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE THESE.
OF A FIVE TO SCHOOL DOUBLE TALK
ABOUT THOSE IN A LITTLE BIT
MORE DETAIL LATER. RIGHT
PROGRAMMATIC CUTS THERE ARE
FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PAYMENT DEFERRALS
AND- WHEN THESE ARE IMPLEMENTED
FOR SCHOOL THE TYPICALLY MEANS
THAT THEY- CAN GO BORROW OR IF
THEY HAVE CASH ON HAND THEY
COULD COVER THEIR COSTS. I'M IN
THE SHORT RUN WALL THEY'RE
WAITING FOR IT. TO COME BUT
THEY'VE TYPICALLY NOT RESULTED
IN A FAIRLY- A PROGRAMMATIC
CUTS TO SCHOOLS. ON PAGE THREE
HERE WE HAVE A CHART THAT KIND
OF. PUT ALL THOSE THINGS
TOGETHER IT SHOWS YOU WHAT
OVERALL FUNDING IS FROM YEAR TO
YEAR. WHEN YOU CONSIDER THESE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING SOURCES
FUNDING IS ROUGHLY FLAT- FOR
OUR KIDS OVER THE KITCHEN IF
YOU IF YOU INCLUDE THOSE OTHER
PARTS OF FUNDING. AND ACCOUNT
FOR THE FACT THAT THERE ARE.
PAYMENT DEFERRALS. I'M THE
OTHER THING THAT THAT WE WERE
NOTED THAT THERE IS A ANOTHER
MAJOR NON PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND PROPOSAL. ON
RELATED. RELATED TO PENSION
READY FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND THIS IS
NOT. THE NEW AUGMENTATION TO
FOODS ARE TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET ACT- THIS WAS IN
AN- INTENSELY. ARE ARE
INITIALLY INTENDED TO BE A
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATION. I
WAS GONNA GO TOWARDS PAYING
DOWN- THE LONG TERM UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES FOR THE PENSION
SYSTEMS. WHICH WOULD REDUCE ALL
OVER A TWENTY OR THIRTY YEAR
PERIOD- CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
INSTEAD THE PROPOSAL TO TAKE
BOTH FUNDAMENT THAT- PROVIDE
THOSE FUNDS ARE. TO PROVIDE
RELIEF FOR OUR- TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SO
CONTRIBUTION RATES WOULD BE
DECREASING AS A RESULT. SO
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
OVERALL BIG PICTURE OF WHAT'S
GOING ON- MUCH MORE THAN WHAT
GRANTED PROP NINETY EIGHT- I
DON'T WANT TO WALK THROUGH SOME
OF THE MAJOR PROBLEM ANY
CHANGES JUST SO THAT YOU HAVE
A- SENSE OF WHAT THOSE- THOSE
BIG MOVIE PIECES ARE- FIRST.
THE ADMINISTRATION KRISTEN'S
ABOUT ONE POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS IN AUGMENTATIONS EVER
PROVOKE PROPOSED IN JANUARY.
MOST OF THOSE WERE ONE TIME-
PROPOSALS FROM RELATED TO
EDUCATE YOUR EDUCATION
WORKFORCE INITIATIVES OTHERS-
RELATED TO ADDRESSING THE
JAMAICA. ONE NOTABLE PROPOSAL
BUT STILL IN THE MERE VISION IS
SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO INCREASE THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING
RIGHTS. THE MAIN REASON ALSO
INCLUDES A SIX POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION TO THE
HEALTHY PFAFF- THIS IS- A 10%
ACROSS THE BOARD REDUCTION SO
ACT- EVERY DISTRICTS OF THE IF
OF OUR KITCHEN WITH DECREASED
BY ABOUT 10% AMOUNT- ENTIRELY
CONSIST OF TWO PARTS ONE PIECE
OF THAT IS ACTUALLY. ARE JUST
NOT PROVIDING THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT IT'S REQUIRED
UNDER STATUTE AND THEN THE REST
WOULD BE ARE A REDUCTION THAT'S
BEYOND THE CURRENT ARE NINETEEN
TWENTY LEVELS. I'M THEN THERE
ARE THE PAYMENT TO FOR ALL THAT
I DISCUSSED EARLIER THEY ADD UP
TO FIVE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN UNDER SOME
REDUCTIONS THE CATEGORICAL
PROGRAMS. THAT THE TWO MOST
NOTABLE THERE ARE REDUCTIONS
TO. THE CORRECT TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS TOTALING
HUNDRED MILLION THIS IS CUTTING
THOSE PROGRAMS BY ROUGHLY HALF.
I'M AMANDA REDUCTION TO THE
AFTER SCHOOL EDUCATION FIFTY
PROGRAM BY A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH WOULD BRING IT
DOWN TO THE MINIMUM UP IT'S
REQUIRED. BY STATUTE- AS AS WAS
THAT AND ACTED IN PROPOSITION
FORTY NINE. ALL OF THOSE
PROGRAMMATIC REDUCTIONS ARE
OUR- ARE ARE. SUBJECT TO THESE
WHICH TRIGGERED LANGUAGE THAT
IS IN THE MAYOR VISION AND IT'S
IN VARIOUS PARTS OF BURKE. ARE
A VERY. DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE
BUDGET- SUCH THAT IF THERE WAS
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING. ARE
PROVIDED THEM THESE CUTS WOULD
NOT NECESSARILY OCCUR. THE
BALLOT THAT APPLIES TO THE CITY
PROGRAMS AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
AND TO BE A FIFTH OF PRODUCTION
NOT THE PAYMENT FOR. ON THE
NEXT PAGE- WE COVER- THE ONE
TIME FEDERAL FUNDING THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED- THAT THE FIRST-
BIGGEST PART OF FUNDING IS FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION THAT'S FOR
LEARNING LOST MEDICATION. AND
THIS IS- COME FROM TWO SOURCES-
TWO DIFFERENT FUNDS IN THE
CARRIAGE ACT LEGISLATION ITSELF
THERE'S FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THE CROWN OF OURS RELIEF
FUND. THIS IS- THAT THAT
PROVIDES RELIEF FUND THE STATE
IS RECEIVING NINE POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS- OF FOUR UP
FROM FROM THE FUNDING THE FUNDS
YOU TO BE USED BY THE END OF
THE CALENDAR YEAR- THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS CHOSEN TO
PROVIDE FOR ABOUT NINE POINT
FOUR BILLION TO SCHOOLS. FROM
THE OTHER- EIGHT. THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY. THE EDUCATION FUND THIS
IS A PART OF FUNDING WAS. THAT
THE STATE HAS TECH YOU CAN FOR
KIDS OR HIGHER EDUCATION. AND
THE MANY REVIEWS. ARE PROVIDES
ALL OF IT SCHOOLS THIS ARE
LEARNING OFF MEDICATION
PROPOSAL. THE FUNDING FOR A-
BURNING LOVE MEDICATION WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED- ACCORDING TO TWO
DIFFERENT COMPONENTS ONE. AT TO
PROVIDE OUR IS IT IS A FORM
THAT'S PROVIDED BASED ON
WHETHER OR NOT A DISTRICT
RECEIVES A FEE IF OF
CONCENTRATION GRANTS SO. IF YOU
GET OF THE IF OF CONCENTRATION
GRANTS BUT YOU WOULD GET A FOR
PEOPLE AMOUNT FOR ALL OF YOUR
STUDENTS- AND THAT'S A TWO
POINT NINE BILLION OUT OF THE
FOUR POINT FOUR. THEN THERE ONE
POINT FIVE BILLION THAT IS
DISTRICTS BASED ON THE NUMBER
OF SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
ACROSS THE STATE. CAN BE USED
FOR A VARIETY OF ACTIVITIES
THAT- DIRECTLY HELP WITH-
IMPROVING STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT
OR MITIGATING LEARNING LOSS DUE
TO SCHOOL CLOSURES- AS A RESULT
OF THE OUT OF THE COMA NINETEEN
A BREAK. ARE MET AND AS A
RESULT SCHOOL CLOSURES- DARK.
THAT THERE ARE A VARIETY OF
WAYS THAT DISTRICTS CAN SPEND
IT IT CAN BE TO EXTEND THE
SCHOOL YEAR- TO PROVIDE MORE
AND SERVICES TO PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL ACADEMIC SUPPORT- IT
WOULD BE UP TO OUR VALUES TO
DECIDE. THEY DO JUST HAVE TO-
ADOPTEE. COUNTY AND
INSTRUCTIONAL CONTINUITY PLAN
THAT DESCRIBES HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO USE THE FUNDS. HOW
INSURE THAT DEVICES ALSO COULD
HAVE DID NOT DEVICES THE
CONNECTIVITY AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO MEASURE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THESE ACTIONS.
SO THAT'S THE BIGGEST PART OF
FUNDING THE NEXT THERE THERE IS
ONE POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS
IN. ONE TIME FUNDING THAT WAS
ALSO IN THE CARRIAGE ACT ONE
POINT- ONE POINT FIVE BILLION
IS THE- THE SOURCE I MENTIONED
EARLIER TO BE DISTRIBUTED BY
FORMULA BE FROM THE FEDERAL
TITLE ONE FORMULA. I'M DOUBLE
GOAL TO SCHOOLS DIRECTLY AND
THEN THERE'S A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
THAT IS OUR- OF THE LEGISLATION
ALLOWS STATES TO KEEP UP 210%
OF THIS FUNDING- SO THAT IT
COULD BE USED FOR SOME STATE
LEVEL ACTIVITIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S NEAR VISION.
INCLUDES SOME OF PROPOSALS FOR
USING NOT FIND THE BIGGEST IS A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR A
COMMUNITY SCHOOLS GRANT. AND
THEN THERE'S ABOUT SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS THAT ARE FOR
READY PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
ACTIVITY. ONE OTHER PIECE THAT
IN THE MERE VISION IS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS- IN ONETIME CHILD
NUTRITION FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO I WOULD
POINT OUT HERE THAT THIS IS A
FINDING THAT THERE IS VIRTUALLY
NO GUIDANCE FROM- THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AS TO HOW THIS
FUNDING CAN BE SPENT SO AT THIS
POINT IT'S UNCLEAR. WHAT
EXACTLY THE FUNDS CAN BE USED
FOR BUT THE MERE BUSINESS
INCLUDE THE APPROPRIATION OF
FORTY FOUR HOLES FUNDS. SUCH
THAT IF THE STATE WERE TO GET
GUIDANCE THAT THAT THE MONEY
COULD BE DISTRIBUTED DURING THE
FISCAL YEAR. WE GOT TO THE NEXT
AGE TO PAGE SIX- I DID ARM. ON
TALK ABOUT THIS IS A MULTI OR
A- FUTURE YOUR ISSUE THIS IS
NOT RELATED TO THE BUT YEAR BUT
THERE IS SOME. ARE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT PROPOSES TO MAKE
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS TO
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN FUTURE YEARS- THIS WILL
CREATE A MULTI YOUR OBLIGATION.
TO PAY THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS- TO SCHOOLS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ABOUT THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- GUARANTEE. AND IT
WOULD BE- THE WAY THAT THOSE.
PAYMENTS WOULD BE MADE AT THE
BEGINNING OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO. THE STATE WOULD PROVIDE A
ONE POINT 5% OF GENERAL FUND
REVENUES- AND THEY COULD BE
USED FOR ANY PURPOSE AFFECT.
OUR PROP NINETY FUNDING ISSUES
RIGHT NOW. I'M IN THE LONG RUN
AND THE STATE WOULD INCREASE
THE STATE- BUT SHARE OF GENERAL
FUND. THAT GOES TO OUR OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ARE TO
SCHOOL THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
FROM THIRTY PERCENT. TO FORTY
PERCENT- SO RIGHT. WE TALK
ABOUT OFTEN PROP INDEED IT
BEING- 40% OF GENERAL REVENUES.
IN REALITY BECAUSE OF A VARIETY
OF SHIFT THAT WE- NEED- RELATED
PROPERTY TAXES. IT'S ACTUALLY
30% RIGHT NOW THAT WOULD GO TO
THAT'S ABOUT A TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS ON GO ON GOING
INCREASE- TO THE PROPERTY
PLEASE. I'M SUCH THE COVER OF
OUR COME. ON OF PROPOSALS THE
FIRST THING THAT WE WOULD
EMPHASIZE THAT THINK- MISTER
CHAIR MENTIONED THIS A LITTLE
BIT IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS.
THAT THE PACKAGE DOES NOT
ADDRESS ANY A POSSIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL CLOSURES OR POTENTIAL
DELAYS IN THE SCHOOL YEAR- WHEN
THE ACADEMIC YEAR OPENS AND WE
THINK THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THAT THE LEADS THAT YOU
WANT TO ADDRESS AND THAT
HOPEFULLY END UP OF A BUDGET IN
JUNE. WILL HAVE SOME GETTING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICT ABOUT WITH WHAT
IS TO OCCUR. WHEN THE- WHEN THE
OUTBREAK OCCURRED SCHOOL
STARTED TO CLOSE- THERE WAS AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND LET
LEGISLATURE DID IT PASSED SB
ONE SEVENTEEN. WHICH ARE THERE
A NUMBER OF THINGS TO PROVIDE-
FISCAL CERTAINTY FOR DISTRICTS.
IT ESSENTIALLY- HELD HARMLESS
DISTRICTS- AFTER THEIR
ATTENDANCE IN THIS YEAR BY
STOPPING ATTENDANCE COUNTING
AFTER FEBRUARY TWENTY NINTH.
AND IT ALSO- ABOUT. SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO OFFER A- IT'S YEAR
THAT WERE LEFT IN A NEEDED. AT
ANIMAL. RIGHT NOW UNDER CURRENT
LAW IF YOU DON'T HAVE A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SCHOOL YEAR YOU ARE
SUBJECT TO PENALTIES AND YOU
LOSE SOME FUNDING. RIGHT NOW
THERE IS NO PROPOSAL TO EXTEND
THAT FLEXIBILITY. BUT ALSO
NOTHING THAT BAD- REPLACES THEM
WE THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT. FOR
PROVIDING FOR THE CERTAINTY TO
DISTRICT BUT ALSO- BECAUSE WE
DO THINK THAT THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE TO IF YOU'RE
STARTING FROM- ACT MISSIONS FOR
WHAT FUNDING WOULD BE TWELFTH
OF THAT THE NEXT PETITIONS FOR
WHAT STUDENT LEARNING WOULD BE
IN THE EVENT OF CULTURES-
BECAUSE THINGS HAPPEN SO FAST-
IN MARCH WHEN WE MAKE THOSE
CULTURES THERE WAS NOT A LOT OF
CLARITY. ON SOME SPECIFIC
AGENTS FOR OUR FOR SCHOOLS. NOW
MOVES TO OUR NEXT A THIRD OF A
COMMENTS RELATED TO THE
CONTINUITY PLANS WE THINK THAT
THIS. IS AN IS THERE A
DISCONTINUITY PLAN TO BE A GOOD
PLACE TO. SET SOME OF THOSE
CORRECT PETITIONS. I'M SO FOR
EXAMPLE THAT THE CONTINUITY
PLANS RIGHT NOW. SPECIFY HOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SPEND THE
FUNDING BUT WE WOULD- RECOMMEND
YOU ADDING SOME MORE SPECIFIC
REQUIREMENTS LIKE SUGGESTED
WHAT IS THE PLAN. IF SCHOOLS
WERE TO CLOSE- WHAT WOULD BE
THE PLAN FOR ENSURING THAT
THERE IS CONNECTIVITY FOR
STUDENTS AT HOME- HOW WOULD-
LEDS MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT HOW
TO BEST SERVE FOR EXAMPLE. A
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENT OR
OTHER STUDENTS WHO ARE. I'M I
NEED AND- A LITTLE BIT MORE
CHALLENGES AS WE- MOVE TO A
DISTANCE LEARNING DURING THIS
YEAR. A MEETING THAT THAT THIS
WOULD BE A PLACE TO SET THE
MODELS REQUIREMENTS. I'M THE
OTHER THING WE HAVE SOME TIME
FOR THE WAY THAT THAT FUNDING
IS DISTRIBUTED. PATHETICALLY
CONCENTRATION GRANT APPROACH-
SO ON THE WAY THAT IT WORKS-
CONSTRUCTION AND THRESHOLD IF
THE- FIVE. YEARS. POPULATION
BEING LOW INCOME OR- ORDER AND-
THAT THIS ARE. FUNDING IS THIS
IS IT'S A TO BE DISTRIBUTED. IN
YOU GET FIFTY SIX PER. IF 6%
YOUR STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH
RESERVED INCOME. THEN AS OF.
YOU WOULD GET PER PEEP. FUNDING
AMOUNT. BECAUSE YOUR BONTA COME.
THRESHOLD BUT IF YOU HAVE 53%
OF YOUR STUDENTS WHO ARE-
ENGLISHMEN AS OUR LOW INCOME
YOU WILL GET NOTHING. AND WE
THINK THAT CREATES TOO MUCH OF
A- SORT OF A SORT OF A- EITHER
OR EITHER YOU GET OUT. OF ARE A
LOT OF FUNDING OR YOU DON'T GET
ANYTHING AND WE THINK. OUR
APPROACH TO PROVIDE A MORE
SMOOTHER- FUNDING ACROSS
DISTRICTS BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING
A DIFFERENCE IS THE NEED IS TO
DISTRIBUTE FUNDING BASED ON.
THE PERCENTAGE OF A DISTRICTS
POP- STATEWIDE CHAIR OF YELLOW
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS. I'M A
COUPLE OF OTHER THINGS THAT WE
WOULD- JUST MENTIONED ONE IS
THAT THERE YOU COULD PURSUE
ADDITIONAL- BUT TARGETED
REDUCTIONS ARM IN LIEU OF SOME
OF THE- LARGER OFF THE FIFTH
CUTS TO MITIGATE THOSE
REDUCTIONS. FOR EXAMPLE THERE
ARE SOME ADAMS WITHIN THE HOUR
THE FACT THAT ARE DISTRIBUTED-
BASED ON HISTORICAL REASONS NOT
FOR ANY CLEAR POLICY PURPOSES
SUCH AS THE MINIMUM STEADY
PROVISION- THAT ARE IF YOU WERE
TO REDUCE THAT YOU. IF YOU
COULD ELIMINATE THAT AND SAY
NOT- HAVE AS BIG OF AN OFF THE
IF A PRODUCTION. I'M THE OTHER
THING THAT WE WITH A RECOMMEND
REJECTING THE PROPOSED
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT PLAN. I
THINK WE DO HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT- JUST LOCKING IN THE
STATES ARE. A SPENDING AT THIS
POINT- THERE'S NOTHING RIGHT
NOW TO PREVENT THE LEGISLATURE
FOR PROVIDING MORE FUNDING THAN
THAT PROP NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEE REQUIRES- WE WOULD WE
WOULD SUGGEST THAT THE MESSAGE
YOU WANT TO DO THAT. IT COULD
IT COULD DO SO M. BUT I CAN
MAKE THAT DECISION OF PART OF
NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET TO THE- TO
THE NORTH. EARLY ON THE SIDE
AND- WITH STRUCTURE WOULD BE
FOR THE NEXT OUR. THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS. SO THOSE ARE MY-
COMMENTS ON KEYBOARD YOU. ALSO
THE THIRTY FIRST. OKAY YOU WERE
GOING TO HOLD ON. FROM YOU AT
EDGAR AND ASKED THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO PRESENT AND GO
OVER SOME OF THE MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS. I AM HERE I'M NOT
SURE IF I'M IF I'M SHOWING ON
THE VIDEO SCREEN UP BUT THERE
AND OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON AMBER
ALEXANDER WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE- THE LA- ALREADY
COVERED AND SOME OF THE KEY
TENANTS OF THE- GOVERNOR'S ME
REVISION BUT OFTEN TOUCH ON A
COUPLE OF THE KEY PIECES. THE
ECONOMY HAS CHANGED DRASTICALLY
SINCE THE GOVERNOR FIRST PUT
OUT THE BUDGET IN JANUARY.
WE'RE CURRENTLY IN THE MIDST OF
AN UNPRECEDENTED ECONOMIC
EMERGENCY AND A PACKAGE OF
EDUCATION PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD
AND THE MAJOR REVISION. REFLECT
AND REFLECT THE FACT IN IS ALSO
INTENDED TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN PROVIDING AT LEAST WITH
THE FACT FLEXIBILITY TO MEET
THE CHALLENGES DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PRIORITY FOR
EDUCATION INCLUDE A STRONG
FOCUS ON EQUITY FOR VULNERABLE
STUDENTS. STABILITY OF CORE
INSTRUCTIONAL PROGRAMS.
MITIGATING LEARNING MORE AND
SUPPORTING SCHOOLS THROUGH THIS
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. TO THIS END
THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A ONE TIME INVESTMENT
OF FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS. TO LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO ADDRESS LEARNING
LOSS AS A RESULT OF THE COVERT
NINETEEN SCHOOL CLOSURES. AT
THE LA- MENTIONED BE FUNDS
COULD BE USED FOR A VARIETY OF
PURPOSES INCLUDING X. AND
EXTENDING THE INSTRUCTIONAL I'M
HERE. PROVIDING ACADEMIC AND
SUPPORT SERVICES FOR PEOPLE
PROVIDING AN ADDITIONAL
INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIALS ARE
DEVICES AND ACTIVITY FOR THE
STUDENTS AS WELL. THE
METHODOLOGY THAT THE LA DA
ELLIE- DESCRIBED IS INTENDED TO
TARGET- THESE FUNDS TOWARDS
ALLEY ELEAZAR WOULD BE MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS. NAMELY
THOSE- WITH LARGE POPULATIONS
OF FOSTER YOUTH ENGLISH
LEARNERS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES.
ADDITIONALLY CALIFORNIA
RECEIVES ONE POINT SIX BILLION
AND FEDERAL ELEMENTARY AND
SECONDARY SCHOOL EMERGENCY
RELIEF FUNDS. OF THIS AMOUNT
90% WILL BE PROVIDED TO ELEAZAR
BASED ON TERROR TITLE ONE
ALLOCATION. THE REMAINING 10%
WILL BE AVAILABLE FOR STATE
LEVEL ACTIVITIES INCLUDING A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR GRANTS TO
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION. TO
DEVELOP NETWORK THE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS AND COORDINATE- HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR HIGH NEED STUDENTS.
SIXTY THREE POINT TWO MILLION
FOR TRAINING AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
PERSONNEL. AT ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR STATE OPERATION
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THE CLUB
IN NINETEEN RESPONSE. AS NOTED
IN THE ALEJO'S PRESENTATION THE
REDUCTION IN THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM GUARANTEED
WHEN COMBINED WITH THAT FOR A
TECHNICAL CHANGES GREAT THE
FUNDING FOR FALL OF FIFTEEN
POINT ONE BILLION FOR K. TWELVE
SCHOOL. OF OVER THREE PERIOD. A
PARTIALLY ADDRESSED THE FOR ALL
THE MAJOR VERSION PROPOSES TO
WITHDRAW SEVERAL OF THE POLICY
PROPOSAL FOR THE GOVERNOR PUT
FORWARD IN JANUARY.
ADDITIONALLY TO HELP DISTRICTS
MAINTAIN SOME LEVEL OF FISCAL
STABILITY DURING THIS TRYING
TIME. THE MAYOR VISION PROPOSES
TO DEFER ONE POINT NINE BILLION
IN PRINCIPLE OF FORTUNATE
PAYMENTS FROM JUNE TWENTY
NINETEEN TO JULY TWENTY TWENTY.
AN ADDITIONAL THREE POINT FOUR
BILLION IS ADDED TO THIS MOUNT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE FOR A
TOTAL OF FIVE POINT THREE
BILLION AN APARTMENT THE PEARL
SCHEDULED FOR PAYMENT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THE BUDGETARY
SHORTFALL AND A LINE FUNDING
WITH THE NEW FISCAL REALITY THE
MAYOR OF IT'S AN PROPOSES TO
REDUCE FUNDING FOR THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA BY TEN
PERCENT. OR ROUGHLY SIX POINT
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. ANY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. THIS PRODUCTION AND POST
ELIMINATION OF A TWO POINT 31%
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT.
FINALLY THE MAYOR VISION ALSO
INCLUDES PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT REDUCTIONS TO SEVERAL QUE
FIVE CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS IN
ORDER TO FURTHER LIMIT HAVING
TO MEET FACE REDUCTIONS TO THE
OF THE ATTACK. ADMINISTRATION
IS COMMITTED TO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH LEGISLATURE TO
PASS A BALANCED BUDGET TO
PROVIDE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES WITH FLEXIBILITY IS TO
HELP NAVIGATE THESE DIFFICULT
TIME. I HAVE WITH ME- SEVERAL
COLLEAGUES HERE IN THE ROOM
THAT CAN ANSWER SOME OF THE
MORE TECHNICAL QUESTIONS YOU
HAVE ON THE VARIOUS PROPOSALS
AND WE ARE HAPPY TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU MISS ALEXANDER- WE
ALSO HAVE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. STEPHANIE GREG SAN.
IS SHE GOING TO PRESENTER. OKAY
SHE'S HERE JUST ANSWER
QUESTIONS BUT JUST WANNA
CONFIM YOUR THERE HE THERE
STEPHANIE. CHAIR MCCARTY AND I
ALSO ACTUALLYHAVE SOME REMARKS
IF YOU WOULD ALLOW YES PLEASE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GREAT THANK
YOU SO GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE STEPPING GRAYSON
CHIEF DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION FOR
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US HERE TODAY. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS IS AND I'M
PRESIDENTE MOMENT IN CALIFORNIA
AND WORLD HITCHED HISTORY WHICH
HAS LED TO A DISASTROUS IMPACT
ON THE STATE'S ECONOMY. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S WORK
TO KEEP EDUCATION FUNDING AND
CHANGE DURING THE CURRENT YEAR
DESPITE THE DROP IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM COULD
GUARANTEE. WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
15% INCREASE PROPOSED TO THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION PER EIGHTY A
RATE ALTHOUGH WE BELIEVE IT
SHOULD BE BUILT INTO THE
EXISTING FUNDING STRUCTURE WE
FURTHER APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR HAS SHOWN TO
ADDRESS THE NEW REALITY CREATED
BY THE NINETEEN. EIGHTY FOUR
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL FUNDS TO K. TWELVE
EDUCATION TO ADDRESS LEARNING
LOSS AND OTHER SOCIAL IT. WELL
THE FUNDS WILL HELP ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE NEW COSTS FOR
SCHOOLS ARE SCHOOLS WILL NOT BE
A NEED ALL IN LIGHT OF THE CUTS
PROPOSED IN EDUCATION
PARTICULARLY THOSE CUTS TO THE
ALTHEA PFAFF. THAT RICK INTO
THE LC. IT IS SIGNIFICANT. IN
OF ITSELF HOWEVER IT MUST BE
WEIGHED IN THE OF THE INCREASED
COST TOOLS. WE CAN ALL THIS
FROM TO MAKE. THIS RESORT. WILL
IN EACH APPS LARGER CLASS. RE
IN TRANSFER. ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN. AFFORD ARE TO.
ESPECIALLY EPIDEMIC. IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN TO PROTECT AND PRESERVE
LEARNING GOING FORWARD WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH DISTANCE LEARNING
OR HAVING STUDENTS RETURNED TO
SAFE AND CLEAN SCHOOLS. OUR
FOCUS IS TO ENSURE THAT WHEN
SCHOOLS REOPEN STUDENTS
TEACHERS AND ALL SCHOOL
PERSONNEL ARE SAFE AND CONTINUE
TO BE SAFE. THAT INCLUDES
HAVING AVAILABLE PP CLEANING
SUPPLIES THE ABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY SCREEN STUDENTS AND
STAFF AND DEVICES FOR STUDENTS
AND PARENTS THAT NEED TO
CONTINUE WITH DISTANCE
LEARNING. WHEN SCHOOLS REOPENED
WE MAY ALSO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
PRACTICE SOCIAL DISTANCING WE
ALSO HAVE TO PROVIDE TEACHERS
WITH PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
FOR DISTANCE LEARNING AND
ENSURE THEY ARE COMFORTABLE AND
PREPARED FOR THE NEW AND VARIED
APPROACHES TO TEACHING. THESE
MEASURES ILLUSTRATE THE COMPLEX
UNDERTAKING AND THE BEST MATE
NEEDED TO ENSURE WE CAN SAFELY
RE OPENED SCHOOLS WHICH WE ALSO
KNOW IT'S CRUCIAL TOWARDS EACH
AFTER. TO RE OPEN THE MONEY FOR
WORKING FAMILIES. OUR TOP
PRIORITY MUST BE BOTH IN STATE
OF OUR STUDENTS STOP. BURNING
FIRST. STOPS IN WE MUST
REMEMBER THAT WE ARE NOT JUST.
TO MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO WITH
LESS FUNDING WE'RE ASKING
SCHOOLS TO DO EVEN MORE WITH
MUCH LESS. WHEN THIS PANDEMIC
STARTED SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN
FORM SEVERAL TASK FORCES IN
MEMBERS FROM BOTH HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS THE
CHANGES IN EDUCATION. THE TASK
FORCE FOCUSED ON CLOSING THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE IS WORKING TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH DEVICES
AND WIFI ACCESS NEEDED TO
CONTINUE LEARNING. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS AT LEAST FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND LAPTOPS ARE
DEVICES AND THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND WIFI HOTSPOT TO
CONNECT EVERY STUDENT TO THE
INTERNET AT HOME. WE NEED TO
WORK TOGETHER AND BE CREATIVE
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE EASY
BUT WE ARE ASKING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR LOOK
FOR ALTERNATIVE WAYS TO FIND
EDUCATION AND NOT READ. THE
FUNNY SO DESPERATE NEED OUR
TEAM IS HERE IN THE ROOM. FIVE
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE LA L. IN
C. D. E. ON THE- ON THE BIG
PICTURE- WALK THROUGH OF THE
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS. WENT TO
NOW FOCUS ON THE K. TWELVE
PIECE AND SET ASIDE YOU SEE FIT
FOR A ATER PART OF TODAY'S
HEARING. AND ENGAGE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TO- ASK QUESTIONS ARE
PRESENT- COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS ARE I'M GONNA START
WITH A FEW AND- I'LL START WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THE
MEXICAN TO TAKE THIS OFF
BECAUSE I DO HAVE. THAT PLENTY
OF DISTANCE AND A LITTLE COCK
IN THE MIKE IN FRONT OF US
HERE- I WANT TO ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON THE
OVERALL. BIG PICTURE OF THE-
THE ARCHITECTURE OF THIS OF
THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND THE
TRIGGER CUTS- WHICH WOULD
ESSENTIALLY NOT HAPPENED IF WE
GET THE FEDERAL SUPPORTS IN
THAT SECOND ROUND OF THE- OF
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TRUST AND RESPECT FOR OUR
GREAT. SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE-
WHO OF COURSE HELL SOME
CALIFORNIANS SAN FRANCISCO IN
THE DISTRICT OF OUR BUDGET
CHAIRMAN IS JOINED BY IS TODAY
MR TANG- BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE
DECISION OF THE CONGRESS THE
HOUSE IT'S THE U. S. SENATE.
AND THEY'VE BEEN VERY LOUD SO
FAR SAYING NOT SO FAST. IN SO
WHAT ARE ARE PLANS IF- SENATOR
MCCONNELL AND CREW I DON'T GO
AHEAD AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA
WITH THEIR NEEDS YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT IS OUR PLAN B. DO WE HAVE
A PLAN B. BECAUSE ONE OF THE
CONCERNS I THINK THAT I HAVE
AND THAT I THINK PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE IS THAT
WE SURE WHICH WE'RE TRYING TO
GO THROUGH THIS AND GET AS MUCH
BUT ALL SURPRISE WE CAN. BUT
THE TIMES IT AND SO ONLY THOSE
ARE BUDGET BEGAN IN A FEW
MONTHS BUT IF WE WANT TO PUT
FOR EXAMPLE A MEASURE ON THE
BALLOT A REVENUE MEASURE OR-
DEFICIT REDUCTION BOND LIKE WE
DID FIFTEEN YEARS AGO UNDER
SWARTS IN ANGER THAT DISCUSSION
HAS TO HAPPEN THE SAME TIME AND
THAT NEEDS TO BE THE SEPTEMBER
TRY WRAPPER BUDGET SO
ESSENTIALLY- WHAT IS OUR PLAN
B. FIND A- AMBER SANDERS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. SO THAT
THE PLAN IS WHAT WAS PRESENTED
IN THE MAYOR VISION- THE WAY
THAT THE TRIGGER WORKS IS IT'S
STRUCTURED AS A REVERSE TRIGGER
SO THE FACT THAT YOU SEE IN THE
MIRROR VISION TO THE EXTENT
THAT ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS
ARE ABLE TO BE DRAWN DOWN THOSE
THOSE FEDERAL FUNDS WAY TO WHAT
WE TO THE CUT BUT YOU'RE SEEING
PRESENTED IN A MAJOR REVISION
NOT HAPPENING. THE CUTS AROUND
SIXTY FIVE BILLION- YOU KNOW
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE ONE
OF THE MAIN MAIN CUT- THAT WE
WOULD LIKELY FOCUS THOSE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ON TO THE
EXTENT THEY ARE GOING DOWN I'M
HARPER THERE IS A CONTROL
SECTION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS COORDINATING-
GLOBALLY THAT WILL LAY OUT COME
ABOUT FREE MARK IN THE
MECHANICS OF HOW THAT WOULD
WORK TO THE EXTENT THAT WE
RECEIVED SEVERAL. OKAY I'M SO
QUESTION A AND FOR MISS ALEX.
AND I. I'M CERTAIN THAT YOU ARE.
WHAT I SAYING I KNOW WHAT THE
TRIGGER WOULD MEAN- IF WE DON'T
GET THE DIGITAL FEDERAL MONEY.
BUT WHAT'S THE PLAN B. IF IN
TWO WEEKS. THERE'S A HARD NO
FOR THE UNITED STATES SENATE OR
CONGRESS AND YOU KNOW WHAT.
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL SUPPORT
FOR OURS OUR STATES. AND OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND THERE'S
NO OPTION FOR THE FEDERAL
pMEANS THE TRIGGER CUTS WOULD
WOULD HAPPEN WE GET THAT WHAT
THAT MEANS IN THE CONTROLLING
WHICH THE BUDGET. BT WHAT IS
OUR PLAN B. FROM THE GOVERNOR
AND THE ADMINISTRATION AS FAR
AS LOOKING FOR ANOTHER OPTION.
IS THERE ANOTHER OPTION AS FAR
AS I KNOW. THERE'S SOME- SOME
REVENUE PROPOSALS HE LAID OUT
LAST THURSDAY IN THE MAY REVISE
BUT- IS THERE A THOUGHT ABOUT-
LOOKING AT A PLAN B. YOUR PLAN
SEE- POTENTIALLY GOING THE
VOTERS TO ASK THEM. TO HELP
MAKE THE TOUGH CHOICE
ESSENTIALLY JERRY BROWN DID%
THIS IN TWENTY TWELVE HE SAID
HEY. VOTERS YOU WANT TO. USE IN
CSU FINDING DOUBLE CALLS-
TUITION CUT SCHOOL FUNDING VOTE
YES FOR PROP THIRTY IN VOTERS
HAD TO MAKE A TOUGH CHOICE AND
THEY MADE THAT CHOICE- WE COULD
POTENTIALLY DO THAT. BUT THAT I
RECALL. WELL WORK IN THE MOTION
TO HAVE. READY TO GO BY. LATE
JUNE EARLY JULY. IS THERE A
PLAN B. A PLAN SEE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
GOVERNOR IF THE FEDERAL MONIES
DO NOT MATERIALIZE. MICHAEL
CONVERSATIONS HAVE NOT STOPPED
NOW THAT THE MAJOR REVISION IS
OUT AND THIS IS A VERY YOU KNOW
FLEXIBLE AND FLUID PROCESS AND
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO ONE
OF MY I'M POLITICS YOU CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT A SPECIFIC HERE
REVENUE. QUESTION. GOOD
AFTERNOON LEADERS AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO- AT
THE AMBER- HAD MENTIONED.
THINGS HAVE BEEN MOVING VERY
FAST AND FURIOUSLY AS YOU CAN
IMAGINE AND THERE'S A LOT OF
PROPOSALS IN ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS GOING OUT THROUGH.
OUT FINANCE AND I'M SURE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE SO MODES A LOT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS ARE HELP OUR
OUTSIDE IF YOU CAN UNITS PER
YOU HAVE PERCENT. TAKE SIX.
MORE INFORMATION ON ANY
CONVERSATIONS WE WOULD HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU. OUT WITH SOME
OTHER INFORMATION FROM OTHER
UNITS. OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
RESPONSE ON. AND I REALIZE IT'S
NOT JUST THE EDUCATION BUDGET
WHICH YOU'RE- CERTAINLY- BEEN
INVOLVED WITH US FOR THE PAST
FEW YEARS ON BUT- A LARGER
STRUCTURAL ISSUE IN
ARCHITECTURE AT THE END. OF
THEIR- CALIFORNIA FISCAL PLAN
SO- BUT WITH THAT I THINK THAT.
WE'LL HEAR LATER FROM THE CHILD
CARE- IMPACT- HIGHER READ
TOMORROW AND WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
FOR OUR CALLS UNIVERSITIES. BUT
THE NOTION THAT WE JUST KIND
OF. ALL LAND YEAH WE'RE ALL IN
TRYING TO GET ADDITIONAL
FEDERAL MONEY- WERE ALL IN WITH
OUR NATIONAL LOCATION OURS BUT
WE'RE WE'RE SOLID HERE ON THAT
STOP SIGN CALIFORNIA THERE'S
THINGS ARE OUT OF OUR CONTROL.
THE U. S. SENATE BASED UPON
WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM US
SENATORS THIS VERY THING AS FAR
AS HELPING OUT. ON STATE
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA CELL I
THINK THAT WE NEED TO REALLY
THINK ABOUT WHAT IS OUR PLAN
CALIFORNIA WHAT WHAT DO YOU TO
DEAL. AND PUT THOSE THINGS IN
PLACE BECAUSE- A MEASURE OUT
FOR EXAMPLE IT HAS TO CLEAR.
PICTURE BY LATE JUNE EARLY
JULY. ITSELF WERE WAITING
AROUND FOR THREE OR FOUR MORE
WEEKS. AND NOT PREPARED FOR
THAT THAN THAT HAS. DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES ON KIDS IN SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. SO ALL
TAKE A TIME OUT FOR THAT- NOW I
WANT TO GO TO. THE NOTION OF-
OF THAT THAT THAT THE FEDERAL
MONEY THAT WE'VE RECEIVED SO
FAR. IS PROMISING. HEARD FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
THAT DISTANCE AWAY THAT WOULD
THEY'RE BEING ASKED TO DO MORE
WITH LESS ESPECIALLY WHEN
SCHOOLS REOPEN. SO MAYBE THE
PARMA FINANCER LA- CAN TALK
ABOUT IT. IF WE- DON'T HAVE TO
GO THROUGH- WELL EITHER WAY SO
IF THE TRIGGER IS PAUL THEN WE
HAVE THESE CUTS IS THERE
REALLY. A DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR-
BACK FILL OUT THIS YEAR FOR
PROGRAMS- I KNOW WE HAVE FOR
EXAMPLE. THAT THAT POTENTIAL
SIX BILLION WOULD CUTS FOR LC A
FAST AND THE FOUR BILLION IN
THE FEDERAL MONEY FOR THE
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION BUT IF
YOU'RE A SCHOOL DISTRICT. HERE
IN SACRAMENTO ARE LA RIVER
CENTER BY WHAT HAVE YOU. TO
KEEP HOLE THEY'RE CURRENTLY
DOING OR WILL THEY HAVE TO.
FOCUS ON LAYOFFS INCREASE CLASS
SIZE AND SO FORTH. THANK YOU I
COULD START AND TAKE THE
QUESTION I THINK THAT. THE ONE
OF THE KEY THINGS. YOUR MISTER
CHECK OF ONE OF THE KEY
QUESTIONS THIS SORT OF WHAT
SCHOOL LOOKS LIKE WHEN IT
REOPENS AFTER A VERY IMPORTANT
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS. I'M
LOOKING AT THE BIG PICTURE
NUMBERS AS I MENTIONED I
DESCRIBE IN OUR PRESENTATION
THAT THE NUMBERS LOOK ROUGHLY
FLAT- SO IT DOESN'T APPEAR THAT
THERE WOULD. BE IMMEDIATE- NEED
TO SAY FOR EXAMPLE HAVE. MAJOR
LAYOFFS AND THE FOUR POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE FIFTY WITH ITS
ARE APPEARS TO BE VERY FLEXIBLE
AND WILL PROVIDE DISTRICTS
OFFICE BILLION DECIDING HOW TO
USE THOSE FUNDS THAT CAN BE.
YOU KNOW IT DOESN'T HAVE TO- WE
THINK THAT THE RESULT. SCHOOLS
USE THOSE. AND THEY HAVE TO ME.
NOT NOT HAVE MAKE BIG BIGGER.
HOWEVER I THINK THAT QUESTION
IS SORT OF WHAT THE SCHOOL LOOK
LIKE AND WHAT ARE THE
EXPECTATIONS. DO DO WE HAVE DO
WE NEED TO HAVE MORE ADULTS
AROUND TO MAKE SURE THE KIDS
ARE SAFE- IF THEY'RE GOING TO
NEED TO BE A GREATER USE OF
FACILITY THAT WE WANT TO HAVE
KIDS MORE SPREAD OUT THOSE
KINDS OF COST PRESSURES ARE.
ISSUES THAT. NEED TO BE
CONSIDERED IN TRYING TO THINK
ABOUT HOW YOU WOULD. WHETHER
THIS FUNDING AMOUNT WHAT WITH
THE IMPLICATION IS. OF THE
FUNDING. THE IS WHAT. THE KEEP.
THAT THE LET'S SEE WILL BE
THREE FIFTY. THE PARTY IS
HORRIBLE MUCH OF THE- THAT IS A
VERY UNCERTAIN CONVERSATION-
AND- YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT SURE.
WHEN SCHOOL. SOME SCHOOLS WILL
WANT TO. OPEN UP PHYSICALLY.
AND SO I THINK. TIME TO FIGURE
THAT OUT COULD BE DIFFICULT BUT
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS HAVE
CONTENT AND THINKING ABOUT- HOW
HOW. THIS THIS LEVEL OF FUNDING
WOULD AFFECT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I'M JUST TO ADD TELL WHAT THEY
ALEJO'S STATED. WE DID TRY TO
CRAFT THE LANGUAGE I'M TO BE AS
FLEXIBLE AS POSSIBLE NOTING
THAT ONLY A FOR GONNA AND YOU
DON'T. QUITE A BIT OF
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE FACING-
WITH REGARDS TO THAT THE-
PERIOD OF TIME- HAVE AND WHICH
ALWAYS CAN SPEND THAT'S FINE.
I'M HOT SEEMS TO HAVE-
DIFFERENT GUIDANCE COMING OUT
FROM THE FEDS. AND WE WOULD
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW THE GARDEN
TO ITS STILL TRICKLING OUT AND
TO THE EXTENT- YOU KNOW THAT WE
RECEIVE- GUIDANCE AROUND
SPECIFIC USES OR AM. ANYTHING
AROUND YOU KNOW STATE LEVEL
ACTIVITIES WE WILL HAVE TO
REVIVED IN LINE WITH THAT KIND
OF. BUT OUT OF THE MAJOR
REVISION BOTH THE LANGUAGE DOES
REFLECT KIND OF WHERE WE ARE AM
IN RETURN IN REGARDS TO GOD IF
I HAS COME OUT AND NOT. WITH
THE WITH THE REST OF A FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN KERR'S
FINDS. THAT O'LEARY'S CAN GO
BACK TO THE PERIOD OF MARCH
FIRST AND SPEND THOSE DOLLARS
FROM THAT PERIOD ON TO DECEMBER
THIRTIETH. AND ANY COSTS THAT
THEY INCURRED DURING THAT TIME
THAT ARE- COOKING. NINETEEN
RELATED. OKAY THANK YOU FOR
CLARIFYING THAT I THINK WE'LL
HEAR FROM THE PUBLIC COMMENT
FROM THE ED COALITION MEMBERS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN A BIT
FOR PUBLIC CALM AS FAR AS WHAT
THIS WHAT THIS REALLY MEANS AND
IT KIND OF A REALITY CHECK FOR
THAT BECAUSE I'M I'M NOT
CERTAIN THAT. THAT IS DOLLAR
FOR DOLLAR- HELD HARMLESS
REALITY. I WANT TO GO BACK TO
THE- THE TRIGGER CUTS AND SO
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT THE MID
OVERALL MAY REVISE PROP NINETY
EIGHT SOLUTIONS HAS THE
GOVERNOR. OUTLINED LAST
THURSDAY TALKED ABOUT ROUGHLY A
THIRD THIRD THIRD SO A THIRD
CAN DEFERRALS THIRD AND TRIGGER
CUTS IN THE THIRD ONE TIME
FEDERAL FUNDS. OF COURSE THOSE
TRIGGER CUTS WOULD GO AWAY
FORGOTTEN FEDERAL MY WOULD BE
ROUGHLY IS. FUNDS AND ONE THIRD
DEFERRALS AND SO DEFERRALS ARE
SOMETHING THAT WE'VE USED
BEFORE DURING THE PRIOR-
BUDGET- TOUGH TIMES IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE QUESTION IS
AS PART OF THIS DIALOGUE- CAN
WE CONSIDER LARGER DEFERRALS.
TO MITIGATE AND REDUCE SOME OF
THE POTENTIAL TRIGGER CUTS AND
COULD THAT WORK WOULD THAT WORK
SO IF BOTH LA OWN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE COULD. ADDRESS THAT.
AND GO AHEAD AND START ON THAT
PIECE OF THE- DEFERRAL AMOUNT
THAT YOU SEE REFLECTED IN THE
MAJOR VISION. ARE WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION CURRENTLY FEELS-
IT'S A REASONABLE BALANCE
BETWEEN CUTS AND DIFFERENT
RECOGNIZING THAT AT SOME POINT
THOSE DEFERRAL COST YOU HAVE TO
BE. REPAID WE DO RECOGNIZE THAT
AS WE GET MORE. INFORMATION
AROUND STATE REVENUES WE MAY
NEED TO GO BACK AND TAKE AND
TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT THIS. BUT
AT THIS TIME THAT BALANCE THAT
STRUCK ME REVISION IS- WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE REASONABLE. OKAY
AND THEN I KNOW IT'S NOT PART
OF EARLY EDUCATION PRESCHOOL
AND CHILDCARE BUT- AS FAR AS
THE CATEGORICAL CUTS. I JUST
WANNA NOTE THAT ONE OF THEM WAS
ACES AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM AT
HIS DISPENSED WITH SENSUALLY.
I'M CHILD CARE FOR MANY WORKING
FAMILIES SO I'LL COME BACK TO
THAT IN THE NEXT PRESENTATION.
THE THANK YOU THAT'S IT FOR NOW
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER
GALLAGHER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SO I'LL TRY TO GET THE
RIFLE THROUGH A FEW THINGS HERE
ONE. IN THIS TO BE FOR DO F. IT
LOOKS TO ME FROM REVIEWING THIS
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
OVERALL ENERAL FUND REDUCTION
OF EIGHT POINT SIX PERCENT. IN
THE MAY REVISE. YET IN THE PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
FUNDING IT IS FOURTEEN POINT
THREE PERCENT. LESS SO IT
DOESN'T MATTER IT'S NOT
PROPORTIONAL TO WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IN TERMS OF GENERAL FUND
MáS AND I THINK ONE OF THINGS
WE COULD DO IN THIS IN THIS
YEAR RIGHT NOW. AND IS GOING TO
GET TO A COMMON THEME HERE. I
THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
THE RIGHT NOW ESPECIALLY TO TRY
AND KEEP IT AS STABLE AS
POSSIBLE- AND- SO WHY NOT RIGHT
SIZE THAT LOOKS LIKE EIGHT
POINT 6% REDUCTION IN GENERAL
FUND YET. WE'VE GOT A FOURTEEN
POINT 3% REDUCTION. IN PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUNDS IN
THE MAY REVISE. I HAVE- MY
COLLEAGUE COME UP TO SPEAK
ABOUT. HELLO AGAIN REASON IS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
SO- AS YOU KNOW EDUCATION IS
FUNDED WITH THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEES SO THAT
IS REALLY JUSTICE- IT'S A
CONSTITUTIONAL FORMULA. SO THE
DECREASE IN REVENUES IS A 38%
WILL BE HAD AT WITH THE
GUARANTEE BECAUSE WE'RE IN A
TEST WHEN YOU ARE- THAT'S JUST
THAT TO THE EXTENT YOU WANT TO
GO ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
CONSTITUTIONAL FORMULA WOULD.
REQUIRE OVER APPROPRIATE
GUARANTEE AND THAT MEANS CUTS
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE BUDGET
SO IT. IT'S A BALANCING ACT WAS
PRIORITIES I THINK WE DO THAT
IN THIS YEAR TO HELP KEEP
EDUCATE AND STAPLE. SO YEAH I
WOULD BE OPPOSE IN THAT. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE COULD
DO A CORRECT. THAT IT YES YOU
COULD DO THAT YOU COULD
APPROPRIATE. RIGHT AND THEN AND
THEN INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT
DOING THIS OVER A THREE YEAR
AND MAKE A THREE YEAR FUNDING
COMMITMENT WHEN WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT. THE NEXT TWO YEARS ARE
GOING TO BE. WE TRY RIGHT SIZE
OF THIS BECAUSE BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW YOU'RE PROPOSING TO DO A
THREE YEAR FUNDING COMMITMENT-
TO THE TUNE OF THIRTEEN BILLION
DOLLARS. AND WE REALLY HAVE NO
IDEA WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
YOU KNOW WE STILL HAVEN'T SEEN
WITH ACTUAL REVENUE SO ARE YOU
KNOW THAT ARE GOING TO BECOME
AND WE'RE JUST. WORKING PROJECT
ENDS. AGAIN I SAY LET'S TRY TO
FIND. MORE THIS YEAR. AND NOT
JUST TAKE THE TEST ONE BUT
MAYBE FROM FROM MORE THIS YEAR
BECAUSE WE CAN DO THAT KEEP IT
CONSISTENT WITH. AN OVERALL
REDUCTION IN GENERAL FUND AND
NOT MAKE A COMMITMENT. YOU KNOW
TWO MORE YEARS DOWN THE ROAD.
IT'S GOING TO PUT US IN A PLACE
WE MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO MEET
THOSE OBLIGATIONS AND CERTAINLY
IN NEXT YEAR'S BUDGET HEARINGS.
WE CAN MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS RIGHT. IT TO THE
EXTENT YOU OVER HER PRE THE
GUARANTEE I I'M SURE I DON'T
HAVE TO EXPLAIN THIS BUT IT
MEANS THAT THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE BUDGET HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SOMEONE ELSE WILL NEED
TO TAKE. THAT CUT BECAUSE RIGHT
NOW THE BALLOT THE BUDGET IS
BALANCED WITH THE A PROP NINETY
EIGHT AT THE CONSTITUTIONAL AND-
WILL. OR SOME OTHER A WE WOULD
HAVE TO LOOK AT CUTTING THAT. I
UNDERSTAND THAT. DON'T KNOW
THAT WOULD BE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES IT COULD BE. ANY
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT THINGS BUT-
EDUCATION IS A BIG PRIORITY SO
I THINK WE SHOULD MAKE IT ONE.
BY MAKING SURE THAT IT SIZE-
THIS YEAR LET ME RUN THROUGH
JUST A COUPLE MORE THINGS.
AGAIN I WOULDN'T CREATE THIS
MULTI YOUR OBLIGATION I THINK
YOUR POINT WHERE SAY IN
OURSELVES UP FOR TROUBLE THERE
WITH A THREE YEAR THIRTEEN
BILLION DOLLAR OBLIGATION.
LET'S DO IT RIGHT THIS YEAR. IN
THE LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION
THE FOUR POINT FOUR THAT WERE
READ REALLOCATING USING FEDERAL
FUNDS. COULD THIS BE USED FOR
OTHER PURPOSES THERE'S A BIG
FOCUS HERE ON- LEARNING LAWSON
AND ESPECIALLY ON GETTING. YOU
KNOW MORE DEVICES BUT AS MY
COLLEAGUES ON BEACH POINTED OUT
OUR LAST YEAR IN THIS BECAUSE
YOU GIVE SOMEONE A DEVICE
DOESN'T MEAN THAT YOU'VE
CONNECTED THEM DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY LEARNING
AT HOME- AND AGAIN I THINK I'M
MORE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE CAN. IS A VERY GOOD
CHANCE WE COULD REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS IN THE FALL- THERE MAY
BE SOME DELAYS- BUT GETTING
KIDS BACK INTO SCHOOL GETTING
BACK INTO PROGRAMS. AND
MEANWHILE WE'RE CUTTING WE ARE
CUTTING. ATTACK AND WE'RE
CUTTING AFTER SCHOOL. WHICH I
THINK ARE TOO BIG PRIORITIES
THAT MAYBE IF WE RE SHIFTED
THESE MONIES AS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. MAYBE GOING A LITTLE BIT
MORE THIS YEAR ABOVE THE- TEST
ONE. MAYBE USING SOME OF THIS
FEDERAL MONEY. WE COULD MAKE
THOSE THINGS PRIORITIES AND NOT
JUST FOCUS IT ON PURCHASING
MORE DEVICES AND- BECAUSE ALSO
MY WORK WHAT THESE KIDS NEED IS
ACTUAL. YOU KNOW INSTRUCTION IN
SCHOOL THAT'S GOING TO DO MORE
THAN ANYTHING TO HELP REMEDY
THE LEARNING LOS RIGHT. EVER
OUTLANDER CAN WITH FINANCE- YOU
ARE RIGHT AND THAT THE REASON
WHY THE LANGUAGE IS WRITTEN AND
THE WAY THAT IT IS IT IS
PROBABLY NOT- THAT IF IT IF AND
ONLY EIGHT CHOSE TO. TAKE THESE
DOLLARS AND- THEY FELT THAT THE
BEST WAY TO- OFFER ADDITIONAL
ENRICHMENT OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THEIR STUDENTS WAS TO DO IT FOR
AFTER SCHOOL OR THROUGH CTT
PROGRAMS. THEY COULD DO THAT
UNDER THE PROPOSAL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN OBVIOUSLY THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO YOU KNOW
SPEND THOSE DOLLARS IN LINE
WITH A WITH FEDERAL LAW- BUT IT
IS IT IS QUITE BROAD AT THIS
POINT SO LONG AS THOSE
EXPENDITURES ARE RELATED
DIRECTLY TO MITIGATING THE
IMPACTS OF OCTOBER NINETEEN
SCHOOL CLOSURES. OKAY SO WITHIN
THAT FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
THERE IS FLEXIBILITY TO USE
THAT IN OTHER WAYS. SO LONG AS
FINISH ARE ARE TO THE HOOK OF A-
AND RELATED LEARNING. TAPERED
TYPE. YES I ALSO REALLY LIKE
THIS IDEA THAT THE LA- PROPOSES
OF MAYBE YOU CAN HELP TARGET
THAT INCOME TARGET THAT MONEY
TOWARDS LOW INCOME IN ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS RATHER THAN
JUST DOING AS A BLANKET GRANT
IS THAT SOMETHING YOU GUYS ARE
OPEN TO. THE PROPOSAL- AS
STRUCTURED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION I THINK IT'S
ACTUALLY- PROBABLY A LITTLE
MORE TARGETED- BUT IT'S
TARGETED SPECIFICALLY OP BOTH
L. USE THAT GENERATE
CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING-
FOR THE TWO POINT EIGHT. FIVE
FIVE. MILLION OR BILLION DOLLAR
PIECE- SO IT IS VERY VERY MUCH
TARGETED ON THOSE- STUDENTS
THAT GENERATE THAT FUNDING SO
THAT YOUR FOSTER YOUTH YOUR
ENGLISH LEARNERS- AND LOW
INCOME. THE PIECE THAT'S NOT
QUITE AS TARGETED IS. ONE AND A
HALF BILLION THAT'S GOING OUT
BASED ON SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
ROLL MY COUNTY. AND THE REASON
FOR THAT IS WE DID RECOGNIZE
THAT ALL AND ALL. ALL UNITS ARE
GOING TO. EXPERIENCE SOME LEVEL
OF- LEARNING LOSS. AND WE FELT
LIKE THIS PROPOSAL WOULD ALLOW
AND FUNDING TO GO OUT FOR.
EDUCATION BASED BUT FOR
PATIENTS. ONE OF POPULATION
THAT WE FOR HAVE. PART OF UNDER
SHIFTED AND FINE. BUT ALSO TO
PROVIDE ALL THE AIDS WITH WHAT.
TO SPEND. FUNDS BEYOND
POPULATION. AND THAT'S A GOOD
SO FOR ME BECAUSE ON. A SO I
VERY MUCH OF. THE CAN COMMIT TO
THIS ARE FIVE. FOR EQUALIZATION.
I DO WANT TO DRESS THAT YOU ARE
USING A THREE YEAR ROLLING
AVERAGE ADA- FOR THE FUTURE.
AND YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THE
GOAL OF PROVIDING FUNNY
STABILITY. YOU KNOW FOR THOSE
ELEAZAR EXPERIENCING DECLINING
ENROLLMENT AND ATTENDANCE AT
WHICH IS MOST ELEAZAR. HOWEVER
THIS APPROACH COULD BE
DETRIMENTAL TO ELEAZAR
EXPERIENCING GROWTH SO WOULD
THE ADMINISTRATION BE OPEN TO
MODIFY AND THEIR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FUNDING BASED ON THE GREATER OF
THE THREE YEAR ROLLING AVERAGE
OR CURRENT YEAR ADA. AND I'M
GONNA ASK MY COLLEAGUE WHO
HANDLES THAT SPECIAL EDUCATION
TO COME UP ON THAT. AGAIN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE I'M SO
IN THE SPECIAL EDUCATION- WE
WOULD BE OPEN TO CONVERSATIONS
ON NOT. FORMULAS WELL WE CHOSE
THREE ROLLING AVERAGE BECAUSE
IT IT BETTER- ALLOW DISTRICTS
TO KINDA RAMP UP AND DECLINED-
MORE SMOOTHLY THAN THEY
CURRENTLY DO SO. ANY
MODIFICATION WE'D BE HAPPY TO
TAKE A LOOK AT. OKAY THAT'S ALL
I HAVE MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
THANK YOU WE HAVE NEXT- MISTER
MARTUCCI THAN MISTER MEDINA
THAN MISTER MOAN AND THEN
MISTER DON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WOULD LIKE TO START OFF BY
SUPPORTING WHAT THE MISTER
GALLAGHER WAS SHOCKED TALKING
ABOUT IN IN TERMS OF A COMMON
MANTRA THAT WE HAVE HEARD OFTEN
IN THIS COMMITTEE THAT WE
SHOULD NOT. TREAT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT- A
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AS A- AS A
CEILING. I ALSO AGREE THAT
EDUCATION IS AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO BE OUR NUMBER ONE A
BUDGET PRIORITY AND SO IF THAT
MEANS- FUNDING ABOVE THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEE AND PULLING
FROM OTHER A PRIORITIES I WOULD
SUPPORT THAT. NUMBER TWO. I AM
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL IS-
TAKING THAT THE LARGEST- POTS
OF MONEY OF- ESPECIALLY THE
FEDERAL AID THAT WE HAVE
RECEIVED AN TREATING CLEAR
WINNERS AND LOSERS BETWEEN THE
CONCENTRATE CONCENTRATION.
GRANT DISTRICTS AND THE NON
CONCENTRATION GRANT DISTRICTS
THOSE FEDERAL DOLLARS- WHERE IN
LARGE PART SUPPOSED TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND DEAL WITH
THE COST OF KEEPING THEIR KIDS
AND THEIR STAFF SAFE THOSE
COSTS ARE BORNE BY ALL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS REGARDLESS OF WHETHER
YOU'RE A CONCENTRATION DISTRICT
OR NOT. AND YOU KNOW IF THERE
IS ANYONE OUT THERE WHO THINKS
THAT THAT SUBURBAN DISTRICTS
ARE NOT FACING YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT FACING THE SAME FINANCIAL.
EVEN BEFORE THE PAN MAKE HIT
YOU KNOW I CAN GIVE YOU ARE.
TWO EXAMPLES FOR IT FROM MY
DISTRICT SUBURBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT PASSED PARCEL
TAXES YOU KNOW WHAT TO DO TRY
TO- SUPPORT THEIR LOCAL
SCHOOLS. I GIVE A GIVEN THE-
THE REALITIES THAT THEY HAVE TO
DEAL WITH UNDER THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA WHERE
THEY ARE READY RECEIVE. A
DRAMATICALLY SMALLER. FRACTION
OF DOLLARS THAN THOSE THAT HAVE
THE HIGHER POPULATIONS OF
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND YET
AT AN AND THIS GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL JUST DOUBLES
DOWN TROUBLES DOWN ON THE
INEQUITIES BETWEEN. THE
DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE MORE
DOLLARS FOR UNDER THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND
THOSE THAT DON'T. CASE IN POINT
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION- OF FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE CROWN OF VIRUS
RELIEF FUND. AND A TOTAL OF
FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
TO GO FOR LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION- WITH TWO POINT NINE
BILLION TO GO TO ONLY TO THE
DISTRICTS THAT RECEIVE THE LC
FF CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDS I
MEAN. THERE'S JUST NO WAY THAT
I CAN SUPPORT A BUDGET THAT
DOESN'T GIVE. YOU KNOW. IS SOME
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT YOU KNOW
IT'S NOT JUST THE CONCENTRATION
GRANT DISTRICTS THAT HAVE ARE
FACING TREMENDOUS COSTS FROM
CORONA VIRUS SAFETY MEDICATION
SO- I MEAN I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
I DON'T THE LA- HAS THIS
NUMBER. A YOU KNOW AT THE AT
HAND BUT THE DO YOU HAVE THE.
THE AVERAGE LCF FUNDING PER
STUDENT FOR CONCENTRATION GRANT
DISTRICTS VERSUS NON
CONCENTRATION GRANT DISTRICTS.
pTHAT ARE- THAT WE HAVE ARE
EASILY AVAILABLE AT RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF THE OVERALL AMOUNT
IS- A LITTLE OVER TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER STUDENT WE DON'T
HAVE THAT- THAT SPECIFIC
DIFFERENCE BUT IF I MIGHT ADD I
THINK THERE'S A ANOTHER LIKE
COMPARTE POINT THAT I THINK WE
HAVE FOR WHY WE- CONCERNS
BECAUSE AS WELL. EVEN WITHIN
THE BUCKET A CONCENTRATION
GRANT DISTRICTS- THEIR THEIR
TREE AT ALL THE STATEMENT WE
WE'VE GOT TO THINK THAT THAT'S
CONCERNING SO- YOU KNOW THE
STATEWIDE A PRIVILEGE OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW INCOME
REGISTERS IS ABOUT 60% THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT START THAT
FIFTY FIVE IF YOU'RE DISTRICT
TO HAVE 55% OF YOUR STUDENTS
WHO ARE YELLOW INCOME FOSTER.
AND YOUR DISTRESS 90% COURT
YELLOW INCOME FOSTER UNDER THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
YOU'RE GETTING THE SAME AMOUNT
PER STUDENT AND THOSE ARE VERY
DIFFERENT SITUATION SO AND NOW
THOSE IN THOSE TWO EXAMPLES OF
55% AND- PERCENT. THE DOLLAR.
AND IN MANY WHO THAT. HE ARE.
FIFTY THEY GET NOTHING SO. WE
THINK THAT JUST IS NOT A VERY
KNOW WHAT THE- THAT WE THINK
DISTRIBUTING THE FUNDING. BASED
ON TO. CHAIR OUR ENGLISH.
IMPOSSIBLE THINK IT'S GONNA BE
SOMETHING THAT'S ARE MORE
BROADLY DISTRIBUTING FUNDING AN
ADULT IS ALSO GOING TO BE GOING
UP BASED ON THE DISTRICTS NEED.
OKAY I'D I'D LIKE TO GET THAT
OF THOSE DOLLAR FIGURES. OUT
FROM YOU AND FOLLOW UP AFTER
THIS MEETING BUT I JUST WANTED
FOR A HIGHLIGHT. IN ADDITION TO
THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION. THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSING. THERE IS THE ONE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FEDERAL FUNDING- WITH
WITH ALMOST ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION- OVER 90% GOING TO
SCHOOLS BASED ON THE TITLE ONE
FUNDING FORMULA NOW I
UNDERSTAND. THAT THIS IS THE
FEDERAL LEGISLATION AND SO WE
HAVE NO CONTROL OVER THIS BUT
JUST TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA I. I
HAVEN'T CONFIRMED THE THESE
FIGURES BUT- YOU KNOW I
REPRESENT BOTH LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED. AND TORRANCE UNIFIED
AND THERE'S ONE STREET THAT
DIVIDES LOS ANGELES THE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM. FROM THE THAT THE
TORRANCE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT JUST ONE ST YOU KNOW
DEPENDING ON WHETHER YOU LIVE
ON THE WEST SIDE OF WESTERN
AVENUE OR THE EAST SIDE OF
WESTERN AVENUE. THAT DETERMINES
WHICH DISTRICT URINE. LAUSD
UNDER THE- THE ONE TIME SCHOOL
FEDERAL FUNDING FORMULA UNDER
THE TITLE ONE FORMULA THEY GET.
AN ESTIMATED SIX HUNDRED TWENTY
EIGHT DOLLARS PER STUDENT WHILE
TORRANCE UNIFIED GET SEVEN
EIGHT DOLLARS PER STUDENT. AND
THAT'S YOU KNOW IS JUST
IGNORING THE REALITY THAT JUST
BECAUSE YOU MAY LIVE ON THE
WEST SIDE OF WESTERN AVENUE.
YOU KNOW THAT SOMEHOW YOU YOU
SUDDENLY ARE LIVE IN A MUCH APT.
CA SO. THE THEY GOVERNOR THE OF
FINANCE NEEDS TO RECOGNIZE
THAT- THAT ALL DISTRICTS ARE
HURTING THIS IS A SURVIVAL
BUDGET AND THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO. MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF OUR
KIDS AND ALL OF OUR STAFF AND
ALL OF OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS OUR
TEAM SAFE AND SO THIS. THIS
AREN'T YOU KNOW THERE. IN AND
AN INCREASE IN WINTERS IN YOUR
IS BETWEEN TO RECEIVE OUR OUR
TARGET. OF A FOR THE FUNDING
AND THOSE THAT ARE NOT IS SO I
CANNOT REPORT. I MAILED TO MOVE
ON TO IT. ANOTHER ISSUE THAT-
THAT THAT I AM TRYING TO FOCUS
ON WHICH IS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
THERE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION- DOCTOR. GREGSON
INDICATED THAT THE STATE NEEDS
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
COMPUTER DEVICES AND THREE
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND HOT
SPOTS. I AM ENGAGED IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SUMMER
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY OF A
DISTANCE LEARNING BOND- IN
ORDER TO TRY TO SUPPLEMENT THE
DOLLARS THAT WE CAN PROVIDE
FROM THE GENERAL FUND- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE COSTS SOME
OF THESE COSTS OF COMPUTER
DEVICES AND HOT SPOTS. AS
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
CONSIDERED- THE OPTION OF BOND
FUNDS. TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE-
THE URGENT NEEDS CREATED BY
THIS PANDEMIC AS IT RELATES TO
AS THEY RELATE TO DISTANCE
LEARNING. AMBER ALEXANDER WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THAT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
CURRENTLY- ADDRESSED IN THE MAY
REVISION THERE ARE-
CONVERSATIONS HAPPENING- ON ON
MULTIPLE LEVELS- RICK WITH
REGARDS TO STEP THAT MAY BE
TAKEN. TO RESPOND TO- YOU KNOW
DROPS IN REVENUES- AND TO
ENSURE THAT AT NOT ONLY ONLY A
FOOT THE STATE THE WHOLE IS
ABLE TO RECOVER THEM FROM THIS
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN. BUT I'M NOT
AWARE I AM AT LEAST AT THIS
POINT OF ANY CONVERSATIONS
HAPPENING ON WITH REGARDS TO
EDUCATION AND BOND SPECIFICALLY.
IS THE A DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION DR GRETCHEN AVAILABLE.
YES WE WILL CAP OFF THANK YOU.
SAID LIKE TO CUT MENTION A
COUPLE OF THINGS AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE SCHOOLS WILL HAVE NEW
EXPENSIVE AND THE EXPENSES AND
NEED MORE REVENUE- WE DON'T
FAVOR ANY PARTICULAR REVENUE
STREAM WE JUST KNOW ADDITIONAL
REVENUE WOULD BE NEEDED AND SO
WE WOULD BE WILLING TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE GOVERNOR TO EXPLORE ANY
AND ALL REVENUE STREAMS. I'D
ALSO LIKE TO KNOW THAT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH INTERNET
SERVICE PROVIDERS TO OUR
DIGITAL TAX FORCED TO INCREASE
THE ACCESS TO OUR FAMILIES THAT
HAVE ANY FOR YEARS TO SEVENTY
I. MENTION PREVIOUSLY. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. LAST TOPIC I'D
LIKE TO TOUCH UPON IS. I SAID
THIS IN A IN OUR LAST BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE MEETING AGAIN AND
I LIKE TO SEE IT AGAIN BUT- END
THIS. SURVIVAL BUDGET THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO
BE FACING I. WANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT- SCHOOL DISTRICTS NEED TO
HAVE AS MUCH FLEXIBILITY AS
POSSIBLE. I KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNOR. DID NOT REYES AND THE
LA HIGHLIGHTED THIS FACT THAT
TO. YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
CRITICAL TOOLS THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS USED IT DURING THE
OUR LAST GREAT DOWNTURN THE
GREAT RECESSION- WAS IN GIVING
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FLEXIBILITY IN
TERMS OF THEIR SCHOOL YEAR- TO
HAVE FLEXIBILITY FROM THE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY- ARE.
MINIMUM SCHOOL YEAR I. WE NEED
WE NEED STATE LEADERSHIP TO
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
FLEXIBILITY THE OTHER
FLEXIBILITY THAT- THAT I KNOW
THAT- WAS A HIGHLY VALUED- WHEN
I WAS ON A SCHOOL BOARD DURING
THE GREAT RECESSION WAS THE
ABILITY TO MOVE MONIES. ARE
AROUND FROM DIFFERENT ACCOUNTS-
INCLUDING- BEING ABLE TO SWEEP.
THE BALANCES OF ANY FUNDS THAT
ARE NOT USED IN CERTAIN
ACCOUNTS TO ALLOW SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE FLEXIBILITY TO
USE THEM WHERE THEIR THEIR
NEEDS ARE THE GREATEST AND SO I
JUST LIKE TO CALL FOR- THE NEED
FOR FURTHER FLEXIBILITY FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN ORDER TO
MATCH THEY THEY KNOW BASS WHERE
THEIR GREATEST NEEDS ARE AND
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO MOVE
THE DOLLARS TO WEAR THEIR
GREATEST NEEDS ARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
MEDINA THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I HAVE A THREE TOPICS THAT I
WANT TO BRING UP- WITH COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING. SECOND THE
AGE CAPS ON CHARTER SCHOOLS AND
THIRD ADDRESSING FOOD IN
SECURITIES. SO GOING THROUGH
THE FIRST TOPIC SPECIAL
EDUCATION. I WANT TO VOICE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MAINTAIN THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
INCREASING SPECIAL EDUCATION
RESOURCES AND IMPROVING SPECIAL
EDUCATION FINANCING PROGRAMS
AND STUDENT OUTCOMES. THIS IS
MUCH NEEDED FUNDING TO HELP
INSURE THE EQUALIZATION OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION. FOCUS ON
ADDRESSING EQUITY THROUGH THE
CREATION OF A NEW FUNDING
FORMULA AND THIS TIME I URGE US
TO MAINTAIN THE EXISTING AB SIX
OH TWO FUNDING FORMULA GIVEN
ALL THE COURT CURRENT
CHALLENGES THAT ARE DISTRICTS
ARE FACING. SINCE THE GOVERNOR
FIRST INTRODUCES BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN JANUARY THE NEEDS
OF STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES
HAVE ONLY INCREASED. GENERAL
EDUCATION SETS A FOUNDATION FOR
DISTANCE LEARNING AS SPECIAL
EDUCATORS ARE WORKING TIRES
LOOSELY TO ENSURE THAT STUDENTS
DISABILITY HAVE ACCESS AND
APPROPRIATE ACCOMMODATIONS
RELATED SERVICES AND
TECHNOLOGIES TO CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE EDUCATIONAL BENEFIT.
DURING THIS CHALLENGING TIME.
CONTINUATION OF CURRENT
SERVICES VIA DISTANCE LEARNING
IS ALREADY INCREASING SPECIAL
EDUCATION CLASS AS ELEAZAR
PIVOT TO VIRTUAL PLATFORMS AND
PROVIDE TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER
SUPPORTS TO INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
HOMES. THIS FUNDING IS CRITICAL
TO SUPPORT CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
NEEDS STUDENTS AND FAMILIES AS
WELL AS TO US WORK TOWARDS
ESTABLISHING EQUITY. AND TOPIC
OPPOSING CAPS ON CHARTER SCHOOL.
I WANT EXPRESSED GREAT CONCERN
WITH MY ROOMMATE DINA DO YOU
WANT TO BREAK THEM UP AND HAVE
THEM RESPOND TO EACH YEAR
ISSUES OF QUESTIONS ON THE
FIRST ONE SURE I DON'T I REALLY
DON'T HAVE QUESTIONS BUT- IF
THEY WANT TO RESPOND THAT THE-
IT. ANYONE WANT TO RESPOND TO.
SPECIAL EDUCATION. AND. IF
THERE'S NO RESPONSE I'LL GO TO
THE SECOND. OPPOSING CAPS ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS I I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS GREAT CONCERN ABOUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE EFFORT.
TO PLAYS AN H. CAP ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE
THAT I REPRESENT IS HOME TO
FEEL CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL WHICH
SERVES ADULT IMMIGRANTS AND
FARM WORKERS. PROGRAMMING AT
THIS SCHOOL HOUSE TO
STRENGTHENED ROLE IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES BY ADDRESSING
EDUCATIONAL GAPS IN OUR CURRENT
SCHOOL SYSTEMS. RIVERSIDE
PROGRAM HAS OVER SIXTY PEOPLE
ENROLLED AND IS VERY MUCH TIED
INTO PARTNERSHIPS WITH THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE AND HOPES TO
EXPAND TO THE CITIES OF MORENO
VALLEY PARIS AND SAMBAR MEDINA.
IT SEEMS OF THE PROPOSED AGE
GAP ON CHARTER SCHOOLS WOULD
NOT ONLY DECIMATE PROGRAMS LIKE
FIELD BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT
LEAVES FEAR RESOURCES FOR ADULT
IMMIGRANTS TO UTILIZED. AS THEY
NAVIGATE THEIR LIVES AND
COMMUNITIES IN THIS STATE. NOW
MORE THAN EVER AS WE SPEAK
ABOUT HOW ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND
IMMIGRANTS ARE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES AND WORKFORCE WE
SHOULD NOT MAKE POLICY THE
CHANGES AND LEAVES AND BE HIGH.
TWO QUESTIONS. ADD TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHAT IS
THE DEPARTMENT'S REASONING FOR
INSTITUTING AN H. CAP. FOR
PUPILS ENROLLED IN A CHARTER
SCHOOL. EVER ALEXANDER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE DOES
PLACE A CAP ON- ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS- TO AT AT THE AGE OF
UNDER TWENTY SEVEN SO THAT WILL
PEOPLE'S UP THROUGH THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX AND ALLOW THEM TO
STILL BE FUNDED. THE REASON
THAT THE CAPITAL AND SET AT
THIS LEVEL IF WE WERE TRYING TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN THOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE-
PARTNERING WITH- UNDER WE ALL
PARTNERSHIPS AND PARTNERING
WITH PROGRAMS LIKE CONSERVATION
CORPS AND YOU FELT AND A LOT OF
THOSE PROGRAMS A CAP AT THE AGE
OF TWENTY FOUR OR TWENTY FIVE.
SO WE DID TRY TO STRIKE THAT
BALANCE- BUT REALLY THE CRUX OF
THE REASON WHY WE ARE PROPOSING
PROPOSAL IS BECAUSE AT SOME
POINT BUT BUILT EDUCATION
FUNDING MECHANISM IS A BETTER
VENUE FOR- FOR PROVIDING-
EDUCATION FOR ADULTS. AND AT
THIS POINT WE'VE TAKEN IT UPON
OURSELVES TO SETBACK CAP UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN FOR
THAT REASON. THANK YOU. AND
SECOND QUESTION TO THE MEN OF
FINANCE. HAS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. OF DONE ANYTHING TO
REVIEW THE IMPACT. OF THIS NEW
CAP ON SCHOOL SUCH AS FIELDS
SAYS ARE TRAVIS. CHARTER SCHOOL
AND IN DISTRICTS LIKE MY- WE
HAVEN'T RESEARCH SPECIFIC AS
SCHOOLS ARE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS
AT SCHOOL TO BUY AGAIN WE DID
LOOK AT- SOME OF THE LARGER AT
CONSERVATION. CONSERVATION
CORPS PROGRAM AND YOUTH BUILD
JOB CORPS AND TRIED TO
ACCOMMODATE- IT EXCITING THE
AGE CAP AT A LEVEL THAT WOULD
NOT IMPACT THOSE PROGRAMS. SO I
WOULD. SUBMIT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THAT. HAVING SEEN
WHAT VALUABLE OF SERVICES THE
PROGRAM IS- BY FEEL IN MY OWN
DISTRICT I WOULD BE OPPOSED TO-
GETTING- SETTING A CAP ON H.
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS. AND TO THE
LAST TOPIC ADDRESSING FOOD IN
SECURITIES. WE'VE SEEN THE
IMPACT OF COVERT NINETEEN HAS
HAD ON STUDENTS NOT ONLY
ATTENDED SCHOOL BUT HAVING
ACCESS TO SCHOOL MEALS. FOR
SOME CHILDREN ESPECIALLY THOSE
ON FREE OR REDUCED MEALS THESE
MEALS RECEIVE IT SCHOOLS ARE
THE ONLY ONES THEY WILL HAVE ON
ANY GIVEN DAY. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS ARE
NOT GOING HUNGRY AND THE
DISTRICTS AN ALLEY ETS ARE
DOING THEIR PART TO ENSURE THAT
THESE MEALS ARE STILL BEING
PROVIDED. TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS SO QUESTION
HOW OUR SCHOOL MEALS PROGRAM
WHICH ALREADY ARE UNDERFUNDED
AND UNDERSTAFFED. DEALING WITH
THE SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
CHALLENGE FROM THE PANDEMIC.
HOW MANY UHHUH BUT WENT WENT
ONE MORE HOW MANY DISTRICTS ARE
STILL IN DEFICIT DUE TO HIGHER
OPERATIONAL COSTS MOSTLY TIED
THE LABOR AND LOTS OF PAID
REVENUE STREAMS EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE MAXIMIZING THEIR
FEDERAL REAM REIMBURSEMENT. I
MEAN I HAVE ARE- MY COLLEAGUE
WHO HANDLES THE NUTRITION
ASSIGNMENT COME UP TO SPEAK
WITHOUT.
IT HANSON DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE THE MAY REVISION
PROVIDE SEVEN HUNDRED NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED FOURTEEN MILLER
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS MADE
AVAILABLE THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
UNFORTUNATELY THIS FUNDING IS
NOT TERRIBLY FLEXIBLE I KNOW
THE DEPARTMENT IS CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SEE IF THIS FUNNY
CAN BE A LITTLE MORE FLEXIBLE
TO WORK AND HELP ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT SCHOOLS
ARE HONORING THAT MOMENT. I
KNOW THOSE DIALOGUES ARE
CONTINUING AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT THE FUNDING THAT'S IN THE
MAY REVISION WILL AUTOMATICALLY
BE AVAILABLE TO HELP SCHOOLS
THAT ARE- CHALLENGED BY THE
CURRENT ENVIRONMENT. AND TO
FOLLOW UP QUESTION IS OUR
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND THE
IT DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
SEE HOW MEAL PROGRAMS CAN BE
USED. TO HELP FARMERS
ESPECIALLY WHEN SO MUCH FOOD IS
GOING TO WASTE. THERE IT IS I
KNOW THAT. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET THERE WAS A PROPOSAL TO
FOR A- ADDRESS MORE. AT TO HAVE
SCHOOLS ENGAGE WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND FARMERS TO BE
ABLE TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES- AND ALL THAT WAS
PROPOSED. NOT QUITE SURE WHERE
THAT STANDS MOMENT QUITE
HONESTLY- WE DO CONTINUE TO
HAVE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION JUST
GENERALLY ABOUT OUR SCHOOL FOOD
PROGRAMS AND TO TRY TO
MAINTAIN- ADEQUATE FUNNY TO
KEEP THEM MANAGEABLE. AND MY
LAST QUESTION DO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO PROVIDE
HEALTHY MEALS HAVE SUFFICIENT
GUIDANCE. AND TRAINING. AND THE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
TO ENSURE THAT THESE MEALS ARE
PROVIDED SAFELY AND HOW ARE
THEY PAYING FOR THESE SUPPLIES.
HI IT'S DIFFICULT FOR ME TO
ANSWER SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S
HAPPENING AT EVERY DISTRICT I
WOULD HAVE TO DEFER TO THE
DEPARTMENT ON WHAT SPECIFIC. IS
THAT THEY'RE BEING THE LOCAL
LEVEL- I HAVE NOT HEARD. IN
GENERAL AFRICAN CHALLENGES THAT
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE HAVING
A IN THE CURRENT ENVIRONMENT OF
HAVING PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT AND
DEALING WITH SOME OF THE MEAL
PROGRAMS. THEN AGAIN I WOULD
SAY THAT THE- RIGHTS AT NEARLY
SEVEN HUNDRED FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
WILL HOPEFULLY HELP SCHOOLS
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
CHALLENGES IN WORLD THE- WE'RE
HOPING THAT THAT FUNNY WILL
ULTIMATELY BE AVAIL. TO HELP
SCHOOLS. AND COULD I YOUR
PRIVATE OF EDUCATION ON THE
LAST QUESTION. AND I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU'D LIKE TO REPEAT THE
QUESTION. NO I AM WELL THINGS
AROUND YOUR QUESTIONS AT MEMBER
MEDINA IS OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE OVER FIVE
THOUSAND SITES THAT ARE
OFFERING MEALS. AND ONE OF THE
ISSUES THAT IS CAUSING A
DEFICIT FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS IS
NOT BEING ABLE TO BE REIMBURSED
FOR THE COST OF THOSE MEALS
SERVED. AND SO THEY ARE
UTILIZING ENORMOUS OF STAFF I'M
SURE THIS DISBURSEMENT OF FOOD
BUT THEY ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO
BE. REIMBURSED FOR THIS COSTS
THROUGH THE FEDERAL WE- AS-
PURSUED MANY DIFFERENT FEDERAL
WAIVERS TO MAKE IT MORE
FLEXIBLE FOR OUR DISTRICTS TO
SERVE MEALS DURING THIS TIME SO
THAT HAS BEEN EXTREMELY HELPFUL
FOR OUR FAMILIES- BUT AGAIN
THAT DOES COME. AT A COST FOR
DISTRICTS. THE TRAINING FOR P.
P. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH
OUR NUTRITION SERVICES DIVISION
ALONG WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER THE BEST APPROACH IS TO
ENSURE THE SAFETY TRAIN. OUR
STAFF. AND FOR SCHOOL STAFF IT
AND PART OF ONE OF THE RE
OPENING TASK FORCE AT GOALS IS
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S THAT
HEALTH AND SAFETY FOR NOT ONLY
STUDENTS BUT STAFF AS WELL.
THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU NEXT
WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
MOAN AND ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL. THANK YOU AND TO AT
THIS POINT SOME OF WHAT I'M
GONNA SAY JUST REPEATS ARE
ECHOES WHAT AT SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE SAID- BUT FIRST
I JUST WNT TO START OFF BY
MAKING IT JUST A COMMENT
OVERALL ABOUT THE STATE OF THE
BUDGET. AND NEEDLESS TO SAY
THAT AT I SHARE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND BELIEVABLE
CONCERNING- IT THE THING THAT
STICKS OUT IN THAT I'M HAVING A
VERY HARD TO SWALLOW. EIGHT ARE
CHAIRED QUESTION ABOUT KNOW
WHAT'S PLAN B. YOUR PLAN SEE-
IS THE UP THE EFFORT IN AND THE
PER. THE FOR. I THE ENOUGH. ST
ARE DOING AS MUCH AS THEY CAN
WITH THE REASON. OF ENTER BEAN
ASK TO DO SOMETHING. THAN WHAT
WE'VE ASKED OTHERS TO DO
COMMENT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
COMMENTED ON THE CHALLENGES
WITH TECHNOLOGY IT'S NOT JUST
LETTING THEM. THE EQUIPMENT IS
GETTING THEM TO BE ABLE TO YOU.
EQUIPMENT BUT AT ITS WHEN THE
STUDENTS ARE ADDED THEIR SITE
THEIR CONTROL- AND NOT IN THEIR
PURVIEW- AND GETTING SOME
RESULTS IN TERMS OF LEARNING SO
I THINK THAT THERE'S REAL
CHALLENGES- AND I DO HOPE. WE
THINK ABOUT WHAT OUR PLAN. YOU
KNOW B. OR C. I'M IF THE
FEDERAL SPENDING DOESN'T COME
THROUGH I KNOW THAT WHAT'S
PROPOSES JUST FLAT OUT CUTS BUT
WERE ASKING FOR ANOTHER PLAN-
IN ADDITION TO THE FEDERAL
FUNDING AND JUST. GOT OUT CUTS-
STATING THAT THE US THAT YOU
PUNISH SAY OVERALL. RELATION TO
BUDGET- AND- WE SEE A LITTLE
BIT MORE. I HAVE A CUP. IS IT
AFTER SCHOOL. SPECIAL MEALS ALL
THOSE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE CHAR
EIGHT AT JUST PREPARING YOU A
TO SEE WHO'S GONNA. COME UP AND
ANSWER QUESTIONS I ON THE
SPECIAL AND FRIENDS. YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD AT LEAST I'VE HEARD
FROM SOME FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT-
WHO APPRECIATE THAT
ADMINISTRATION INCREASE IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION RATES- BUT I
AM CURIOUS ON WHY THE FORMULA
THAT IMPACT- I'VE HEARD FROM MY
DISTRICT AT THE- THEY- ARE THE
AB SIX OH TWO FOR. THE FORMULA.
WHAT MIGHT ITS FORMULA. I WE
HAD A LOT OF IS THE- IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET BUT THE NEW
FORMALLY AS VERY VERY SOMEONE'S
BABY SIX OH TWO. WHAT IT DOES
THOUGH IT STARTS THE LANGUAGE
NEW THERE'S A LOT OF- CONFUSING
SEGMENTS IN THE SIX OH TWO
FORMULA THERE'S A LOT OF OUT ON
CATEGORICAL THAT ARE FROZEN IN
TIME THAT MAKE KNOWS AND- SO
THIS WOULD JUST BE STARTING
WITH THE BAY. WE HAVE WORKED
THE STUDIES WAS. DIFFERENT
THESE THEN. NOW AS WE MOVE OUT
WHICH WOULD ADD THE EQUITY P.
WITH OTHER PARTS OF THE PROGRAM
SO YOU SAID IT'S SIMILAR BUT
NOT IDENTICAL SO WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT ARE DIFFERENT. THE
BIGGEST DIFFERENCE THREE A
ROLLING AVERAGE FOR THE EIGHTY
A RIGHT NOW- SPECIAL EDUCATION
FORMULA IS KIND OF THE GREATER
OF. PRIOR IN PRIOR YEAR- SO
THEY THEY KIND OF GOT A THREE
YEAR. OLD ARE TEAR HOLD
HARMLESS BUT I'M NOT. YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE FACT THAT WITH.
FEARFUL TARA AND THEN THAT THAT
IS MOSTLY THE BASE FORMULA-
ISSUES I'M TRYING TO THINK I'M
SORRY I DID NOT BRING. BACK UP
ON THAT BUT- THE DEPARTMENT
MIGHT HAVE SOMETHING HERE THAT
COULD SPEAK TO A LITTLE BETTER
THAN I BUT- THAT THAT IS THE
BIGGEST ISSUE IS THE ATA. OKAY
I'M ARE A IN THE IN I THINK AT
THIS POINT THE- AGAIN YOU'VE
HEARD SOME OF THIS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES BUT FLEXIBILITY IS
REALLY IMPORTANT- AND SO I'M
TRYING TO JUST MAKE SURE THAT
IN THESE REALLY TOUGH TIMES.
SOMETHING SIMILAR BUT IS NOT
IDENTICAL LIKE IS THAT WHERE.
I'M TRYING TO MAKE THINGS
EASIER FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THIS IS REALLY REALLY HARD SO
IT'S MOMENTS LIKE THIS WHERE
I'M LIKE IT MIGHT BE THE BEST.
YOU KNOW FOR WHAT WHERE AND
THERE BUT IF THE- DAYS. BUT NOT
IDENTICAL FORMULA IS EASIER FOR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS I'D LIKE FOR
US TO CONSIDER. PUTTING MORE
AND DIFFERENT ON THEM IN A TIME
WHERE. WE NEED MORE FLEXIBILITY
I THINK IT. SOMETHING NEED TO
LOOK AT INCOMES. I'M THE OTHER
IS THAT. THAT I HAD RELATED TO
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS. AND
AGAIN SOME OF THIS IS BEEN
SAID. THAT YOU KNOW AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS ARE A FORM OF
CHILD CARE FOR SOME OF OUR-
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY AND
UP. IF OUR STUDENTS AREN'T
GOING TO AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
WHERE ARE THEY GOING. AS FAR AS
THAT A QUESTION FOR ME THAT IS
A QUOTE I MEAN THAT'S A
QUESTION FOR WHO EVER LET
ANSWER IT SORRY AND I. TURNED
AROUND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CAN
SEE NO THAT'S OKAY I CAN EITHER
I'M RIGHT IN FRONT. WITH IT'S-
VERY ODD DURING YOUR FACE YOU
TO. AS WELL SO I. THE EIGHTH IS
TO WHAT THE SLOTS FOR ACES WERE
NOT CUT. IT WAS THE OUT ON A
RATE. THAT WERE WOULD BE
ADDITIONAL ADD ON HUNDRED
MILLION THAT WENT TO THE RATE.
SO THE RATE WOULD JUST REVERT
BACK TO THE SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
RATE- SO THIS DID NOT ACTUALLY
CUT ACCESS. AND IF I MIGHT ADD
THIS IS THE PROPOSITION.
DROPPED DRAMATICALLY AS OUR
DISCUSSION EARLIER- WE DID WE
DISCUSSED DEATH. SO ALL
CATEGORICAL THAT SIDE OF
SPECIAL EDUCATION AND NUTRITION
WERE CUT. 50% IN ORDER TO STAY
WITHIN THE GUARANTEE ASUS
HOWEVER WAS NOT CUT 50% JUST.
MILLION BECAUSE THE FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IS. PART
OF THE PROPOSITION. FORTY NINE
COMMITMENT. OKAY I'LL PROBABLY
BEING BRING THIS UP AGAIN IN
THE NEXT SECTION BUT I MEAN I
THINK WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES
SOME OF THIS IS GOING TO BE
FUNDAMENTAL NEEDED IN TERMS OF
OUR ECONOMY. ARE RE OPENING AND
SO AFTER SCHOOL AND CHILD CARE
GOING TO BE IMPORTANT SO I'LL
LEAVE IT HEALTHCARE PART BUT-
I'LL GO. FOR TWO. I'M IN A
LITTLE BIT. AND THEN THE OTHER
PIECE- IS ABOUT MEAL PROGRAMS
AGAIN OUR SCHOOLS ARE DOING SO
MUCH BUT THE MEAL PROGRAMS-
HEALTHY EATING A IN HEALTH IS
AMONG THE MOST IMPORTANT THINGS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. AND I
KNOW THAT. MY COLLEAGUE HAS
BROUGHT. UP SOME ISSUES IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR NOT. A CD
IF A IN CD ARE WORKING
TOGETHER. YOU MENTIONED THERE
IS A PROPOSAL ARE WE GOING TO
SEE IN THEIR VERSION OF THIS
PROPOSAL. I'M A AND US IN. BLY
GIRL FOR. THAT THE C. A LITTLE
STABLE THIS WEEK. UNSTABLE THIS
WEEK- IN TERMS OF WHAT ELSE WE
MAY BE RECEIVING IT BUT WHAT IS
THAT PLAN THERE I MEAN THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT CAN BE. USED TO
BE. REALLY IMPORTANT. FEEL IN A
SEA LIKE. CALIFORNIA HAVE. YOU
AT. DOING MUCH ARMS IF THEY'RE
STATE THIS. SHOULD BE ABLE TO
WORK. AND GOT. IN SOME TO
FIGURE WHAT WE COULD DO AND
WE'RE GOING TO NEEDS. ARE FOOD
BAY ARE DOING IS MUCH AS CAN IN
THEY ALL SING IN AND IT FEELS
LIKE SCHOOLS COULD BE A PARTNER
TO THIS GREATER ISSUE WERE
TRYING TO ADDRESS. DECIDEDLY.
THAT WAS THE ENVY AND YET IT
WAS A THERE IS A QUESTION
SOMEWHERE IN THERE AND I'M
HOPING SOMEONE CAN RESPOND WHAT
ELSE ARE WE DOING- RELATED TO
THE MAIL PROGRAMS- WHAT DO YOU
DO WE DO WE THINK WE'RE GONNA.
SOMETHING ELSE A DIFFERENT AND
OF THE PROJECT THAT WE- NO
LONGER. THERE IS IT JUST
COMPLETELY ELIMINATED DOES IT
MAKE SENSE FOR OUR STATE TO
LOOK AT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
GIVING OUR STRONG ROOTS IN AG.
BUT IT'S FAR AS WHAT WAS IN AND
WHAT WAS OUT I'M NOT QUITE
SURE. ENHANCE AND PART OF
FINANCE US FAR AS WHAT IS IN
AND WHAT IS OUT I'M NOT. QUITE
SURE I'M FOLLOWING EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO IF YOU
COULD CLARIFY THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL. AND I THINK TO JUST ME
INTERJECT. THIS IS AN ISSUE I
KNOW SOMEONE OVER GALLAGHER
BROUGHT UP FROM AN AG DISTRICT
THAT. THE FARM TO SCHOOL
PROGRAM. IS IN AND IT'S ANOTHER.
I X. WHAT YOU. ARE FOOD NICK
FOOD ACT. SO YES UP AGAIN AT
THE FOOD NAG ISSUE AND IT'S
DIFFICULT FOR ME TO COMMENT ON
THAT PARTICULAR PROPOSAL OKAY
THAT'S WHERE I JUST HOPE THAT
WE THINK ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF
SCHOOLS I MEAN BECAUSE I DO
THINK THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
AS MUCH AS WE CAN- AND THERE
COULD BE A PARTNERSHIP THERE-
THIS IS A BIGGER ISSUE PEOPLE
PEOPLE ARE HUNGRY PEOPLE ARE
LOSING THEIR BOB AND SO I WANT
TO THINK ABOUT HOW. COMPLY ROLE
IN THIS DON'T WANT KIDS GO
HUNGRY SO I WANT TO ECHO OF
WHAT'S BEEN SAID BY I
APPRECIATE THAT THIS ISN'T THE
COMMITTEE IT'S A DIFFERENT
COMMITTEE AND THEN FINALLY I
HAVE A QUESTION RELATED TO.
JUSTIN AGE. AND I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT- WHY WAS THIS AGE
CAP PUT IN PLACE AND WHAT
PROBLEMS IT TRYING TO SOLVE. I
NEVER OUT. OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE A GOOD FIT FOR THIS
THAT THE EVER. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SOTHE-
THE PROPOSAL ORIGINATED BECAUSE
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT SOME OF
THE MORE EGREGIOUS AT CAPE IF
THAT WE PART OF. WHERE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE ENROLLING STUDENTS
YOU KNOW. WELL INTO THEIR
FIFTIES OR SIXTIES IN SOME
CASES AND CLASSIFYING THEM AS A
SECOND GRADER TO AVOID I'M
HAVING TO DO THAT THE STATE
ASSESSMENT. AND THEN GENERATING
I'LL SEE IF THAT BOTHERS FOR
THOSE STUDENTS. SO WE- WE
ATTEMPTED TO STRIKE A BALANCE-
BYE BYE CRAFTING THE LANGUAGE
TO ALLOW FOR LTFS APPORTIONMENT
TO BE GENERATED. FOR THESE-
STUDENTS THROUGH THE AGE OF
TWENTY SIX- AND THEN THE YOU
KNOW IT ANY STUDENT OVER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SEVEN WOULD NOT
GENERATE ELSE GET HALF DOLLARS.
GOT IT SO I GUESS IT YOU KNOW
MY FEEDBACK IS THAT IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME THAT- YOU KNOW THAT
THERE ARE PROBABLY WAYS TO
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM YOU'RE
TRYING. TO US ALL FOR- IN A WAY
THAT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
IMPACTS THE SPECIALTY PROGRAMS
I KNOW THAT YOU KNOW MY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR A COLLEAGUE
FROM RIVERSIDE MENTIONED A
PROGRAM THAT'S SPECIFIC TO
FARMWORKERS- MY DISTRICT WAS
LOOKING TO SEEN. PROGRAM COME
INTO THE DISTRICT AND IT'S JUST
SO UNIQUE- AND IT'S SUCH A AND
NICHE PROGRAM- AND- I WISH THAT
WE HAD- FOLKS. WHO WERE OF SIR
IN AGES WHERE A SECOND GRADE
READING LEVEL WAS JUST TO GIVE
AND BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT SO
MANY. OF THE INDIVIDUALS WERE
TRYING TO HELP AVE VERY
DIFFERENT NEEDS SO- IF THERE IS
A WAY TO THINK ABOUT SOME OF
THE SPECIALTY PROGRAMS WHILE
STILL SOBBING FOR THE PROBLEM
THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO SOLVE I
HOPE THAT WE WOULD CONSIDER
THAT. THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
SOMEWHERE MEMBER. AND AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
ACTUALLY HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD.
YES GO AHEAD. DID YOU WANT TO.
TESTIFY YES THEY MEMBER LIMóN
YOU HAD MENTIONED YOU HAD ASKED
THE CVT WAS WORKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CDFA AND I
JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT WE
ARE WE HAVE WHAT'S CALLED THE
STRING STRONG PARTNERSHIP. WITH
CDFA AND WE ARE ALSO SHARING
LIST OF LOCAL FARMS WITH
SCHOOLS WE'RE ALSO WORKING WITH
THE IF YOU SAW ON THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL A VERY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP AROUND OUR LOCAL
FARMS AND SCHOOLS IN MAKING
THAT CONNECTION AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO ADVOCATE WITHIN
THAT WORK. OKAY YOU SOME
REMEMBER O'DONNELL I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- THANK YOU
THROUGH TO THE PRESENTERS TODAY
THIS IS NOT AN EASY TASK.
CERTAINLY ON THE COMMITTEE BUT
ALSO ON THE STAFF SIDE TWO WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
THUS FAR. BECAUSE JUST ABOUT
ANY CUT WE FIGHT UP HERE IS
GOING TO RESULT IN SOMETHING
ELSE GETTING CUT I THINK WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- WITH THAT ALL
JUST. TO THE COMMON AND THAT'S
ABOUT LIABILITY- WE NEED TO
CONTEMPLATE SLIPPING SOMETHING
INTO THE SOME LANGUAGE IN THE
BUDGET THAT SPEAKS TO LIABILITY
BECAUSE NO INSTITUTION PUBLIC
OR OTHERWISE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IS GOING TO BE ABLE
TO OPEN IF WE IF THEY ARE HELD
LIABLE. FOR EVERY MEDICAL
ATTENTION LONG LINE NOW SO
THAT'S JUST SOMETHING TO
CONTEMPLATE I KNOW SCHOOL DISH.
FEARFUL OF THE HE HELD UP.
DOING IT SIX FOR ANY GOING
WHERE SO THAT IS SOMETHING WE
NEED TO CAUGHT. YES TO A
QUESTION IT. FOUR POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DO DO DO
YOU AGREE WITH THAT FIGURE.
THAT'S FOR THE ALEJO. I THINK-
SO I THINK OUR- RECOMMENDATION
OR OUR OFFICE PUT PRETTY TO
FISCAL OUTLOOK- A WEEK BEFORE
ME REVISION BUT WE HAD A
PROBLEM DEFINITION THAT WAS. A
LITTLE DIFFERENT BUT THEN- BOTH
THE MAGNITUDE OF DIFFERENCE OUR
WITH NOT OF IT WASN'T A BIG AT
THE THEME FROM LOOKING AT THE
TOP A NUMBER I'M WE DO UP TO
DIFFERENT ARE. REVENUE BASE
SCENARIOS WILL CALL THE SHIPS
AND EN EL IN OUR BUT YOU SHOULD
CENTER BEING A BIT MORE UP. IN
TERMS OF HOW QUICKLY BECOME
RECOVERS. TLC MORE PESSIMISTS.
I'M ARE COMPARING. OUR FORECAST
THE MAYOR VISION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE. VISION IS
VERY SIMILAR TO OUR OUT STATE
ARE MORE. SET EVEN IF I COULD
THERE BE IS ABOUT BILLION
DOLLARS LOWER THAN A SO IN
TERMS OF WHAT GOING ON WITH
THAT THIS IS CLOSE TO ARE MORE
PRESSING SIX NERIO SOME OF THE
BIG DIPPER IS THE NUMBER WERE
JUST TERMS OF YOU FOR EXAMPLE
THE NOTE YOU THINK OF GEN YOUR
PROPOSALS ARE STILL THERE NOT.
PEOPLE ARE THE- GENETIC. THE
PART THERE AND THEN CUTTING THE
ARE IF CONSIDER A SOLUTION AND
THAT. ARE IN THEIR ME REPEAT.
OF I ONE OF THE BIG BUT REVENUE
THINK WE'RE- WE'RE PRETTY. IF
YOU'RE AT OUR MARKETS. SNOW SO
ON COST BECAUSE WISE. GOING
FORWARD YOU IN THE SAME PLACE.
I THINK WE'RE STILL LOOKING AT
THE WE'RE STILL AT THE ARMED. I
KNOW IN OUR AND ON THE AND IT'S-
BUT- YOU KNOW. IT'S NOT AS BIG
OF A- DIFFERENCE I. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE A OF DIFFERENT I
KNOW THAT ON. I'M SOME OF THE
OF PROGRAMS THAT THAT EDUCATION
AT THE SUPER GOT HELPING YOU
SERVICES. OUR ARMED. WE ARE
LOOK UP OF QUE BUT A FEW BUT I
DON'T THINK AT POINT WE'VE HAD
ENOUGH. TO TELL YOU THAT WE
THINK THAT WE HAVE SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THOSE PURPLE GONNA
LIKE STILL DOING SOME RE. YES
THANK YOU THANK YOU ADJUSTS
ONCE EVERY. COME FROM. FIRST
SHE- OR HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE FOR. POINT HAVE THAT
BILLION WILL TO A ONLY THOSE.
THAT RECEIVE CONSTANT MONEY.
THAT'LL BE A TOPIC OF
CONVERSATION AS WE GO FORWARD
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE- I'M
LOOKING AT TWO STUDIES HERE
THERE'S A SELF A STUDY THERE'S
TWO. GROUPS ONE IS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND. WHAT A SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND I KNOW WE'RE SWITCHING
THE FUNDING SOURCES OUTSIDE OF
NINETY EIGHT NOW IT APPEARS.
BUT I THOSE ARE PRETTY
EXPENSIVE STUDIES FOR THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH TO CONDUCT.
AND YOU'RE NOT CONDUCTING THOSE
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH SO I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT WHEN THE STUDIES
COME BACK AND BE. YOU KNOW.
YOUR STUDY TO- WE MAY OR MAY
NOT. AGREE WITH THE PREMISE OF
THE STUDIES ARE THE OUTCOMES OF
THOSE STUDIES BUT THEY DO SEEM
LIKE EXTREMELY. EXPENSIVE
VENTURES. AT THIS POINT IN OUR-
IN OUR IN OUR- IN OUR HISTORY-
SIDE SO I AM CONFUSED ABOUT AND
ALSO WHO DOES OF STUDIES. IT IS
IT IS THAT NEEDS TO BE A TOPIC
OF CONVERSATION AS WELL. LET'S
SEE SOME OTHER ITEMS IN HERE
ARE WITH REGARD TO THE CUT K.
TWELVE STRONG WORK FORCE
PROGRAMS- THERE'S MORE TO THIS
IS C. T. MONEY- TYPICALLY LAST
COUPLE YOU'RE A HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION ON NE SIDE HER FIFTY
MILLION ON THE THEIR SIDE
HUNDRED FIFTEEN IS A CD. OVER
THE GONNA THE COMMUTE. WHICH IS
TO MISTER AN VERY OPEN AT THE
CAN COLLEGE HAVE NOVA.
ADMINISTERING K. TWELVE MONEY
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE BUT WHY
WOULD YOU SPLIT BOTH OF THOSE
BUCKETS OF MONEY WHY WOULDN'T
YOU JUST SHIFT THEM BACK CD
STORE HAS A STORE. VAN THE
ENERGY THAT IS DOLED OUT THESE
DOLLARS AND YET HEAR WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING WELL WE'RE STILL
GONNA HAVE TO ENTITIES DOLE
THEM OUT. AMBER BUT WE'RE GONNA
CUT EACH PART DOWN WHAT COULD
SOMEONE SHARE WITH ME THE
REASONING BEHIND THAT. EVER
WONDER WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. SO THE- THE
ADMINISTRATION- CHOSE TO REDUCE
BOTH PROGRAMS AS WELL AS EVERY
OTHER CTV CATEGORICAL THAT
EXISTS OUTSIDE OF BELL FEEDBACK
BY FIFTY PERCENT. AND THAT IS
WHY- YOU SEE YOU KNOW BOTH
PROGRAMS BEING RETAINED BUT AT
THE LOWER LEVEL. THANK YOU JUST
TO ME IT SEEMS A NO BRAINER.
LOOK THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY AND PUT REGARD AND
THE- THE COMMUNITY CALL.
ADMINISTRATION OF THE STRONG
WORK FORCE PROGRAM THE CD OF
THE CAGE SIDE. PACIFIC LEE- DO
YOU JUST LIKE A TIME FOR
EFFICIENCY ALONE A- OF SCALE TO
SWITCH IT BACK OVER TO CD WITH
JUST STARKLY. HAS DONE A PRETTY
GOOD JOB OF IT AND THE RESULTS
OF AN RATHER NON CONTROVERSIAL
SO I HOPE THAT WILL BE
SOMETHING YOU'LL CONTEMPLATE-
WHAT ELSE DO I HAVE HERE.
QUICKLY CAN YOU TALK TO A CD
PROGRAMS THE CHARTER AGE CAP I
ACTUALLY AGREE WITH THAT
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK FIRST
GRADERS- FORTY YEAR OLD SHOULD
BE ENROLLED AS FIRST GRADERS
SHOULD THEY RECEIVE ADULT
EDUCATION SHOULD THEY RECEIVE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITY
ABSOLUTELY BUT WHAT'S BEEN
GOING ON AND WE SHOULDN'T HAVE
A FORTY YEAR OLD SITTING NEXT
TO A FIVE YEAR OLD IN A
CLASSROOM OR NOT THAT'S
HAPPENING I DON'T KNOW BUT-
DON'T INSIST. NOT NOT. ALL THAT
WE HAVE FUNDING FOR ADULT ED SO
WE WANT TO SERVE ADULTS LET'S
LET'S SERVING WITH THE DAHLE
TED. AN ADULT AT SERVICES NOT
PUT THEM IN A FIRST GRADE
CLASSROOM- ON THE ON THE- ON
THE CUTS IN THE ON THE SEAT C.
T. PROGRAMS- BUT WE COULD HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT- BUILDING
IN AN AUTOMATIC CLAWBACK SHOULD
FEDERAL STIMULUS MONEY COME.
BECAUSE THOSE CUTS REMAIN. EVEN
IF YOU GET BACK FOR WITH
FEDERAL STEM MONEY PER THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BUDGET NOW AS I
UNDERSTAND. WHAT ELSE ARE US
DISTRICTS TRICIA PROGRAM I
BELIEVE THERE'S EIGHT POINT
EIGHT BILLION FROM THE CARES
ACT- HAVE WE ALREADY ALLOCATED
THIS MONEY AND IS IT GOING OUT
TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT ARE
QUITE FRANKLY SERVING MORE THAN
JUST THAT'S BECAUSE THEY ARE
THE MODERN DAY SUPPLY OUR
SCHOOLS HAVE ENDED UP BEING THE
MOPAR NAY SU PLAN THEY'RE
SERVING NOT JUST K<c.cyan> BUT</c>
ENTIRE MAYES WHO NEED FOOD THE
MOST BASIC NEED WE HAVE. SO CAN
YOU SHARE WITH US. I'M GONNA
HAVE MY AT COOLEY COOPER THE
NUTRITION ASSIGNMENT COME UP.
HELLO ENHANCE WOULD FINANCE-
YES CALIFORNIA'S SHARE OF THAT
EIGHT POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS IS A SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WE BUILT INTO THE MAY REVISION
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT THOSE
RESOURCES WILL ULTIMATELY HAVE
ENOUGH FLEXIBILITY TO BE. ABLE
TO HELP OUR SCHOOL FOOD IN
FLORIDA. THANK YOU WOULD THAT
NECESSARILY INCLUDE FAMILIES
AND OF LINED UP. FOR FOOD
CURRENTLY I DON'T BELIEVE IT
DOES. THAT IF WE CAN DO IT IF
IT IS PERMISSIVE YOU KNOW AND
FEDERAL I HOPE- ITALY'S
CONTEMPLATE THAT BECAUSE AGAIN
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS NOT ALL
ARE FEEDING THE ENTIRE. ARE
WITH THAT- ON ON THE SPECIAL ED
FUNDING- I HOPE WE CAN LOOK
TOWARDS CREATING WITH WITH BUT
THE GOVERNOR'S MONEY THAT IS
ALLOCATED FOR THE SPECIAL ED-
THAT WE COULD. POSSIBLY LOOK
CREATING AWAITED FORMULA FOR
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT SERVE MORE
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS AND OTHER
SOME DISTRICTS. HAVE A LOT OF
SPECIAL STUDENTS WITH OTHERS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS DON'T. THERE'S
PAST PRACTICE OF DOING IT WE DO
IT WITH THE CONCENTRATION. THE
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
CLINT GRANTS WE DO WE DO IT FOR
THEM. AND IN SOME DISTRICTS IN
PARTICULAR. WHAT WE HAVE IS
CHARTER SCHOOLS HAVE COME AND
THEY'RE SERVING STUDENTS ARE
NOT. SPECIAL NEEDS CHILDREN.
AND THAT'S A THAT THAT THAT.
THAT HAVE CREATE SOME A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL BURDEN ON
THE DISTRICT THAT THEN DOES
SERVE THE SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD
SO THAT THAT SHOULD BE A POINT
OF CONVERSATION GOING FORWARD.
SOME OTHER THINGS AS WHAT WE
MIGHT WANT TO CONTEMPLATE IS-
REDUCE THE ROUTINE RESTRICTED
THAT'S ACCOUNT. I DELAYED-
DELAY INSTRUCTIONAL MATERIAL
ADOPTIONS TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME CLASS SIZE
PENALTIES TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE
THE LCF UPGRADE SPAN ADJUSTMENT
WE MAKE WE MIGHT WANT ALLOW FOR
MORE FLEXIBILITY THERE SURPLUS
PROPERTY I BELIEVE THAT'S IN
THE TRAILER BILL RIGHT NOW AS I
UNDERSTAND IT. POTENTIALLY LOOK
AT SOME PEPPERONI. SUSPENSION
OF THAT SO THE TEACHERS CAN
RETIRE MAKE YOUR- SOME PROGRAM
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT AS WELL OF
SUSPEND MANDATES THE START TIME
BILL RIGHT PROBABLY THE WORST
BILL OF MY TENURE HERE- FORCING
SCHOOLS TO STARTED A CERTAIN
TIMES CAN BE VERY EXPENSIVE I'M
HEARING FROM DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE ABOUT THAT. IT'S
GOING TO BE VERY EXPENSIVE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT- INSTRUCTIONAL
DAYS WE HEARD THAT WE NEED SOME
FLEXIBILITY SO THE DISTRICTS
CAN GO HYBRID WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT. NEXT YEAR IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE AND I THINK IT'S
GOING TO LOOK LIKE IT'S GONNA
LOOK VERY DIFFERENT IN
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS- SOME
DISTRICTS ARE PROBABLY GONNA
HAVE A HYBRID WHERE THEY MIGHT
GO MONDAY WEDNESDAY FRIDAY ONE
WEEK TUESDAY THURSDAY THEM ACT
EXTEND THE OTHER KIDS FEEL ON
THE OTHER DAYS. SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT DISTRICTS HAVE
THE- THE ABILITY TO- TO- TO GO
HYBRID IF THEY NEED TO FOR
SAFETY REASONSALONG- WITH THAT
I THINK THAT IS ABOUT IT RIGHT
NOW. AND I'VE SAID MY PIECE
MISTER CHAIR BACK TO YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU I KNOW WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF. PUBLIC COMMENT AS WELL.
ON THE K. TWELVE PIECE BUT NOW
WE'RE GOING TO GET INTO THE
EARLY EDUCATION. MAY REVISED
PROPOSALS- WHICH ARE ARE JUST
AS- PROBLEMATIC BUT MAY HAVE A
MORE LASTING IMPACT SO WITH
THAT WE'RE GOING TO ASK THE LA-
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND CD.
TO GO OVER THE E. C. E. MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS. GREAT SO I'M
GONNA CONTINUE ON THE HANDOUT
THAT WAS PROVIDED TO YOU- ONE
ON PAGE- OF THE HANDOUT. BUT
BEFORE THE MAJOR IT PAPA BEGIN.
OF THE APPROACH OF THE EARLY
FOR THEIR THE FIRST THING IS
10% REDUCTIONS TO REIMBURSEMENT
RATES SO- FOR THE BATTERIES
PROGRAMS THAT ARE FUNDED ON THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. TO BE A
10% ACROSS THE BOARD REDUCTION
TO WHAT'S TO WHAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING- FOR THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
THAT DIRECT CONTACT PROGRAMS
LIKE GENERAL CHECKERED STATE
PRESCHOOL. OF THE COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTING ADJUSTMENTS ME
THAT WAS- INCLUDED IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET WOULD BE
RESCINDED AND THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL 10% REDUCTION- BOTH
OF THESE PRODUCTIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE FEDERAL
TRICKLING WHICH SO THEY ALSO
WOULD BE. LIKE I'LL SEE AFFECT
SOME OF THE CATEGORICAL
CONNECTION IF THERE IS NOT A
MONEY THOSE. THOSE CUTS WOULD
BE RESCINDED. I'M THE NEXT IS
THE REDUCTION IN PRESCHOOL
SLOTS SO THE ADMIN AND- IS HAD
INITIALLY ARE TO OF THOUSANDS
THE- START TEN THOUSAND
PRESCHOOL. ABOUT THE J. PULLED
BOTH A THOUSAND HAVE BEEN RISK.
NOT BEEN- ALLOCATED ACROSS THE
STATE- THAT ADDS UP TO A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL PROPPING THE
GENERAL FUND AND A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE MILLION. ARE NOT
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND A
REDUCTIONS TO STAY PRICKLES
LOTS THE NEXT. THING THAT'S
UNDERNEATH THAT ONE TIME
AUGMENTATIONS THAT WERE IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET-
BUT THE BIGGEST APART THE
FUNDING WERE UP FUNDING FOR-
EARLY EDUCATION TUCKER
FACILITIES- OR FOR FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION RENOVATION. AND
THEN- FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT- THOSE WERE ONE
TIME FUNDING FUNDS PROVIDED IN
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN SPENT YESAND THOSE FOLKS
HAVE BEEN TAKING BACK INCOME
WILL BE SWEPT IF THIS IS
APPROVED. AND THERE'S ALSO TEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR. A MEDINA
TO START THE E. THAT FUNDING
THAT IS ALSO BEEN REMOVED MAYOR
VISION. FINALLY THE OTHER. ARE
THE OTHER THING THAT I WOULD AT
HERE IS THAT IS A OF. A CAN. OF
A PROPOSAL TO RE ORGANIZE- SORT
OF CHAKRA PROGRAMS THE JANUARY
PROPOSAL WAS TO CREATE A NEW
DEPARTMENT OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
DEVELOPMENT- THAT WOULD BE
WITHIN THE HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY. THE PROPOSAL
HAS NOT BEEN MODIFIED TO BE TO
SHIFT- IS STILL SENDING WORRIED
SHIFTING ALL OF THE ROGER
PROGRAMS AND- GENERAL
CHOCOLATE. I'M INTO A NEW PLACE
BUT INSTEAD OF GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF GOING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
I'M THE NEXT PAGE WE TALK ABOUT
SOME OF THE DIRECTLY FROM
AUGMENTATIONS IN THE MIRROR
VISION. AND THIS IS THE- DUE
TO- ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING.
THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT PART
THE FUNDING HERE. ONE IS AN
ONGOING- CHAO KERN DEVELOPMENT
BLOCK GRANT AGMENTATION AND
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT. I THINK
THE STATE OF NEW THAT THEY GOT
A WORD OF THIS AT THE END OF
DECEMBER AND THE
ADMINISTRATION'S DIDN'T HAVE
TIME TO ENTER THE INGREDIENTS
THE JANUARY BUDGET- BUT NOW
THAT THE CORPORATION OF THE
MARRIAGE ANNOUNCES FIFTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL.
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT DOCTORS.
I'M DOT NEXT PART IS AT. THE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IT ONE TIME- CCTV
DEFINING THAT THE STATE
RECEIVED AS PART OF BURKE CARES
ACT. AND THAT'S DISTRIBUTED AND
THERE ARE THREE DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING TO USE THAT FUNDING.
THE FIRST IS A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS TO
COVER THE CURRENT YEAR COSTS.
OF THE OPEN NINETY NOW BREAKS
SO- THERE WERE A COUPLE OF X.
EXECUTIVE ORDERS IT'S AN
ACTIONS- AND SOME ARE. BURNT
THE LETTERS THAT PROVIDED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOUR PP- FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS- TO- A PROVIDES
EMERGENCY VOUCHERS FOR SINCE
WORKERS. AND IN A VARIETY OF
POLICY CHANGES THAT TRACTOR
RIGHT THE MORE FISCAL RELIEF TO
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS. CANDLES
ARE ADDING UP TO HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO MILLION. I THE REMAINING IF
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT USES. OF
THE REMAINING FUND HI AND
TWENTY FIVE MILLION I WOULD BE.
FOR PROVIDERS BASED ON NUMBER
OF SUCH AS CHILDREN THAT
THEY'RE SERVING. AND THEN
SEVENTY THREE MILLION FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL- TEMPORARY
ALTERNATIVE THE MINIATURES. SO
NOW GOING TO THE NEXT PAGE
TALKING OUR COVERAGE OF OUR
OVERALL COMMENTS HERE. AGAIN
FOR MOST OF THE KEY TWELVE-
TRUCK WITH THEM HE TOLD WORLD I
THINK WE WERE JUST A HIGHLIGHT
HERE AGAIN. THAT THE PROPOSAL
HERE JUST ASSUMES THAT WE CAN
TO GO BACK TO THE WORLD AS IT
WAS BEFORE THERE'S NOTHING.
HERE SIR CONTEMPLATING WHETHER
AT THE EMERGENCY ORDERS THAT
WERE IN PLACE WERE TO CONTINUE-
AND WHAT PROVIDERS WORK TO DO
IF WE DON'T END UP BAKER GOING
BACK TO NORMAL. I'M JUST- AS A
REFRESHER WHEN THE STATE DID-
CREATED EMERGENCY THERE'S A
VARIETY OF EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
MANAGEMENT BOLTON'S. THAT ON
CERTAIN SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS
FOR- CHALKER PROVIDERS ONE OF
THEM IS TO LIMIT GROUP SIZES
WHICH IS SOMETHING THAT- ARE AT
OR NOT JUST BECAUSE OF THE
CLASSROOM SIZES WHICH SOMETHING
THAT. HAVE BEEN YOU NEED NO
MATTER WHAT SIZE YOU CAN HAVE
MORE THAN A THIRD NUMBER
pMORE ADULTS PER STUDENT TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN
ANY PARTICULAR. AREA OF THESE
ARE ACTIONS THAT WERE NECESSARY
TO DEAL WITH- THE COVER
NINETEEN OUTBREAK BUT THE DO
PLACE A LOT. ON. SO NOT ARE
HAVING THE KITCHEN BUT WHAT.
WITH THE CIVIC BEFORE IMPORTANT
FRIEND OR- BAREFOOT SITUATE.
I'M WE WOULD SAY ON THE ON THE-
TO REDUCE OUR VOUCHERS 10%
ACROSS BOARD AT THE WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THIS WOULD DOES NOT-
DOES NOT ALIGNED WITH THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE. THAT'S
THE WAY THAT THESE- RATES ARE
STEP ACROSS THE STATE- BY DOING
ACROSS THE BORDER ACTION AS
OPPOSED TO SAY MOVING TO A
DIFFERENT PERCENT ON THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE MEANS THAT
FAMILIES WILL HAVE DIFFERENT
LEVELS OF ACCESS TO THEIR
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE SO.
IN SOME CASES THAT 10%
REDUCTION MADE STILL MEAN THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PROVIDERS THAT
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO USE THE
VOUCHER FOR IN OTHER CASES THAT
MIGHT BE SEVERELY LIMITED AND
SO WE WOULD RECOMMEND THE
REDUCTION BE MADE. BY TAKING IT
TO A TO THE LOWER PERCENTILE IN
SERVICE. I'M IN IN TERMS OF-
BUT WE HAVE A FEW OTHER THINGS
TO CONSIDER IN TERMS OF
MINIMIZING RATE REDUCTIONS. WE
WERE NOT THAT THERE ARE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN PROP SIXTY
FOUR FUNDS THAT ARE SCHEDULED
TO. OUR GO OUT IN THE BUDGET
YEAR THAT ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
FOR NEW GENERAL TUCKER SLOTS.
ARE BOTH THAT FUNDING COULD
POTENTIALLY BE REPURPOSE TO BE
USED TO MITIGATE THE- NINETY
RATE. RATE REDUCTIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING- AND ALTHOUGH WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE WOULD BE
LESS CHILDREN SIR. WE DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE ABILITY
OF PROVIDERS TO STAY IN
BUSINESS IF THEY'RE FACING A
LOT OF COST PRESSURES AND FOR
MAKING REDUCTIONS- TO THE
RATES- THE LEGISLATURE ALSO
COULD CONSIDER SOME OTHER-
REDUCTIONS THAT DO NOT. GO
DIRECTLY DO NOT ADDRESS
SERVICES SUCH AS- THE ADMIN
COSTS FOR ABOUT YOUR PROGRAMS.
OR THE- THE PRESCHOOL ALREADY
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM. I'M WE WERE
NOT ALSO IF THE LEGISLATURE'S
INTERESTED IN FAVOR DO THING
THE NUMBER. OF SLOTS IN SOME
WAY WE WOULD RECOMMEND DOING
THAT BASED ON THE IN. REDUCING
THE AMOUNT OF ABILITY THRESHOLD
SO WE'RE STILL PRIORITIZING.
CHILDREN WITH THE HIGHEST NEED.
AND FAMILIES WITH ITS NEED-
COUPLE OF OTHER COMMENTS WOULD
MAKE REGARDING THAT ONE TIME
FUNDING FROM THE CARES ACT WE
RECOMMEND USING ALL THAT FOR.
THE FIRST TAPINGS AGAIN
RECOGNIZING THAT WE HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE COST
PRESSURES THAT PROVIDERS. WILL
BE FACING. ARE WE THINK ARE
USING THAT ENTIRE THE HUNDRED
AND- RATHER THAN JUST BEING ONE
THIRTY FIVE. I'M NOT DOING ALL
OF. THE AS- FUNDING DIRECTLY
PERSPECTIVES TYPE IN THE
PROVIDING RELIEF FIGHTERS WOULD
BE- PREFERABLE. WE WOULD NOTE
THAT THE- THE FIFTY MILLION
THAT WAS PROVIDED- FOR
EMERGENCY DOCTORS IN THE
CURRENT YEAR WE DON'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THAT SPENT. AND SO WE
THINK THAT ONE ALTERNATIVE TO
PROVIDING THAT SEVENTY THREE
MILLION- FOR ADDITIONAL
TEMPORARY VOUCHERS IS TO MOVE
AT THE STATE AND- THEN JUST
ALLOW THE FIFTY MILLION THAT
WAS. INCLUDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR- THROUGH A SECTION THAT
OFFICE TO ALLOW THAT TO BE USED
FOR. THE BUDGET YEARS WELL. AND
FINALLY WE WILL CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND REJECT. IN THE
PROPOSALS FOR REORGANIZATION-
WE HAVE CONCERNS. IN IN THE
INITIAL PROPOSAL WE CAN YOU
HAVE. I'M CONCERNED THE ONGOING
COSTS OF THE- OR OF THE- WE ARE.
IS NOT CLEAR. WE ALSO WOULD NOT.
BY SHIFTING PROGRAM THE DF
RIGHT NOW ME BE PRETTY
DIFFICULT COULD THREE THAT
THERE RIGHT NOW ARE PROJECTED
TO BE SIGNIFICANT HE FILLED IN-
VIRTUALLY ALL THE DEFENSE
PROGRAMS. SO WITH MAYBE A
DIFFICULT TIME FOR
ADMINISTRATIVELY THAT CHANGE TO
OCCUR. SOFT UP THERE- AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. YEAH ONLY THREE GIVE
IT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
EVER DID A VERY GOOD JOB OF
LAYING OUT OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT ARE IN THE NAY REVISION SO
I WON'T GO INTO DETAIL- BUT
JUST SO YOU KNOW OVERALL-
BEHIND THIS PROPOSAL IS THE
COMMITMENT TO TRY TO RETAIN
ACCESS WHICH IS WHY YOU SEE
ACTUALLY THE RATE REDUCTION AS
OPPOSED ANY REDUCTION TO- SLOTS
OR- ACCESS- WE TRIED TO DO THIS
IN SEVERAL WAYS ONE WAS BY
FINDING EFFICIENCIES SWEEPING
STATE IN SWEEPING UNUSED- SLOTS
IN THE PRESCHOOL AND ACTUALLY
PUTTING THE POTS ON THE
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL AND-
EXPAND. THE PROGRAM AT THIS
POINT IN TIME ADDITIONALLY AND
TO USE THE FEDERAL CARES ACT
FUNDING TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE TO PROVIDE ASSISTANCE
TO OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND
ALSO- MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM TO WORKERS-
AND THOSE CHILDREN. HIGHEST
RATE. SO WITH THAT I ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS AT THIS
POINT. OKAY THANK YOU. THE PART
OF EDUCATION. I'M GONNA. YEAH.
THE NAME MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THEIR NUMBER MORE AGAIN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT PUBLIC- TONY
THURMOND IN TOTAL THE
GOVERNOR'S ME REVISED PROPOSES
THREE POINT SIX BILLION FOR
EARLY LEARNING CARE PROGRAMS
CURRENTLY ADMINISTERED BY THIS
P. D. WHICH IS ABOUT AN 8%
THREE HUNDRED AND TWELVE
MILLION DECREASE FROM JANUARY
AND A FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FOUR MILLION THIRTY. HEY SERRA.
YEAH AND I'M GONNA ASK YOU TO
TAKE A LITTLE TIME OUT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A FIVE MINUTE.
RECESS REAL QUICK. OKAY GREAT
BACK THANK YOU. ONLY I CAN SHUT
DOWN THE I THINK WE'RE AT THAT
PARTICULAR. THANK.
YEAH. HELLO
IT WOULD BE ANOTHER. REALLY
GOOD. YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH
ALWAYS. WE CAN'T ALWAYS YOUR.
RIGHT. PROBABLY. WE WERE. THERE
WERE YOU LOOKING AT. OKAY OKAY.
HELLO. A LITTLE. YEAH. YEAH OR-
YEAH. YOUR YEAH. YEAH. WE WILL
BE. I'M NOT. VERY VERY.
PROBABLY. SO YOU WANT. RIGHT WE
GET OUR FROM MY VERY ACTIVE WE
WANTED TO HAVE. A LINE. I DON'T
KNOW YOU GOT THREE YEARS. UHHUH
UHHUH. SO BASICALLY- ALRIGHT
WELL EVERYTHING BOB. THE FOURTH
OKAY OKAY MOVED AWAY FROM. ALL
WITH THEIR. THE LITTLE YEAH.
YEAH MY BROTHER IN LAW. NO NO
NO HE WAS THIRTY FOUR YEARS- WE
REMEMBER THAT MORE THAN ONE.
EVERY DAY I GO SEPTEMBER NO
THAT. LIKE PLEASE SEE WHAT WILL
HAPPEN. ALSO REALLY LONG SHAFT-
YEAH THE OVER HIS HEAD OKAY I
GOT. THAT FROM THE OTHER PHONE
CALLS ONE OF. THE FIVE BOND
INVESTORS. ALONE YEAH. AND THEN
WHAT YEAH YEAH YEAH AND- YEAH
OKAY MAYBE FROM. RESUME YEAH SO
THE MORNING AROUND EIGHT THAT
ARE. TRYING TO TELL. ANYTHING
YEAH I WOULD PUT A GUN ON OF SO
THEY PUT IT ON THE LOOKING AT
THE. HAD A SIMPLE RETAIL SO I'M
MORE YEAH GOOD YEAH BUT- WE'RE.
ALREADY WE WILL. THREE AT THIS
HEARING WE GET THE TECHNOLOGY
BACK IN BACK IN ORDER. A GOOD.
OKAY EXCELLENT SO YES WE ARE
NOW ONTHE SECOND PART OF THE
AGENDA THIS IS THEIR EARLY
EDUCATION SEGMENT LEAD TO CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL AND WE SO
FAR I'VE HEARD THE
PRESENTATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN THE
ALEJO AND WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION-
GOING OVER THESE PROPOSALS
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE-
FOR THE PATIENTS- SERRA NEVER
WORKING HERE AS WELL AS THE
AUDIENCE WE HAD ANOTHER HEARING
THAT SEVERAL OF THE MEMBERS HAD
TO GOV BUT AND COME BACK. SO
WITH THAT- LET'S PUT IT. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
THERE NEVER MORGAN AGAIN DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT AT TONY THURMOND
SO I ALREADY WENT OVER A LITTLE
BIT THAT GREAT DECREASE IN THE
PROJECT TO EARLY LEARNING CARE
WHICH IS FIVE HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO MILLION THIRTEEN PERCENT.
FROM IN TWENTY PROJECT WE ARE
CONCERNED BY. INTEGRAL ROLE WE
KNOW QUALITY EARLY LEARNING
CARE PLAYS AND SUPPORTING A
STRONG ECONOMY IT PROVIDES
ESSENTIAL CHILD CARE TO WORKING
FAMILIES AND IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTAL OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY ITS MOST VULNERABLE
I WON'T GO INTO DETAILS OF THE
PROPOSAL SINCE FINANCE AN ALLEY
OUR PARTY COVER THEM BUT I DO
WANT TO THE LATE TWO OR THREE
MAIN THINGS. FIRST ONE I THINK
LED TO IN MINUTES XIN THE
PARTNERSHIP FAR AND HELPING US
THE DRESS CODE NINETEEN ISSUES
AS THEY HAVE ARISEN WE ARE
SHAPE IDENTIFICATION OF
RESOURCES THE CITY SEE THAT
ALLOWED US TO PROVIDE EMERGENCY
CHILDCARE TO ESSENTIAL WORKERS
AND- FIVE. FOR PAYMENTS WE ALL
PRE THE INCLUSION OF THE EIGHT
MILLION IN THE MAY REVISED TO
WAYS WAY FAMILY FEES THROUGH
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY AS
WE KNOW A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES
ARE STRUGGLING. WELL I
UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL IT.
SITUATION THE STATE FIND AT
SOUTH THEN WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED THAT THE EIGHT THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION IN
SAVINGS IDENTIFIED WITH THAT
10% PROPOSED RATE CUT FOR
SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE PROVIDERS.
RUNS COUNTER TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL OF
SUPPORTING ACCESS TO CARE AND
SHORING UP PROVIDER SOLVENCY TO
ENSURE THE STATE'S CHILD CARE
SYSTEM SURVIVES THIS CRISIS.
OUR PROGRAMS WERE ALREADY
STRUGGLING WITH RATE AT BARELY
ALLOWED THEM TO STAY AFLOAT.
FOR EXAMPLE WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET RATE PROPOSAL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM OR C. F. P.
P. THE RATES WERE FOUR THOUSAND
LESS PER YEAR THAN WHAT THE
STATE CURRENTLY PAYS FOR
VOUCHER CENTER BASED PRESCHOOL.
BASED ON A MARKET RATE SURVEY
MANY PROVIDERS HAVE CHOSEN NOT
TO APPLY FOR PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION FUNDS IN THE PAST
CITING THESE LOW RATES AND IN
IN ABOUT. SPEAKER SPACE AND HE
TEACHERS AT THE OFFERED RATE.
ADDITIONALLY DUE TO COPE IN
NINETEEN PUBLIC HEALTH
DIRECTIVES. WERE REDUCING CHILD
CARE CAPACITY SO IT COSTS MORE
TO OPERATE THESE PROGRAMS WE'VE
HEARD FROM OUR PROGRAMS THAT IT
WILL BE AN ADDITIONAL
APPROXIMATELY ELEVEN THOUSAND
HUNDRED PER CLASSROOM. TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS THE COVER
NINETEEN ISSUES. THE PROPOSED
10% CUT WILL PROVE CATASTROPHIC
TO THE FIELD IN RESULT IN MANY
PROVIDERS GOING OUT OF
BUSINESS. AND CRITICAL LC
CAPACITY IN LOST CAPACITY THAT
IS ESSENTIAL FIRST ECONOMIC
RECOVERY AS CALIFORNIANS HEAD
BACK TO WORK. AND WE NEED TO
KICK START OUR ECONOMY. WE'RE
ALSO CONCERNED THAT THE
PROPOSED MECHANISM OF THE RATE
CAPS WILL GREAT INEQUITIES AND
HOW FAMILIES CAN ACCESS CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS THROUGH VOUCHERS
ACROSS THE STATE. AN IMPACT
FAMILIES LIVING IN DIFFERENT
PARTS OF THE STATE DIFFERENTLY.
CURRENTLY ALL FAMILIES HAVE
ACCESS TO AT LEAST 75% OF
PROVIDERS IN YOUR AREA. HOWEVER
AS A RESULT OF THE RATE AT.
SOME PARTS OF THE STATE WILL
ONLY BE ABLE TO ACCESS FORTY
TWO. OF THEIR CHILD PROVIDER.
THE BATTERY WELL EITHER. WITH
BE ABLE TO ACCESS HUNDRED FOR.
WE ARE HAPPY TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
AND ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
HELP IDENTIFY ALTERNATIVE COST
SAVINGS TO THE SYSTEM SAID THAT
THESE DROUGHT DRAMATIC CUTS CAN
BE AVOIDED IF CALIFORNIA
RECEIVES NO ADDITIONAL FEDERAL
FUNDING. AND THAT SAME VEIN WE
ARE ALSO DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE FIFTEEN POINT 4% CUTS TO
THE ASUS PROGRAM. AT A MINIMUM
WE MUST PRESERVE THE EIGHT
DOLLARS AN EIGHTY EIGHT DAILY
RATE EEN IF WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION. IF WE REDUCE THE
RATE WHILE ALSO HAVING TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH AN INCREASE
MINIMUM WAGE OUR PROGRAMS WOULD
HAVE TO SERVE THE SAME NUMBER
OF CHILDREN WITH 15% LESS
SPENDING. PROGRAMS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO PAY STAFF AND WILL HAVE
TO CLOSE THEIR DOORS LEADING
FAMILIES WHO HAVE. WITHOUT
THESE CRITICAL PROGRAMS JUST AT
A TIME WHEN WE NEED THEM TO
ADDRESS THE EARLY LEARNING SIDE
FOR THE LEARNING SIDE AND-
WORKING FAMILIES. FINALLY WE
WANT AT THE CONCERN OF THAT ON
PROPOSAL SHIFT SOME OF THE- CAR.
IN EARLY CARE. AS WELL AS THE
CHILD ADULT FOOD PROGRAM OVER
TO DFS. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT COME. OKAY
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A NUMBER OF-
HAVE QUESTIONS- HERE FOR CD E.
AND PARTMINER FINANCE LA L. WE
JUST KINDA GET ORGANIZED HERE.
I JUST WANTED TO START. OUT OF
THE GATE THAT WE KNOW THAT THIS
IS AN ESSENTIAL- COMPONENT
EVERY OPENING OUR ECONOMY WE
KNOW THE WORKERS ARE ESSENTIAL
THE SAID OVER AND OVER- BUYER
GOVERNOR. AND WE REALIZE THAT
THIS IS A VERY FRAGILE FIELD
AND WHAT WE DO HERE CAN BOOST
IT UP OR CONVERSELY CAN REALLY-
YOU KNOW FRANKLY BUT THE DEATH
KNELL AUDI CENTERS. AND THERE'S
A REALLY POWERFUL ARTICLE LAST
WEEK BY A WOMAN NAMED EMILY
PACK WROTE A COLUMN AND- INTRO
LINE I THINK SAYS IT ALL IT
SAYS. OUR CENTER. A BIG MONEY
MAKER BEST OF TIMES BUT RUNNING
ONE DURING A PANDEMIC IS
BASICALLY LIKE TAKING A BUNCH
OF MONEY AND SETTING IT ON FIRE
SO THAT'S THE REALITY. AND IF
WE LOWER- THEIR RATIOS FAMILIES
KIDS CAN BE IN A SITES IF WE
DECREASE- OF THAT THE RATES IT
HAS FRANKLY- AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE YOU KNOW- TO- ESSENTIALLY
A PROBLEM FOR NON THESE CENTERS
BUT FOR US TO. REOPEN OUR
ECONOMY SO I GUESS MY FIRST
QUESTION IS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WE KNOW THIS IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART. OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE ALREADY STATE
STATED THAT THE WORKERS IN THE
FIELD ARE PART OF THE CENTURY
OPENING OF CALIFORNIA THEN
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK THINKING
ABOUT HERE IN MY OWN. DISTRICT
ALL OF MY STATE WORKERS. WE CAN
GET TO WORK- PART OF THAT IS
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE A PLACE
TO PUT THEIR KIDS WE- IS.
BUDGET AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
CAN SUPPORT IN PROP UP C. SENSE
PART OF OUR ECONOMY. HELLO LISA
RESIDENTS GARY ABOUT WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. BUT YEAH
YOU MUCH AS YOU KNOW THESE ARE-VERY VERY DIFFICULT DECISIONS
THAT WE HAD TO MAKE- AND
CUTTING THE BUDGET AND WE TRY
TO BE AS- EQUITABLE AND THE
DECISIONS IN THESE REDUCTIONS
SO. I THINK AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WE WERE LOOKING FOR MORE DATA
ON UNDERSTANDING THE CLOSURES
WHO IS GOING TO RE OPEN AND
WHAT THE STATE OF AFFAIRS LOOK
LIKE AS WE GO INTO THE SUMMER
MONTHS AND WE WILL AND WE DO
LOOK FORWARD WITH.WORKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF. EDUCATION
AND THE LEGISLATURE AND KIND
OF- MAKING SOME OF THESE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. THE I'M
SORRY. ARE YOU FINISHED YES
OKAY SO I GUESS THAT THAT THE
ANTHONY AGAIN IS. ADD ALL THESE
OTHER QUESTIONS YOU'RE WELCOME
BACK TO THAT. DO WE THINK THAT
THE PROPOSAL BEFORE US WILL
ALLOW US TO KEEP THE- THE
GRADUAL CHILD CARE NETWORK
GOING IN CALIFORNIA.
ESSENTIALLY IF WE HAVE TO FACE
THE TRIGGER CUTS AND I'LL GET
TO THIS IN A LITTLE BIT THAT
THAT THE RATE REDUCTIONS DO WE
THINK THAT THEY'LL BE ABLE TO
STAY IN BUSINESS KNOWING THAT
IN THE BEST OF TIMES IT WAS
ALWAYS FRAGILE. POTENTIALLY
HAVING TO SEARCH. FOR A KIDS-
WITH THE NEW. US SAFETY RATIOS.
WITH GLASS OF THE STATE
REIMBURSEMENT. DO WE THINK THAT
THAT THE CENTERS WILL. STAY
OPEN. AND BE ABLE TO SERVE THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL
CERTAINLY ASSUMES THAT THERE
WILL BE THAT THEY WILL STAY
OPEN WITH THE LOWER RATES AND
WE'RE HOPING THAT- WITH
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
THE AT LEAST THE TEN PERCENT.
RATE REDUCTIONS WHICH ARE
INCLUDED IN THE TRIGGER CUTS
WILL WILL NOT HAVE TO TAKE
PLACE. OKAY AND AGAIN THAT GETS
BACK TO THAT THE ISSUE WE SPOKE
AT THE VERY BEGINNING IS THAT.
WE REALLY DON'T HAVE AN
ADEQUATE PLAN BEER PLAN AND CAN
IF IN THE END THE- SCENARIO
THAT THE FEDERAL. SECONDARY
FEDERAL. CARES PROPOSAL- PET IT
DOESN'T MATERIALIZE FOR
CALIFORNIA SO I WANT TO ASK NOW
ABOUT THE OTHER- POTS OF MONEY
THAT WE'RE WE ALLOCATED FOR K.
TWELVE EARLIER WE TALKED ABOUT
THE FOUR POINT FOUR BILLION
GOING TO- LEARNING LOSS AND
THERE'S THE OTHER FOUR BILLION
ELSEWHERE- AT WHY HAVEN'T SOME
OF THOSE RESOURCES BEING. A
BEEN PUT FORTH TO SUPPORT AND
PROP UP THIS INDUSTRY WHICH WE
KNOW IS SO CRITICAL TO GETTING
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AND
SUPPORTING- THE WORK FORCE IN
THIS FIELD. WELL WE HAVE THE
GREATER FIFTY MILLION WHICH IS
DEDICATED TO THE CARE STOCKS
FOR- CCTV JEEZ SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT. THE OTHER FUNDING-
AGAIN AS YOU KNOW THERE'S- IT'S
GOING TO SHORT CUTS AND KATE
TWELVE AND OTHER SITES THE
BUDGET SO. I REALLY WASN'T
INVOLVED IN A LOT OF THE
CONVERSATION FUNDS PUTTING
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE WORK. WE
HAVE THE CARE TAX MONEY THAT WE
WERE. I COUNTY. OKAY. LET'S GO
NOW TO AND I'LL COME BACK IN
THE SECOND FOR THE ASUS PROGRAM.
THE AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSAL IS TO HAVE A RATE
REDUCTION BACK DOWN TO THE
INITIAL PROPERTY NINE LEVELS OF
SEVEN SEVEN FIFTY A DAY DO WE
THINK THAT WILL ALLOW THE
PROGRAMS TO STAY OPEN OR WERE
THEY ALSO SERVE FEWER KIDS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER THE AMOUNT
MENTIONED IN OUR OUR SO GO. THE
REDUCTION IS REALLY AT. FOR
JUST RATE REDUCTION AND NOT
NECESSARY BUT WITH SOME REALLY
THE SLOTS BUT WE'RE CERTAINLY
KEEP AN EYE ON LOOKING AT WHAT
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THAT PROGRAM.
YOU KNOW LAST YEAR DURING THE
BUDGET. WE TRY TO INCREASE
AFTER SCHOOL FUNDING THROUGH
PROP SIXTY FOR THE LEGALIZATION
OF MARIJUANA. A MEASURE AND
UNDERSTOOD THAT WE HAD TO MAKE
A TRADE OFF AND SO WE USE THOSE
RESOURCES TO EXPAND. CHILDCARE
SLOTS AND ONE OF THE PROPOSALS
THE EP DOCTORS LOTS RIGHT. YES
YEAH AND SO YOU CAN YEAH AND
CHAPTER YEAH THAT IS A LOT OF
THE YOU KNOW KIDS OF COURSE ARE
SCHOOL AGE SO WE UNDERSTOOD
THAT THAT IS A TRADE OFF.
GRANTED THAT THE L. THAT THE
PROPONENTS OF THE MEASURE
TALKED ABOUT HOW TO GO TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAM BUT IT IS WHAT IT IS.
THE PROPOSAL THAT THE LA GO
LAYS OUT IS THAT WE COULD USE
THOSE MONIES. TO SHORE UP THE
RATES. IN LIEU OF THE EXPANSION
OF SLOTS IF THE TRIGGER IS
KICKING IN WE DON'T GET THE
FEDERAL MONEY. IS THAT
SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK WE
OUGHT TO BE CONSIDERING I GUESS
YOU'RE- LITERALLY ARE. ROBBING
PETER TO PAY PAUL SLOTS AND
RATES ARE IMPORTANT BUT- AS-
SIR NOBLE MORGAN MENTIONED. IT
IF. PEOPLE WERE BARELY PICKING
UP. THE SLOTS IN THE FIRST
PLACE WITH WITH THE RATES AND
IF YOU REDUCING EVEN MORE DOES
THAT DOES THAT REALLY JUST YOU
KNOW. HAVE EVERYTHING CRATER
AND HOW THE PROGRAMS FALL APART.
I WOULD HAVE CONCERNED WITH
THAT USE WITH THE PROP SIXTY
FOUR FUNDING I WOULD DEFINITELY
NEED TO GO BACK AND RE READ THE
LANGUAGE WITH SOME OF- MARK ARE
EXPERTS. IN PROP SIXTY FOUR
BACK AT FINANCE BUT. OKAY I
GUESS ONE OF THE THAT THE
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS IS THAT WE
KNOW THAT. THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE- STRUCTURE FOR ALLOF OUR
EASY PROGRAMS FOR CHILD CARE
AND STATE PRESCHOOL IT'S- IT'S
IT IS VARIABLE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. IT'S DEMONSTRATED
THAT IT'S- INADEQUATE BY USING
THAT THE SURVEYS FROM THAT ARE
COUPLE YEARS OLD. AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S TWO PROPOSALS IN THE
LEGISLATURE AB ONE IS ONE THE
SENATE. TO REFORM THIS AND
INCREASE TAKE MAKE SURE THAT
THE THESE PROGRAMS CAN STAY
HALL AND FRANKLY EXPANDED SERVE
MORE KIDS. SO THE QUESTION THAT
WE NEED TO ASK OURSELVES IS IF
YOU KNOW THE YOU KNOW THE
TRIGGER GOES INTO A FACT WHAT
WILL THIS MEAN DO WE DO WE
REALLY THINK THAT THAT THESE
PROGRAMS WILL REMAIN
FINANCIALLY VIABLE OR WERE THEY
CLOSE. THEIR DOORS AND SO AGAIN
I ASK DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. IF
WE HADN'T DO THESE 10% CUTS IF
WE HAD TO GO AND PULL THE
TRIGGER BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FEDERAL BAILOUT. WHAT DO YOU
THINK WOULD HAPPEN THERE ARE
PROGRAMS ARE EASY PATCHWORK OF
PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN- THE CHILD
CARE WORLD IN THE AND IT'S PART
DAY PRESCHOOL IN FULL DAY PRE
SCHOOL. I REALLY DON'T HAVE A
COMMENT ON THAT I CAN'T I CAN'T
PROJECT WHAT THIS WILL BE IT'S
NOT OUR INTENT THAT WITH OUR
INTENT WAS TO MAINTAIN ACCESS-
I KNOW THE MASTER PLAN FOR
EARLY LEARNING CARE IS
CONTINUING THEIR EFFORTS AND
WE'RE HOPING THATA WITH WHAT
THEY'RE WORKING ON THAT THERE
WILL BE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS-
MOVING FORWARD. WITH THAT THE
MASTER PLAN. YES YEAH WELL I
KNOW THAT THE MASTER PLAN AT
ISSUE MORE NOT LESS AND SO IT'S
OUR GREAT FEAR THAT THAT THE
WOULD BE AN ABSOLUTE DISASTER
AND ONE. THESE THESE PROGRAMS
PEOPLE TO WORK IN THIS FIELD
WOULD POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW LOSE
THEIR LIVELIHOOD LOSE THEIR
JOBS AND MORE IMPORTANTLY. WE
LOSE PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO SEND
THEIR KIDS AND GET BACK TO WORK
AND SO YOU KNOW MY FRIEND OVER
HERE MISTER GALLAGHER SAYS THE
ONE THING THAT WE NEED TO DO.
TO FIX OUR ECONOMY ISRAEL BUT
ECONOMY PEOPLE BACK TO WORK BUT
HOW CAN PEOPLE COULD GET BACK
TO WORK IF THEY HAVE NO PLACE
TO SEND THEIR KIDS DURING THE
DAY. WELL THAT'S OUR K. TWELVE
SCHOOL SYSTEM. FOR OUR CHILD
CARE CENTERS AND EAT AND
COURSES ARE SUBSIDIZED PROGRAMS
BUT WE KNOW A LOT OF THEM A
BLIND BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN.
AND PRIVATE PAY AND SUBSIDIZE
AS WELL SO I THINK IT'S A GREAT
GREAT CONCERN. ABOUT IS THAT WE
NEED TO. ONE THINK ABOUT IT
THERE A PLAN B. TO MITIGATE.
POTENTIAL TRIGGER CUTS OR- IF
THAT DOESN'T COME THROUGH. YOU
KNOW. THE OTHER DISCRETIONARY
MONIES THAT ARE IN ELSEWHERE IN
THE BUDGET I KNOW THAT.
WHATEVER ACTION WE TAKE
SOMEWHERE ELSE HAS THE IMPACTS
SOMEBODY ELSE AS WELL BUT THIS
IS SUCH A KEY. PIECE OF OUR- OF
GETTING OUR ECONOMY BACK IN
ORDER- OKAY NEXT I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT. THE SHIFT TO. DS S. AND-
I THINK WE HAD A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS. IN
JANUARY QUICK CREATING ITS OWN
DEPARTMENT. AND I THINK THAT
THERE ARE PROBABLY. HE WAS A
LITTLE BIT TAKE HINGED. WHERE
AND I WOULD. MORE THIRTY DAY
AND SO. THE QUESTION IS DO WE
THINK THAT'S ESSENTIAL. TO
CREATE. TO DO THE SHOW. THAT
THAT. OCCUR PRO. IS FROM. CITY
TO DEPARTMENT ALSO SERVE. IN IN
LARGE PART. BECAUSE IT'S SUCH
A- THAT. SHIFT IN IT AND THAT
IN A- THIS TIME RIGHT NOW WE'RE
NOT WE'RE- STEADY AND-
LEADERSHIP IN THIS. ANYWAY AND
THEN SECONDLY IS AT. BUT TO ME.
HOW HE SAID MONIES THAT. THAT
THE PROBING DURING THE NINETEEN
PARA. IT IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSED YESAND
WE DO BY IT IS AND IN ORDER TO
A ON THIS THE PROBE ENERGY
GOING FORWARD. ON THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IS QUITE
FLEXIBLE THAT'S JUST TO START
THE TRANSITION- AND- THE- THE
DETAILS OF THE REMAINDER OF THE
PLAN ARE IN ANOTHER- AGENCIES
SO- UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE HAVING
BACK TO BACK. HEARINGS TO THE
FOLKS THAT COULD PROBABLY GIVE
YOU A LOT MORE DETAILS ON THAT
ARE IN. A SOMEWHAT RIGHT NOW
AND ALSO IN THE FULL SENATE
HEARING. ALRIGHT WE MIGHT WITH
THE NAKED. EYE COOLEY OPEN- ON
THE LINE TO. ANSWER A FEW
QUESTIONS AS WELL. YEAH HEY
YOU'RE HEARING YES ALL TO GO
BACK TO SOME OF YOUR
RECOMMENDATIONS SO- WOULD WANT
ONE WAS. THE POLICY THAT I
BROUGHT UP EARLIER AS FAR AS
THAT PROP SIXTY FOUR THE
MARIHUANA TAX RESOURCES AT LAST
YEAR WENT TO THOSE AT P. P. DOT
JUST FIVE EXPANSION AND YOU'RE
SAYING THAT WE COULD CONSIDER
USING THOSE. FOR RATE
STABILIZATION YOU WANNA TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT. IF THAT'S
RIGHT TO OUR UNDERSTANDING YOU
KNOW- LAST YEAR THE BUDGET-
THERE WAS FIFTY MILLION IN ONE
TIME FUNDING PROVIDED I'M FOR
THE GENERAL TALKER PROGRAM THAT
WAS THE TEND TO BE FOR FUNDING
FOR THE NINETEEN TWENTY YEAR.
AND I WAS INTENDED TO SORT OF
GET STARTED THE FIFTY MILLION
IN WORTH OF SLOTH I WOULD THAT
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BE FUNDED WITH PROP SIXTY FOUR
FUNDING. ARE WE NEED A PROXY
FOR FUNDING WAS COMING
BEGINNING IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
WELL OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THOSE FUNDS OVER THERE WITH
THAT- ARE OF A PROCESS AND-
APPLICATIONS WERE RECEIVED AND
SCORED NONE OF THOSE LAWS HAVE
BEEN OUT THERE NOBODY HAVE BEEN
AWARDED THE SLOTS NONE OF THEIR-
OR A- ANNOUNCES. DIRT THOSE
WATER TO STILL NOT. NUMBER
WHO'S WHO THINK THAT THEY'RE
GETTING THAT THAT'S WHAT I'M WE
RECOGNIZE THAT IT THIS IS
TYPICALLY NOT SOMETHING YOU
WOULD WANT TO DO WITH THAT AND
SAY WELL THAT'S NOT- LET'S NOT
A WARD OF THE SLOTS EVEN THE
PEOPLE OF GOD AND PLIED- FORTY
FIVE BUT WE DO THINK GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF THOSE REDUCTION TO
TEN PERCENT. RATE REDUCTION
THAN GIVEN ALREADY THE COST
PRESSURES THE PROVIDER ARE
FEELING RIGHT NOW THAT RATHER
THAN ISSUING THE SLOTS WHICH
RIGHT NOW ARE STILL NOT THERE'S
NOT THEIR OWN FAMILY THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE ARE DIRECTLY
HARMING BY DOING THIS BUT
INSTEAD OF REDIRECTING THOSE
FUNDS TO HELP STATE REDUCE THE
MAGNITUDE OF THOSE RATE THAT'S
WHAT HELPED. THEY BY FOR
PROVIDERS AND AVOID. SOME OF
THEM I MEAN CLOTHES. YEAH SO IS
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
POTENTIALLY THERE ARE FIVE
THOUSAND FAMILIES ON A WAITING
LIST THAT DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
CHILD CARE THAT COULD
POTENTIALLY GET IT. WITH THESE
PROP SIXTY FOUR MONIES OF LAST
YEAR'S EXPANSION SO THAT
THEY'RE NOT LOSING ANYTHING
THAT THEY DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
RIGHT NOW. BUT PRESSURES
NOTHING BUT CONVERSELY IF YOU
HAVE A- DISASTROUS A RATE
REDUCTION THERE'S TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES COULD
THEY COULD GET KICKED OUT SO
IT'S LIKE YOU'RE NOT CALLING
FAMILIES A HEY YOU WANT YOU GOT
A SPACE BUT THE FLIP SIDE
YOU'RE CALLING. TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES AND
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
CENTERS CLOSE DWN I'M SORRY
SO. I THINK IT'S JUST THE RISK
REWARD ANALYSIS WE NEED TO DO
WHAT'S THE BEST USE THAT AND
IT'S PAINFUL TO BECAUSE YOU'RE-
ROBBING PETER TO PAY PAUL
THEY'RE BOTH- CHILD CARE.
ACCESS BUT WE NEED TO FOCUS ON
WHAT IS YOU KNOW AT WHAT WHAT
WOULD HAVE THE BIGGEST. IMPACT
AND FRANKLY THE BIGGEST
NEGATIVE IMPACT RIGHT. THAT'S
RIGHT AND THAT'S KIND OF A
CONSISTENT FROM A
RECOMMENDATION SIMILARLY WHERE
WE RECOMMEND TAKING THE FUNDING
FOR TEMPORARY VOUCHERS INSTEAD
USING IT PERSPECTIVES. I AM
AGAINST THE MOTHERLY CONCERN
ABOUT THE MAGNITUDE OF THOSE
CUTS TO PROVIDERS AND WHAT THAT
MIGHT MEAN FOR THEIR- LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY. SO WHAT THE WE
RECOGNIZE. ALWAYS WANTING TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL ACTORS
IMPORTANT WE ARE CONCERNED-
ABOUT THESE COST PRESSURES
PARTICULAR RIGHT NOW GIVEN. ALL
OF THE DIFFERENT ISSUES THAT
ARE GONE AS WERE INDEPENDENT.
YET MAYBE YOU CAN HELP US
UNDERSTAND THIS AT YOUR BECAUSE
IT'S LIKE A GAME OF CHESS RIGHT
YOU MOVE ONE PIECE AND- HAS AN
IMPACT OVER HERE AND THEN. YOU
DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
RIGHT. SO HAVE. YOU YOU WOULD
ESSENTIALLY CONSIDERED PULLING
THIS- HE COULD CONSIDER GOING
ON THIS PATH. IF WE DIDN'T GET
THE FEDERAL MONEY BUT WHEN DO
WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW WE WERE
TRYING TO. PUT OUR BUDGET
TOGETHER AND HAVE IT READY TO
VOTE ON THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR IN.
TWO WEEKS OR SO AND WHAT THE
TIME LINE FOR US TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S HAPPENING THE FEDERAL
LEVEL- TO MAKE THIS DECISION.
RIGHT I THOUGHT OBVIOUSLY A
VERY DIFFICULT ON GIVEN THAT
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO. NO WORK
HERE THE YOU KNOW THIS IS THESE
TRIGGERS ARE DIFFERENT FROM SAY
FOR EXAMPLE TRIGGERS OUT THE
STATE IMPLEMENTED- OR OR
ENACTED WHEN WE PUT PROP THIRTY
ON THE BALLOT AT LEAST THERE
WAS SOME VERY CLEAR CERTAINTY
ABOUT. IT IS WHAT HAPPENS IF WE
IF THE MEASURE FAILED WITH WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE MEASURE PASSES
HERE THEY'RE SORT OF LIKE THE
STATE COULD GIVE ZERO TWO WHO
KNOWS HOW MUCH FUNDING TO BACK
OF THESE TRIGGERS THAT DOES
CREATE SOME UNCERTAINTY- IN
DECIDING HOW TO HOW YOU WANT TO
MOVE FORWARD. YEAH OKAY AND
THEN. HOW HOW DOES THIS- PLAY
OUT WITH. MAYBE THIS IS FOR CD
FOR SERRA THAT MORGAN RIGHT
THERE HOW DOES THIS PLAY OUT
WITH THESE LOWER CHILD TO ADULT
RATIOS IN THE SMALLER GROUP
SIZES AS THE ELLIE TALKS ABOUT
IT HOW DOES THIS. HOW DOES MAKE
THESE. WHETHER IT'S A FAMILY
FAMILY BASED- HOME OR A CENTER.
HOW DOES THAT HOW DOES THAT
PENCIL OUT FINANCIALLY. SEVEN
THIS IS THERE IT DOESN'T REALLY
PENCIL OUT SO IT WILL MEAN
INCREASED COSTS FOR THE PROGRAM
SAID THEY HAVE DONE A SURVEY
AND I'M SURE YOU'LL ACTUALLY
GET SOME PUBLIC COMMENT IN A
LITTLE BIT THAT ADDRESSES THAT
BETTER THAN I WELL. BUT SOME OF
WHAT THEY PROVIDED TO US IS THE
ELEVEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
COED COSTS PER CLASSROOM AND
NOT 43% INCREASE COSTS DUE TO
THOSE REDUCE GROUPS ACCESS SO
YOU HAVE TO HAVE ADDITIONAL
STAFF TO COME IN AND ADDRESS
THOSE- SMALLER GRIP SIZES AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY WHEN YOU'RE
HAVING TO DO PRETTY INTENSE
CLEANING EVERY DAY THAT
INCREASES COSTS. IN STAFF TIME
AS WELL WE HAD AN EXAMPLE FROM
ONE OF OUR RURAL COUNTIES THAT
THE 10% CUT WILL COST THEM
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND AND THE
CLEANING ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND SO ALMOST A
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THEY WOULD
LOSE IN ONE YEAR AS THEY IF
THEY WERE ABLE TO KEEP MOVING
FORWARD WITH. HAVING OUR
PROGRAMS. YES SO IT KIND OF
WHAT I SAID EARLIER THAT IN THE
BEST OF TIMES THESE ARE.
ALLOCATE BUSINESSES AND THEY
THEY THEY CAN BARELY HANG ON
AND DURING THIS ERA. THE QUOTE
WAS IT'S LIKE TAKING A BUNCH OF
MONEY IN SETTING A FIRE NOT
SAYING THAT'S WHAT TALK IS THAT
IS ARE WE BELIEVE IN WHAT THEY
DO WHAT WE DON'T TO HAPPEN OF
COURSE SO. WITH THE RATE CUT
AND ATTENTION LEADS DOLE TO
CHILD RATIOS WHAT DO YOU THINK
WOULD HAPPEN AT THE CENTERS. I
DON'T THINK MY CENTERS COULD
CONTINUE GOING FORWARD BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
FINDS TO DO THAT'S I THINK YOU
QUOTED SOMEBODY IS THAT THEY'RE
NOT IN THIS FOR THE MONEY SO WE
SEE ALL THE TIME THAT FROM OUR
CONTRACTORS WHO WE WORK WITH.
HOW CLOSE TO THE EDGE THEY ARE
AND ACTUALLY OUR FISCAL STAFF
HAVE TO GIVE A LOT OF TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO THE FIELD AROUND
HOW TO STAY SOLVENT AND SO IF
THAT'S SOMETHING THEY'RE DOING
WHEN THEY ARE HAVE THE CURRENT
RATES AND WEREN'T HAVING
ADDRESS A SMALLER GRIP SIZES.
RATIOS AND ENHANCE CLEANING WE
KNOW IT WILL BE MORE CRIME
PROBLEMATIC MOVING FORWARD AND
COVERED NINETEEN WORLD. YES SO
I THINK THAT THE QUESTION WE
HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES IS
THERE'S- I THINK THE CENTERS OF
PROBABLY ASK FOR MORE
RESOURCES. YOU KNOW WE BAIL OUT
CERTAIN PLACES IN THE- IN THE
ECONOMY AND THE FEDERAL LEVEL
NOT TOO MUCH HERE WE CAN'T
PRINT MONEY. BUT MAYBE NOT A
BAILOUT BUT SHOULD BE FOCUS ON
NOT DOING ANY HARM RIGHT. AND I
THINK THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE
IS WE'RE NOT JUST KEEPING IT AT
BAY WE HAVE PROPOSALS TO. IT TO
INCREASE- RATES A ROOF AND
REFORM THE RATE STRUCTURE FOR
YOU SEE PROGRAMS AND THAT'S YOU
KNOW FRANKLY KINDA HARD TO PUSH
FOR DURING THIS COVER NINETEEN
ERA. BUT WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
AND THIS MAY REVISED PACKAGE IS
ABSOLUTE HARM IT'S LIKE THE
WORLD OF MEDICINE DO NO HARM
AND SO THESE REALLY- DO HARM SO
I THINK WE NEED TO BE VERY.
MINDFUL ABOUT THAT AGAIN IT'S
NOT JUST WHAT'S MORALLYRIGHT
BUT IF YOU WANT THE ECONOMY NOT
TO CRATER YOU NEED TO HAVE-
FINANCIALLY VIABLE CHILD CARE
IN OUR IN OUR STATE. I THINK I
HAVE. A QUESTION A COME BACK TO
DAHLE TURNED OVER. TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE MONNING GALLAGHER IN
THE MEANTIME SOMEONE MEMBER
LIMA. THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE- WHAT ARE CHAIR HAS
BROUGHT FORWARD I MEAN I CAN'T
EXPRESS. HOW CRITICAL IT IS ADD
THAT WE FOCUS ON PRESERVING THE
CHILD CARE- INFRASTRUCTURE I
KNOW THAT NOT JUST MY
COLLEAGUES HERE BUT THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS HAS LONG LONG
RECOGNIZED- IS THAT AT THIS FOR
DECADES. THAT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS- ARE YOU CENTRAL AND
THEY ARE PART OF RECOVERY I
MEAN WE ARE CLEAR THAT CHILD
CARE IN SCHOOL RE OPENING IS
HOW OUR BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
SIDE OF THE YEAH. AND IF THEY
COME TO ME IS GOING TO OPEN UP
AND I AM I MEAN I'M TRULY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROPOSAL
FOR ARM ARE AND AT S. R. OR-
RATES I HAD TO BE CUT BY TEN
PERCENT. I THINK THAT THAT IS A
MAJOR MAJOR CONCERN WE ARE
READING- I DON'T THINK THEY'RE
KIND OF VETTED STUDIES YET BUT-
KIND OF PROGNOSIS AN ANALYSIS
THAT SOME OF THESE MAY NEVER
COME. BACK IF WE LOSE SOME OF
THESE CHILD CARE PROVIDERS THEY
MAY NEVER COME BACK AND- THAT
IS. UNBELIEVABLY CONCERNING AND
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE FOLKS
TAKING THIS VERY SERIOUSLY AND
I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS A
SMALL WORKING GROUP ON THIS
VERY ISSUE- BECAUSE WE SHARE
THE CONCERNS- BUT EIGHT THINK
FREE MEME. I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT I MEAN IT ASK QUESTIONS
THAT I DON'T KNOW THAT A
TYPICALLY ASK IN A BUDGET BUT
WHAT VALUES GUIDED YOU TO MAKE
THESE DECISIONS ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL WERE SEEN AND I KNOW I
DON'T TYPICALLY ASK THOSE KINDS
OF QUESTIONS THEY GET DEEP DOWN
BUT I'M TRYING TO UNDERSTAND.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO PRESERVE
AND WHAT VALUES ARE IMPORTANT
TO US TO UNDER STAND. WHAT CAN
FRONT OF US BECAUSE WHAT'S IN
FRONT OF IT HURTS IT HURTS A
LOT- AND- I GET THAT THE
MONEY'S NOT THERE BUT I ALSO
JUST THINK LIKE WE'RE NOT
GETTING SOME OF THESE PROVIDERS
BACK EVER. AT LEAST I AND I'M
NOT THE ONLY ONE THAT'S YOU
KNOW PREDICTING A SO IF YOU
COULD JUST EXPLAIN TO US WHAT'S
IN FRONT OF US. IN TERMS OF
VALUES IN HOW YOU ALL CAME TO
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL. SO I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY FOR
FINANCE NOT FOR ME. THE SCREEN
BUT THE CAMERA I KNOW. SO I
DON'T THINK IT'S FAIR TO STATE
THAT AS A VALUE AS A VALUE
STATEMENT THESE ARE DIFFICULT
DIFFICULT CUTS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THIS IS ON SCENE
DROPS. OUT THAT WE'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA SO THIS IS ABOUT
BALANCING THE BUDGET AND THE
FISCAL HEALTH OF STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND EVERY PIECE OF
OUR BUDGET PARTICIPATING IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE REACH THIS
BALANCE SO- I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE THAT POINT. OKAY SO
THEN WHAT PRINCIPLES WERE USED
IN PANIC COMING TO THIS
PROPOSAL. AND I THINK THAT'S
FAIR THIS CT I MEAN WHAT I'M
SENSING FROM YOU IS THAT IT'S
EQUALLY HARD SO I'M JUST TRYING
TO WHAT WAS THE GUIDING.
PRINCIPLES IF IT'S NOT VALUES
THAT KIND OF GOT IT HERE HOW
DID WE THINK ABOUT THIS. IT WAS
ABOUT EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE REDUCTIONS SO YOU WILL SEE
A 10% CUT IN ALL. STATE
EMPLOYEES SALARIES IN ACROSS
THE BOARD AND I'LL SEE IF F. IN
ALL OF THE RELATED. THE 10% IS
CONSISTENT AND IT.
UNFORTUNATELY FAIRLY
DISTRIBUTED SO I DON'T KNOW
THAT YOU COULD SAY IT'S A
PRINCIPLE OR VALUE IS ABOUT.
TRYING TO BE EQUAL AND- AT THE
VERY EIGHT. YEAH THAT THE I
MEAN THAT'S FAIR AND I THINK
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO YOU KNOW
UNDERSTAND OR I AM NOT YOU KNOW
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS JUST A MATTER OF. THIRTY RAY
IT SOUNDS IKE IT'S PARITY
AMONG ALL INSTITUTIONS. NOW I
DON'T PERSONALLY THINK ALL
INSTITUTIONS ARE THE SAME- I
THINK THEY ALL HAVE DIFFERENT
RESOURCES AND HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN FUNDED-
INDIFFERENTLY. CAN'T FIGURE IF
I LIKE THE SMITHS OR NOT- IT
DIFFERENT LEVELS ARE NOT BUT
AND- I. YOU KNOW AND CHILD CARE
JUST ONE THAT. IF I HAD TO
THINK OF PARITY IN EQUITY I'M
NOT SURE HAS EVER BEEN FOR YOU
KNOW. FUNDED IN IN A WAY THAT'S
NEEDED SO IT FEELS LIKE A 10%
HURTS IN A DIFFERENT WAY BUT I
APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND. AND
RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THIS
ISN'T MEANT TO KIND OF HEY US
AGAINST EACH OTHER IT'S JUST
REALLY TO UNDERSTAND AND ASK
THE HARD QUESTIONS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO. WRAP OUR HEADS
AROUND BEFORE WE VOTE ON A
FINAL BUDGET- SO. WE HELD
HARMLESS AT YOU KNOW FOR
SCHOOLS AND SCHOOL BASED
CENTERS- SOME OF THE FUNDING.
THROUGH THE END OF JUNE
THIRTIETH WHAT HAPPENS AFTER.
SO ONCE THE EXECUTIVE ORDER OF
AND IT WOULD GO IT WOULD BE- A
GO BACK TO THE NORMAL SO IF-
BASED ON THE STUDENTS THAT
PLACER. AND ARE THAT ONE TIME
STIPENDS FOR SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS INTENDED TO
ACT AS HOLD HARMLESS. THEY'RE
INTENDED TO HELP IN THIS VERY
DIFFICULT FINANCIAL SITUATION
SO YES THERE AND THEY'RE
INTENDED TO HELP WITH ALL OF
THE ECONOMIC IMPACTS THAT WE
KNOW THAT THESE PROVIDERS ARE
HAVING RIGHT NOW SO LOOK SO
HELP BUT NOT HOLD HARMLESS
NECESSARILY. AND RAN ARE THE
SEVENTY THREE MILLION FOR
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE FOR AT
RISK CHILDREN- AND CHILDREN OF
SEVENTY THREE S. OF ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. TO BE USED FOR
VOUCHERS IN ADDITION TO THE
VOUCHERS PROVIDED THAT- FOR THE
FIFTY MILLION THAT WERE
RELEASED. YES THIS INTO THE
FIFTY MILLION OKAY I NEED CAN
BE AND THAT THE FEDERAL FUNDING
ON THOSE IS AVAILABLE TO
SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE SO WE'RE HOPING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE- HAVE THOSE
SLOTS AVAILABLE DEPENDING ON
WHAT HAPPENS WITH THIS- WITH CO
THAT NINETEEN. ON THAT THOSE UP
SLOTS ARE AVAILABLE FOR.
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AND KIDS AT
RISK DURING THIS TIME. OKAY
WELL I JUST AND I APPRECIATE
THE ANSWERS I THIS IS A
DIFFICULT CONVERSATION I FEEL
LIKE ALL OF OUR CONVERSATIONS
HAVE BEEN DIFFICULT- IT AT AND
LIKE I SAID I THINK THAT I KNOW
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAS BEEN AT
THIS A DEBT. DECK IT FOR
DECADES AND SO IT'S IT JUST.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S WE'RE
REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT- AS OUR
I THINK MY COLLEAGUES HERE- AND
I A YOU KNOW I WANT TO ECHO
WHAT'S BEEN SAID. BY THE CHAIR
AND- YOU KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF
WE CAN COME UP. IN THE SAME WAY
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT IN THE
PREVIOUS DISCUSSION- FOR K.
TWELVE IF WE CAN COME UP WITH A
PLAN B. OR C. BUT- I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR I
THINK THAT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
AS WELL AS A LAWMAKER JUST AYE
I CAN'T LOSE HOPE RIGHT NOW
THAT WE COULD POTENTIALLY
FIGURE OUT A WAY THAT. WE COULD
KEEP SOME OF THESE PROVIDERS
OPEN AND NOT LOSE THEM
PERMANENTLY SO I THINK THAT ANY
COMMENTS OR PASSION. THAT COMES
OUT OF IT IS REALLY LOOKING AT
IT FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR USAND- TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN
DO BECAUSE THIS IS GONNA HURT
EVERYONE. WE'RE JUST NOT BE
SUMMIT WRITERS BE ABLE TO. READ
AND IT'S GOING TO MAKE OUR
STATES. UP PROBLEM HARDER AND-
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
ASKED RELATED TO AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS IN THE PREVIOUS.
CONVERSATION WAS WHAT DO WE
DEAL WITH ALL THESE KIDS. AND I
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DO WITH ALL
THESE KIDS IF THEY'RE NOT IN
CHILD CARE IF THEY DON'T HAVE
ACCESS. I DON'T KNOW WHAT-
HAPPENS. OF BECAUSE WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IS THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO NEED
CHILDCARE. AND THEY'VE HAD TO
MAKE THE TOUGH DECISIONS ABOUT
WHAT TYPES OF JOBS THEY TAKE
WHETHER THEY CAN TAKE A JOB OR
NOT- AND THAT CERTAINLY. HAS AN
IMPACT TO OUR ECONOMY SO. I
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION.
THAT'S ALL I HAVE. THANK YOU
GOOD QUESTIONS I HAVE SOME
FOLLOW UP- FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
AS WELL AS A MEMBER LIMóN BUT
I WANT TO GET TO SOMEONE MEMBER
GALLAGHER. YES SO I WANTED TO
START BY LAYING OUT A FEW
FUNDAMENTAL FAX. HE WAS AS THE
CHAIR POINTED OUT I HAVE BEEN A
PROPONENT OF SAY FREE OPENING
AND IN ORDER TO DO THAT ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I HAVE SAID IS
WE DO NEED TO PART OF THAT IS
RE OPENING SCHOOLS AND- ALL OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH GUIDANCE IS
INCLUDING THE GOVERNOR'S
FRAMEWORK. SAY THAT SCHOOLS CAN
RE OPEN IN THE FALL- NEO. MORE
BOLD NEED DIFFERENT SAFETY
PROTOCOLS THOSE ARE BEING
WORKED ON- BUT THEY UNDER EVEN
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S FRAME WORK
THEY CAN RE OPEN IN THE FALL SO
THAT WILL DO A WHOLE LOT.
HELPING ENSURE THAT KIDS ARE IN
SCHOOL PARENTS CAN WORK OKAY.
THE OTHER KEY COMPONENT THOUGH
HERE IS CHILD CARE. AND
CERTAINLY THAT'S THE OTHER BIG
COMPONENT HERE THAT IN ORDER
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK- SAFELY REOPEN. WE
NEED CHILDCARE. AND THIS IS AN
AREA WHERE ACTUALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ALREADY BEEN
EXTREMELY HELPFUL. AS I LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE GOVERNOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ALREADY
PROVIDED TWO TRILLION DOLLARS
WORTH OF RELIEF THAT IS GONNA
BUSINESSES THAT HAS GONE TO
CHILD CARE. TO HELP AND SUPPORT
US AND THIS IS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S STRATEGY AND
ARGUMENT THIS DOES NOT LINE UP.
BECAUSE IN FACT AND YOU GUYS
ARE RELYING ON IT YOU'RE
RELYING ON FEDERAL MONEY THAT
HAS COME THROUGH HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO MILLION DOLLARS. FOR CODE
NINETEEN EXPENSES INCLUDING
TEMPORARY EMERGENCY VOUCHERS
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
CLEANING SUPPLIES AND SERVICES.
AND SUSPENDING FAMILY FEES.
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
SUBSIDIZE FIRST PER STIPENDS TO
ALL SUBSIDIZE. PROVIDERS AND
SEVENTY THREE MILLION TO
SUPPORT AN ESTIMATED FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
SLOTS. SO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ACTUALLY ALREADY
COME THROUGH TO HELP SUPPORT
CHILD CARE AND YET AND THIS MAY
REVISE YOUR PULLING BACK STATE
MONEY. YOU'VE GOTTEN FEDERAL
MONEY TO HELP SUPPORT THE
SYSTEM THAT YOU ARE PULLING
BACK STATE MONEY AND THEN
YOU'RE SAYING WELL AND THOSE
THOSE ARE GOING TO PLACE UNLESS
THE FED'S GIVE US EVEN MORE
MONEY. THE YOU KNOW THERE MIGHT
BE AN ARGUMENT FOR OTHER PARTS
OF THIS BUDGET SAYING HEY WE
WANT TO RELY ON FEDERAL FUNDS
AND IF THEY DON'T COME THROUGH.
WE'RE GONNA TO MAKE BIGGER CUTS
BUT IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
IN THE CHILDCARE SECTOR WHERE
WE ARE GETTING. MONEY AND YET
THE STATE IS PULLING BACK OR AT
LEAST THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE
HIS PROPONENT PROPOSING A PULL.
BACK ON STATE COMMITMENTS.
SHOULD BE THE OPPOSITE WE'VE
GOTTEN FEDERAL FUNDS LET'S TRY
TO KEEP AS MUCH OF THAT STATE
FUNDING THERE IS OSSIBLE. SO I
MEAN YOU GUYS HAVE ANY RESPONSE
THAT WHY ARE YOU DOING THAT IN
THIS SITUATION. PULLING BACK
STATE COMMITMENTS IN IF YOU'RE
JUST DOING A 10% I GET THAT.
YOU KNOW SOMETIME BUT THAT'S
NOT A GOOD WAY TO BUDGET.
WHAT'S A PRIORITY. THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GONNA TO DETERMINE GOING
OUT TO MAKE THE HARD DECISIONS
BECAUSE WE ARE IN SCARCE TIMES-
AND THE MONEY IS NOT THERE FOR
EVERYTHING. YOU CAN'T JUST SAY
WE'RE GONNA CUT 10% ACROSS THE
BOARD EVERYBODY. THAT'S AN
OVERSIMPLIFICATION WE GOT A
LOOK AT OKAY WELL WHAT ARE THE
MOST FUNDAMENTAL PROGRAMS THAT
WE NEED TO HAVE IN PLACE. TO
HELP PEOPLE THIS IS ONE OF THEM.
SO I WE SHOULD JUST ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU'VE ALREADY GOTTEN
FEDERAL FUNDS AND YOU'RE
RELYING ON THEM IN YOUR BUDGET.
TO HELP KEEP THINGS STABLE WHY
ARE YOU DOING A 10% CUT IF
ANYTHING WE SHOULD TRY TO KEEP
AS MUCH STATE FUNDS IN THERE AS
POSSIBLE ANY RESPONSE FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AGAIN AS
I MENTIONED EARLIER IT'S ABOUT.
BALANCING AND PROVIDING A
FISCALLY STABLE AND BALANCED
BUDGET. AND THOSE WERE. VERY
VERY DIFFICULT IN OUR CHOICES
AS I. AS I KNOW YOU. YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT. YEAH BUT IT
SOUNDS LIKE YOU JUST DID A
SIMPLE 10% ACROSS THE BOARD CUT
IN EACH YEAR. YOU'RE LEAVING A
LOT OF THE TOUGH DECISIONS TO
US WHICH IS FINE HAT'S HOW WE
GOT INTO THIS WORK- I DON'T
KNOW THAT IT WAS A SIMPLE 10%
CUT IF I MAY UM. IT WAS REALLY
A MATTER OF MULTIPLE AND
LAYERED CUTS BECAUSE THE
PROBLEM WAS SO SEVERE THAT WE
DID A LITTLE BIT AND WE HAD TO
GO BACK AND IT WASN'T ENOUGH
AND WE HAD TO DO SO. IT WAS A
CONTINUAL AND A LONG PROCESS
AND THESE CUTS ARE VERY VERY
DIFFICULT THE ADMINISTRATION-
IT THIS IS NOT EASY FOR ANYONE
SET. UP NOW WHAT. ARE YOU IN
THIS. ANOTHER NOT EASY
DECISIONS FOR ANYBODY- BUT ID
THERE WAS A REFERENCE EARLIER
TO HEY WE TRIED TO MAKE IT
EQUITABLE ACROSS THE BOARD WITH
10% CUTS OF ACROSS DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS. AND I KNOW THESE
ARE EASY DECISIONS BUT THIS IS
THIS ESPECIALLY ONE AREA WHERE
YOU WOULD THINK. WE COULD FIND
A WAY TO KEEP. THE MONEY IN THE
SYSTEM IN A SPECIAL WE NEED
WE'RE GONNA NEED THESE MORE
THAN EVER- HAVING SUB TO THE
AND YOU'RE CUTTING RATES AT A
TIME WHEN WE NEED TO KEEP RATES
STABLE. THAT NOBODY DISAGREES
WITH. THE STATE HOME WATER AND
THE NEED TO DO THAT. TO FLATTEN
THE CURVE- BUT THE SIDE EFFECT
OF THAT HAS BEEN. THAT MANY OF
THESE BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY CRIPPLED AND CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE ARE ARE NO
DIFFERENT THEY HAD TO THEY HAD
TO OPERATE UNDER VERY LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FOR A WHILE
COULD ONLY PROVIDE TO A
SENSUAL- WORKERS- SO THEY
DIDN'T HAVE THE NUMBERS. TO
MAKE A PROFITABLE VIABLE
BUSINESS- AND THEN THEY HAVE
ALL THESE OTHER CONSTRAINTS
BEING PUT UPON THEM SO ALL YOUR
YOUR INCREASING THEIR COSTS AND
CUTTING THEIR REVENUE. AND NOW
WE'RE SAYING OKAY BUT OPEN BACK
UP AGAIN AND PROVIDE THIS
SERVICE- BUT WE'RE GONNA CUT
THE OF THIS. THE RATES THAT WE
PAY YOU. AND THAT MAKES NO
SENSE IF YOU'RE IF YOU'RE
PLANNING KEEP. AND THAT AND I'M
OTHER BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
SEVERELY IMPACTED THAT IS WHY
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REOPEN
SAFELY. AND REALLY BEGIN THAT
PROCESS AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT
IS ACTUALLY VIABLE. FOR
BUSINESSES TO CONTINUE TO
OPERATE CHILD CARE BEING THE
ONE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. RIGHT
NOW LET ME ASK THIS QUESTION I
MEAN LA- HAS RECOMMENDED THAT
THE LEGISLATURE MAYBE MAKE
REDUCTIONS BASED ON A
PERCENTILE OF THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE WHICH- MIGHT BE A
FAIR WAY TO ENSURE EQUAL ACCESS
TO THE PRIVATE MARKET- ACROSS
THE STATE IS THAT. SOMETHING
YOU GUYS OF LOOK THAT YOU GUYS
HAVE ANY COMMENT ON THAT. IT IS
NOT PART OF OUR PROPOSAL THAT
WE WOULD CERTAINLY. SESSIONS
WITH THE LA. WELL LOOK I JUST I
THINK MY POINT IS IT I THINK
THIS IS AN AREA WHERE WE CAN
KEEP STATE MONEY INTO THIS
PROGRAM WE ALREADY HAVE FEDERAL
MONEY WE DON'T KNOW WE HAVE NO
CONTROL AS YOU SAID BEFORE WE
HAVE NO CONTROL OF A WHAT- THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ENDS UP
DOING WITHIN. WITH ADDITIONAL
STIMULUS OVER AND ABOVE THE TWO
TRILLION IT'S ALREADY BEEN
GIVEN. WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF
CONTROL OVER THAT I THINK WE'RE
ALL HOPEFUL THAT THERE WILL BE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING COMING IN.
BUT HERE'S INNER WE'VE ALREADY
GOTTEN FUNDING SO WE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO KEEP STATE FUNDING AS
STABLE AS POSSIBLE. AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY BE A PROPONENT OF
THAT AND THE LAST THING I THINK
WE NEED TO DO ESPECIALLY THE
CHILD CARE SECTOR RIGHT NOW. IS
BE CUTTING RATES. ARBITRARILY
ACROSS THE BOARD. AT THE VERY
LEAST MAYBE WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THIS ON THE ON THE
REGIONAL BASIS. AND A AND
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T HAVE TO DO
THAT. AT ALL SO THAT'S A- THOSE
ARE MY TWO CENTS. BUT. OKAY
THANK YOU A MISTER GALLAGHER
THOSE ARE. THOSE ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS GREAT COMMENTARY THAT
TO SHOW THAT THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN ISSUE AND- AND I
APPRECIATE YOU IF YOU ENGAGE IN
HERE JUST A COUPLE FOLLOW UP-
PIECES FROM THAT YOU KNOW WE'RE
GONNA TALK TOMORROW ABOUT UC
AND CSU AND- I CONCUR THAT
THERE'S PAIN ACROSS THE ENTIRE
BUDGET. BUT THAT 10% IS AN
APPLES TO APPLES AND AS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN SAID IN
SOME AREAS AS A BIGGER
CONSEQUENCE YOU COULD ARGUE
THAT IT UC AND CSU LAST YEAR WE
HAD BIG AUDITS ON THEM THAT
THEY HAD THESE. RESERVE
ACCOUNTS AND- SO CALLED SLUSH
FUNDS AND SO THE CUTS FOR
THOSE- UC AND CSU ARE ROUGHLY
BETWEEN THREE AND FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION. MAYBE THEY CAN WEATHER
THE STORM FOR A YEAR OR TWO-
THEY CERTAINLY SOMETIMES OF THE
UC ESPECIALLY HAVE PRIVATE
PHILANTHROPY THAT COULD COME IN
AND FILL THE GAP. THEY COULD
YOU KNOW DO PAINFUL STUFF LIKE
INCREASE STUDENT FEES THERE ARE
OTHER WAYS TO BALANCE IT OUT
THEY CAN ROLL MORE
INTERNATIONAL STUDENTS AT UC.
BUT WITH THESE CUTS IN FRANKLY
CHILD CARE IT'S NOT JUST 10%
IT'S A DEATH SENTENCE SELECT
THE IT'S A REAL CONSEQUENCES SO
WHAT THAT MEANS IS THAT. WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT GOING TO JUST
TAKE IT AS IT IS IT- IT'S 10%
ACROSS THE BOARD BANG FOR STATE
WORKERS AND UC AND CSU AND-
HEALTHIER FACT BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ALL THE SAME THERE THERE ARE
DIFFERENT. VARIABLES WHICH WE
REALLY NEED TO EVALUATE SO WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE THAT
IN MIND BEFORE WE ADOPT OUR
FINAL BUDGET SO- THAT'S NUMBER
ONE. NUMBER TWO. I DO REALIZE
THAT WE'RE MAKING. VERY
DIFFICULT DECISIONS HERE WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT YET BUT
FOR EXAMPLE THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
ADVOCATE OF. PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
GOVERNOR'S TALKED ABOUT
UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL AND WE'RE
PUTTING THAT EXPANSION ON HOLD
AND SO. I CONCUR WE CAN'T
NECESSARILY FOR THAT RIGHT NOW
WE HAD- NOT JUST PRESCHOOL BUT
FULL DAY PRESCHOOL LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET SLOTS INCREASED- WHICH
ESSENTIALLY AS CHILD CARE
BECAUSE IT'S A FULL DAY- GRAND
NOT THE SAME DAY- SOMETIMES AS
THE CHILD CARE CENTERS. NONE
THE LESS THOUGH IT SERVES
FAMILIES WHEN THEY GO TO WORK-
WERE PULLING BACK ON THAT
EXPANSION AND I THINK THAT'S A
SMART THING TO DO- BUT THOSE
ARE AN EXISTING KIDS BEING
SERVED- THERE'S BEEN SOME IN
NEW FAMILIES AND SO. AGAIN TO
CARE THAT HOUSE OP. TO REALLY
UPSET THE APPLE CART UPSET THE
APPLE CART OF THOUSANDS OF
FAMILIES CURRENTLY BEING
SERVED- SO WE NEED TO BE
MINDFUL ABOUT THAT. WERE USING
THE MONIES THAT WE HAD FOR THE
PRE SCHOOL FACILITIES WERE
SWEEPING HOUSAND PUTTING THOSE
TO BALANCE THE BUDGET TO WHICH
I THINK IT'S SMART TO- SO.
AGAIN THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THAT WERE KINDA GIVING ON BUT
THIS ONE I THINK WE NEED TAKE A
SECOND LOOK. I DO HAVE ANOTHER.
QUESTION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE LA OKAY. ON THE
FEDERAL MONIES- MISTER
GALLAGHER TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE
GOT THE FIRST. BIT OF MONEY IN
THERE SO IT WOULD SEEM THAT WE
SHOULDN'T TAKE A MAJOR HIT
RIGHT HERE WE SHOULD. FRANKLY
LOOK ABOUT POTENTIALLY GROWING
WE DO. HAVE THE MONEY'S IN
THERE FOR SERVING MORE IN THE
SENSE A WORKER- AT THE SUCH A
WORKER- CATEGORY- IF THERE IS
AN- ADDITIONAL WAVE A FEDERAL
MONEY- WOULD THERE BE
OPPORTUNITY TO INCREASE ACCESS
TO NOT. FOCUS ON JUST. YOU KNOW
KEEPING EVEN BUT INCREASE
ACCESS. RATHER FOR SLOTS FOR
RATES. YEAH GOING TO TAKE THE
QUESTION- I THINK PART OF THE-
DETERMINATION WILL BE- WHAT
KIND OF FUNDING THAT PROGRAM
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH STRINGS
ATTACHED TO THEM SO FOR EXAMPLE
THE- THE CARE THAT. ARE HAD A
DVD AUGMENTATION WHICH IS THE
AUGMENTATION OF THINK WOULD IN
THE MAYOR VISION DOES WALL ONE
TIME AUGMENTATION BUT THEY WERE
ARE RELATED TO THE OUTBREAK-
THAT MAKES IT MORE DIFFICULT TO
PAY FOR EXAMPLE. INCREASE
ACTIVE BECAUSE YOU'RE USING ONE
TIME FUNDING- BUT TO DEFER BUT
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
ABLE TO PROVIDE A- MORE
FLEXIBLE FUNDING ABOUT
SOMETHING THAT. BUT DEFINITELY.
COULD BE PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION. OKAY. I THINK- I
THINK THAT'S IT FOR NOW. SO
THIS AGAIN WAS. WE DID TALK
ABOUT HE SAYS AGAIN RIGHT YEAH
WE'RE GOOD WITH THAT. SO THE LA
I JUST WANT TO CONCUR THAT THAT
YOU DID RECOMMEND THAT WE DON'T
DO THAT. CHEF FOR CHILD CARE TO
DSS. YES THAT'S CORRECT YEAH WE
ARE CONTINUE TO RECOMMEND
REJECTING A PROPOSAL- AND WE
HAD A WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS IN
IN IN OUR OUR ORIGINAL HOUSE IS
JUST ABOUT- YOU KNOW FOR
EXAMPLE SPLITTING DID GENERAL
TUCKER AT THE PRESCHOOL- AND
ALSO JUST- THE RATIONALE FOR
WHY THE CHANGE WE NEED TO
OCCUR. WHEN WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE CONCERNS- AND WE THINK
THAT THE PROPOSAL HAS BEEN
MODIFIED BUT THE ONGOING COSTS
OF THE RIPPLES ARE STILL
UNCLEAR OKAY- HERE MY FINAL TWO
ISSUES THAT I FOUND MY NOTES
HERE- THIS I WAS GONNA ASK CD
INSERT NOVEL MORGAN. WHAT WHAT
WERE YEAR WHAT WERE YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT THE LAST TWO
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM LA- AND I
GUESS IT'S PAGE TEN. THE READER
ACT UP PROP SIXTY FOUR DOLLARS
FROM EXPANSION TO RATE
STABILIZATION. AND THEN. THIS
IN KAMALA. THING. SHARES THEY
WERE I JUST RECEIVED A PROPOSAL
WHILE WE WERE IN THE HEARING SO
I HAVEN'T HAD TIME WITH MY TEAM
TO REALLY DIVE INTO IT BUT WE
DO WANT TO MAKE OURSELVES
AVAILABLE BOTH WITHOUT LEO THAT
LEGISLATURE ANYA ADMINISTRATION
TO DROP IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
TO ACHIEVE A REDUCTION ACROSS
EARLY LEARNING CARE BEYOND THE
10% RATE CUTS STILL LOOKING AT
ANY OTHER OPPORTUNITY INCLUDING
THERE'S THE FIFTY THREE MILLION
THAT CAME AND AN ADDITIONAL CCF
FINDS HOW COULD THAT BE USED
FOR THE RATES THIS YEAR INSTEAD
OF FURTHER EXPANSION. AND WE
ALWAYS OF COURSE WANT TO
SUPPORT EXPANSION WE KNOW WE
HAVE A LOT OF FAMILIES THAT
NEED ACCESS TO SUBSIDIZED EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE BUT WE'RE
REALLY WORRIED RIGHT NOW THAT
ACCESS ACTUALLY ISN'T
ACCOUNTABLE WHEN YOU'RE CUTTING
THE RATES AS DRASTICALLY AS WE
WOULD BE CUTTING THEM. OKAY AND
THEN. LASTLY THIS IS BACK TO
LA- SO THERE IS SOME CONFUSION
WHEN WE- WHEN WE LEFT HERE IN
MARCH WE HAD AN EMERGENCY
LEGISLATION WE HAVE THAT FIFTY
MILLION FOR- YOU KNOW. CLEANING
AND PP AND ALL THAT AND YOU
KNOW THINGS HAVE CHANGED AND
SO. THAT MONEY IS SHIFTING FROM
THAT. FROM THE BUT FROM THE
CURRENT YEAR TO THE BUDGET YEAR.
RIGHT. YEAH I THINK WE'RE A
RESURFACING THAT ESSENTIALLY
WE'RE NOT LOSING IT RIGHT. IF
SO I THINK- BUT THE COMMENTS WE
MADE SO THERE TO PUT THE
FUNDING THAT WAS THAT WERE
PROVIDED- THE THESE WERE PART
OF THE ADMINISTRATION HAD. THE
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY TO MAKE
ADDITIONAL PREPARATIONS YEAH-
BUT- AND SO THERE WERE TO
CHALKER RELATED- PROPOSALS OR
AUGMENTATIONS ONE WITH FIFTY
MILLION THAT WAS FOUR PP THAT
WAS DISTRIBUTED TO PROVIDERS
WHO ARE OPEN- THAT THE OTHER
WAS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EMERGENCY DOCTORS FOR SENT TO
WORKERS. I'M WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SPECIFIC OUR OFFICIAL NUMBERS
YET BUT WE HAVE HEARD FROM A
FEW- FOLKS THAT THAT THEY THINK
A LOT OF THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS PROVIDED HAVE
NOT GONE USED- NOW UNDER
CURRENT LAW I BELIEVE- I DON'T
KNOW THAT THAT THE THIRD OF THE
ALLOWABLE MOVIE FOR BUT WE
WITH. BIG ONE IMPORTANT THING
IN IN ADOPTING THE BUDGET IS
TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF HOW
MUCH OUT FUNDING REMAINS
AVAILABLE THAT WE COULD EXPECT
THAT COULD BE PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR FOR. THEM TO
WORKERS IN IF THAT WERE THE
CASE THEN- WITH THE YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO PROVIDE- MUCH
OR ANY OF THAT- ADDITIONAL
AUGMENT WHAT TIME AUGMENTATION
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAPPENED A PURPOSE. OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS SPECIFICALLY
WAS RATHER THAN PROVIDING THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FEET OR THE
ADDITIONAL ONE TIME DOCTORS IS
TO USE THE PERSPECTIVE. I GUESS
THAT'S THE POINT IS WE MAY NOT
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS WITH THE
FEDERAL MONEY FOR A FEW WEEKS
AND WE'RE TRYING TO WRAP UP OUR
STATE BUDGET PROCESS THAT WE
DON'T WANT TO. RECONCILE THOSE
TWO APPROPRIATIONS SIX MONTHS
DOWN THE ROAD IN BACK- WE HAVE
THIS MONEY FOR THE NEXT YEAR'S
BUDGET WHEN WE POTENTIALLY
COULD BE MAKING DEVASTATING.
ACTIONS NOW SO I THINK WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE ALL THAT
INFORMATION BEFORE. US AS WE GO
FORWARD. THIS DONNELLY OF THE
QUESTIONS THIS ITEM NOW OKAY-
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON ON- THIS THAT CHILD
CARE. SCHOOL SECTION OF THE MAY
REVISE AGAIN THIS IS AN
INFORMATION LINE AND THERE ARE
NO VOTES TODAY. WE WILL NOW
PROCEED WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
RIGHT. KAY AND TO HAVE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM. NOW GIVE NOBODY IN
THE ROOM- SO WE'LL START WITH
OUR TELEPHONE PUBLIC COMMENT.
THIS IS GOING TO BE INTERESTING
SO. GREG WE HAVE A MODERATOR
HERE CAN HELP US OUT RIGHT. YES
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
IT IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROVIDE
COMMENT ON TODAY'S CALL AS A
REMINDER PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO WE DO HAVE- FOLKS CUED UP
ALREADY. LINED SEVENTY FOUR.
AIRLINE AND BEFORE YOU SEEN OUR
ENTERTAINMENT NINE SEVENTY FOUR.
BUT AGAIN WE'RE ASKING
INDIVIDUALS FOR ONE MINUTE OR
LESS SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS AND-
USUALLY I HAVE TO CUT YOU OFF
BUT NOW IT'S NOT MY JOB IT'S
THE MODERATOR EIGHTEEN ANTES
CAN BE THE- BAD COP CUTTING YOU
OFF SO SIXTY SECONDS OR LESS.
HE MIGHT THANK YOU. THERE YEAH
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ARE HEARING TALKIN
ISSUE TODAY I AM GOING INTO THE
WEEKEND BUT THE CHECK YOUR
REPORT FROM THER WE'D LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR BUT
EXPANSION IN CONTINUATION OF.
AFTER HELLO BURGER WE ARE WHERE
ABOUT THE PERCENT CUT IN THE
FIRE REMEMBER RATE. ALTHOUGH
ADDING YOUR- TRY THERE ARE.
THREE MEMBER RATE INTEREST ACT
THAT. TARGET PROVIDERS ARE
EARNED LOCKED IN THE CALLED ANY
CAMPUS AND PAID ON TOP OF LOW
BARBARA THAT HIGHER. CLEANING
BE WILL MAKE IT. BY TO FADE BUT-
THE BAY IS OFTEN FOR WITH THEY
OPEN OR REAL AND CANNOT TO DO
BOTH OF HEY THANK YOU. MINE ONE
OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU
MAY BE THE CHAIR EARLY ON
BEHALF OF THE US JOINT
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOU W. AT
THE I. YOU ALONG YOUR COMMENTS
WILL BE EASY COALITION WE THINK
DEMONSTRATION EXPRESS. THE
COURT FOR THE PUBLIC PROPOSAL
FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION FOUR ONE FIVE FIGHTING
OVER CHAPTER PROVIDER. AFTER IN
ACT BOB. UNGER FUNDING FIFTY
SIX ON AND EIGHTY EIGHT SIX
FEDERAL FUNDING FOR THE PGA
FUNDING. LABOR ADDITIONALLY WE
HOPE LOOKING AT THAT FOR
HUNDRED. FIVE EIGHT TO FIVE THE
BUT MONEY BOTH OVER ABOUT WE
NEED MORE PEOPLE LIKE THE
ACTUAL BE TURKEY CHALK A
PROVIDER ONLY THE COURT BEFORE.
PROVISION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THE COMPASS BANK IN THE CREEK.
IN THE ART MARKET OUR
DEPRECIATE THE CHAIR AT THE
MOMENT THE ONLY MOTHER
GALLAGHER COMMENTS AROUND THE
NEED TO PREPARE CHAPTER A BLACK
GREAT. ADDITIONALLY WE ALSO
OPPOSE THAT HOWARD REDUCTION
FOR H. ONE ETHNIC BUT CHILDREN
GOING TO GET BY- FINALLY ON
BEHALF OF THE U. D. W. WE WANT
TO REITERATE THAT FUNDAMENTAL
VALUEOF CHOCOLATE SHOP
EDUCATION AND MAINTAIN THAT
ADDITIONAL LOT OF KNOWLEDGE IN
THERE CAN BE BENEFIT. IT'S
STREAMLINING. CHOCOLATE THE ONE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. IN ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI DENNIE MICHELETTI COLBERN
WITH KAPPA THANKS TO ALL OF YOU
FOR YOUR INSIGHT OVER MARK WHAT
I'D LIKE TO SAY IS THAT CHILD
CARE DID NOT FARE IN THE YEARS
OF GROWTH IN THE STATE HOWEVER
NOW WE'RE BEING TOLD THAT WE
MUST SHARE IN THE PAINT. I'D
LIKE TO LINE MY POSITION WITH
THE E. T. COALITION THE 10%
CUTTING PROVIDER RATE WILL
CLOSE FAMILY CHILD CARE AND
CENTER THE PROPOSAL WILL DROP
EXISTING RIGHT THE FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES AND LIGHT
EXCEPT PROVIDERS TO ROUGHLY
THREE DOLLARS AND ONE CENT PER
HOUR TO NINE DOLLARS AND NINETY
SIX ROUTE. WE ASK THAT
PROVIDERS BE KEPT HOLD POSSIBLE
ABOUT THAT THE POLICY TO DEADEN
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER TO
ELIMINATE VERY ABLE WORK
SCHEDULE HE CONTINUED FINALLY
THE FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. IS
GOING THROUGH THE CAP PROGRAM A
CAP PROGRAM CAN LITTLE CONTRACT
DOLLARS UNTIL THEY'RE FULLY
EXTENDED WE ASK THE DOLLARS BE
ALIGNED TO THAT PROGRAM. UNTIL
THEY'RE FULLY YOU THANK YOU.
NINE ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. FIVE CHAIR MEMBERS
JOHN WINGER IDEA THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOL LOCATION BURKE
YOU'D LIKE TO THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSING A
BUDGET THAT PRESERVES THE STATE
THE MINUTE THE EQUITY DESPITE
THE CHALLENGING FISCAL OUTLOOK.
HOWEVER AS NOTED TODAY WE
BELIEVE DETAILED NEED SOME
REVISIONS- FOR WE WOULD
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE MAYOR
VISION VISION FUNDING FOR THE
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES GRANT
PROGRAM EVEN WITHOUT THE CALL-
THAT- WILL PROVIDE ACT THAT THE
STATE ADEQUATE FACILITIES. AND
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT TO
OUR SCHOOLS BEING ABLE TO RE
OPEN- SIMILARLY WE APPRECIATE
THE MINISTRATIONS CREATIVE
APPROACH FOR TO GRANTING DID
GRADING DISTRICTS WITH
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY AROUND
THE LEAGUE THE SALE OF SURPLUS
PROPERTY. HOWEVER WE OUT THAT
PROTECTION AGAINST THE EVICTION
OF EXISTING CHARTERS OR THE
DENIAL AFFECT MORE EQUITABLE
BATES THE CHARTER BE AMENDED
INTO THE PROPOSAL AS WE HAVE
SEEN. THESE ON GET BACK IS
BEING PROPOSED BY- DISTRICT
SUCH AS WHAT THE END OF
UNIFIED- TO GET THEY AGREED
WITH CONCERNS RATE TODAY ABOUT
THE ROLLING AVERAGE METHOD FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION ALLOCATION.
AND B H. CAP FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS ALTHOUGH WE ARE. STILL
EXPLORING THE PACIFIC IMPACT
THE CAT MAY HAVE ON THE NUMBER
OF UNIQUE PROGRAMS ARE BASED ON
THE NUMBER YOU PROGRAMS FINALLY
REGARDING PROPOSED DEFERRAL THE
SCHOOL FORTUNATE WE WOULD KNOW
THE CHARTER DON'T HAVE THE SAME
BORROWING A REVENUE GENERATING
OPTIONS THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO
DISTRICT WE APPRECIATE THE
OPTION. PROVIDED FOR DEFERRAL
EXEMPTION IF DEFERRAL- CREATE A
DOCUMENTED HARDSHIP BUT WE ALSO
REQUIRE THAT YOU CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL LOW COST FINANCE
OPTION TO MITIGATE CASH FLOW
CHALLENGES THAT. MAY ARISE FROM
DEFERRAL THANK YOU. MY TWENTY
SEVEN YEAR IS OPEN. I'M SORRY
LÏNG TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT THE
TECHNIQUES THAT YOU ON BEHALF
OF EARLY X. CALIFORNIA AND WE
HOPE YOU WILL CONSIDER THE
FOLLOWING. MANY PROVIDERS WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO CONTINUE SERVING
CHILDREN AT THE EXISTING A 10%
REDUCTION FOR THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE. EARLY LEARNING AND
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY AND WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT THEM. ECHO THE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC AND CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSE SO A RELIC IS
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTING
VULNERABLE CHILDREN. INCLUDING
DEVELOPING OUR FAMILY. WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT TEACHERS AND
PARENTS ARE EQUIPPED WITH THE
RESOURCES THEY NEED TO SUPPORT
THEIR CHILDREN. SIMILARLY THE
STATE SHOULD CONSIDER
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR HOME
BASED IN A FORMAL CARE SETTING.
MANY OF WHOM ARE OFTEN LEFT OUT
OF RELIEF PACKAGE BUT I'VE MET
WITH ANY CRACK HAD ON. AND
FINALLY THE PRACTICE OF
DEMONSTRATED THE NEED FOR STATE
STREAMLINED AND COORDINATED A-
CHILD CARE AND EARLY LEARNING.
GIVE ME THE REST OF THE FAMILY
CAN ACT THE PROGRAMS WITHOUT
CONFUSION FOR THE CARE WELL
BEING AND SAFETY OF THEIR
CHILDREN THANK YOU. NINE ONE
HI THIS IS KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER
WITH SERVICE EMPLOYEES
INTERNATIONAL UNION I WON A
LINE MY COMMENT BUT I'D BE
EARLIER- BUT REALLY YOU WITH AT
FIFTY P. YOU AND ALSO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR COMMENTS
AND RECOGNIZING THAT DENTAL
WORK THAT'S OUT THERE PROVIDERS
I DO AND THAT. SPEAKING ON HE
THREE TWELVE PARTICULARLY
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS AN
CRUCIAL NEED TO RECALL- IN
ORDER TO RE OPEN THE FOR CONNIE
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE ARE
BUDGET CONSTRAINTS AND WE HAVE
TO BE- CONSIDERATE AND WHERE WE
FIND FUNDING BUT WE REALLY
URGE- THAT WE HAVE LAID OUT
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE ESPECIALLY
FOR EXAMPLE WORKERS THAT ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING- THEM MAKING
SURE PEOPLE ARE FED. AND THAT
CHILDREN ARE GETTING RESOURCES
DURING THE CLOSURE THAT WE
DON'T PUT THE LAYOFFS THAN ON
THEIR BACKS GIVING BUT WORD- WE
WOULD URGE DIRECT FUNDING TO
CUT. SOCIAL SERVICES. WE'RE
TRYING TO A THE PANDEMIC IN RE
OPEN PRIOR GO BACK. WE NEED
MAKE SURE THE OUR OLDER A THING
CLEAN AND THE FENCE CONDITIONS
THAT. MAD PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE
TO AVERAGE BILLION. BUT COMING
YEAR WELL THE SHIP TO THE
ENROLLMENT OF FORMULA WE
BELIEVE THAT PROVIDE A MORE
STABLE FUNDING- EVEN OUTSIDE A
PANDEMIC FIRST THE- BEING
CALAMITY THEIR IMPACT INTENDED.
IN THE WAY WE OPERATE SO WE
THINK THAT SHOULD MAKE MORE
SENSE IN THE LONG RUN OFF OF
MORE EQUITABLE. WE KNOW THAT
POVERTY IS THE NUMBER ONE CAUSE
FOR CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM WE ALSO
WOULD URGE CONSIDERATION FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
MODERATE TO SEVERE SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS. WERE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE MAIN ROAD
BY COMPLETE FUNDING FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS BUT- AS WE KNOW ABOUT THE
MONARCHY SEVERE NEED MORE
RESOURCES. ESPECIALLY IF WE
SHIP TO DEFEND WARNING- FINALLY
WE WOULD URGE CONSIDERATION FOR
ONGOING FUNDING FOR THAT.
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS MANY OF OUR
WORKERS ARE UNABLE TO FIND
SUMMER EMPLOYMENT ESPECIALLY
WITH WILL CLOSE. AND OPERATIONS
ALSO THE THING WHAT THEY ALSO
DON'T HAVE ACCESS UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE OR PANDEMIC
ASSISTANT. THIS IS ONE FIFTY
NOT SERVICE THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO THIRD BAM- WE OFTEN OF FAT A
MUCH LONGER LETTER WERE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF SOMETHING WE KNOW
THAT WE HAVE TO CREATE A- AND
ONE OFFER. OURSELVES IN HELPING
ADDRESS THE SITUATION. AND
THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX. ONE
THIRTY FIVE A LINE IS A- HI
THIS IS BRENDA BROWN BACK IN
DIRECTOR CALL PROJECT CENTER
AND THE NO THAT PRESS FOR A
CHILD. NOT LIKE THE LINE COMMON
WITH THE ADVICE THEIR EASY
COALITION BUT I WANTED TO GIVE
YOU A LITTLE REFERENCE OF A
CENTER BASED PROGRAM I AM A
CENTER BASED PROGRAM E DID
CLOSE WE OPENED AND ALMOST
IMMEDIATELY BACK OPEN AND IT
OVERHEAD IS NOT CHANGING FOR
SERVING FAMILIES CONSTANTLY AND
THEY'RE CALLING DAILY SO. I
WOULD LIKE TO STAY OPEN I CAN'T
WITH A 10% CUT AND ALL THE
OTHER CUTS ON TOP OF IT- AND
YET THE NEED IS THERE IS THERE
NOW IT'S NOT IT'S- GETTING
GREATER NOW IT'S NOT WAITING
FOR THE NEW BUT THE NEW BUDGET
TO COME OUT WE JUST NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE SERVING. AND
THAT'S ALL I HAVE TO TAKE. NINE
ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER
CRAPPIE WITH PLACES CALIFORNIA
AND WHILE WE ARE GRATEFUL THERE
ARE NO CUTS THE SERVICE WITH
THE FAMILY ANY PROPOSED CUTS TO
PROVIDERS WILL BE TWO MORE
CLOSURES. FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER CANNOT STAND THIS CAT
AND CLOSES THEIR DOORS IN
THEORY A FAMILY HAVE THE
VOUCHER AND COMBINED CHILD CARE
SOMEWHERE ELSE BUT IS NOT THAT
EASY FOR FAMILY COURT
EXPERIENCE TRAUMA- WHO HAVE A
CHILD WITH SPECIAL NEEDS. IDEA
CARE GIVER WHO THEY CAN TRUST.
AND BUILD A RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THERE REALLY EDGE IS NOT. YOU
CAN MAKE OVERNIGHT. ONE PARENT
DESCRIBED IT TOOK HER A WHOLE
YEAR TO IDENTIFY A PROVIDER
THAT. BOTH HER AND HER CHILD TO
TRUST. THE FAMILY. LIVE A
CONTRACTED. STATE CHILD CARE
CENTER- IF THAT'S GONNA CLOSES
THAT DOWN THE LIVES OF THE PLOT
AND WILL HOP YOU CAN. KEEP WITH
OTHER FAMILIES WHO ARE ON OTHER
CHILD CARE CENTER WAITING LIST.
AND WE'RE NEW RATIO WITH THE
NEW RATIOS THE GLASS CHILDREN
WILL BE THIRD MOREOVER WE
CANNOT IGNORE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WILL
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT LOW
WAGE WORKERS. EARLY EDUCATORS
OF COLOR MANY OF WHO ARE BY
THERE'S BEEN STOPPED THANK YOU.
NINE FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS
ANDREA FERNANDES I'M THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN'S ACADEMY A CENTER
BASED FULL DAY FULL YEAR EARLY
OF THE EDUCATION PROGRAM WITH
pPRESCHOOL CENTER THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. WE IMPLORE YOU
PLEASE REJECT THE 10% CUTS TO
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATES THAT STAR AND THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE OUR AND
MARK THE 10% RATE CUT WOULD
CAUSE MANY PROGRAMS TO CLOSE
THEIR DOORS AND ARTS
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED STAFF.
THE EXISTING RATE LEVELS WERE
INSUFFICIENT PRIOR TO THIS
PANDEMIC AND IF THE 10% CUT
GOES THROUGH IT WOULD AIR
APPARENTLY DEVASTATE CHILD CARE
PROGRAMS LIKE MINE AS WELL AS
THE STATE'S ECONOMY IN RECOVERY
THANK YOUASSEMBLY MEMBER NAME
ON AND ALL OF YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VERNE OF. VULNERABLE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES. MY NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
SERRA BUT JUST A CASUAL WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE THE
PRIORY TAKING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS AND
STAFF AND WE THINK THAT SOMEONE
NUMBER O'DONNELL FOR HIS
COMPANY REGARDING LIABILITY
WHICH IS THE TRUE CONCERN. THAT
THE STATE DEMONSTRATION FOR
RECOGNIZING THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ARE CRITICAL TO RE OPENING THE
ECONOMY AND ALTHOUGH WE'RE
TRYING TO GRAPPLE WITH THE
PRODUCTION ABOUT THE UP AND UP
PEARL DO YOU RECOGNIZE THE NEED
TO PROVIDE. THAT HE PROVIDING
FEDERAL FUNDS WE BELIEVE THAT
IN ORDER TO MEDICATE THESE ON
REAL LEVELS OF REDUCTIONS WE
WILL REQUIRE MAXIMUM
FLEXIBILITY TO ACCOMMODATE A
HYBRID LEARNING MODELED BY
SUPPORTING FLEXIBILITY AS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL MINUTES LENGTH OF
YEAR AND EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS.
WE OFFER SUPPORT PROTECTION. I
A- OF MANY RE. FOR SPECIAL.
STUDENTS AND THE L. YOUR CALL
REGARD THE READ. OF TWO POINT
EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS. CORD TO
ALL. IN VETERINARY PERFORMANCE
OF GRANT THANK YOU SO MUCH. ONE
ONE FORTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THAT EVENING MICHELLE
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION I'M
CALLING TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S CONTINUED COMMITMENT
TO EQUITY AND SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING RIGHT. HOWEVER WE DO
NOT BELIEVE IT IS TIME TO
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
FUNDING FORMULA WHAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS ALREADY FACING SO
MANY ISSUES DURING THE AND THEN
ACT. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
COMMITTEE TO APPROVE THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION EQUITY BUT
THROUGH THE EXISTING EIGHTY SIX
THE TO FUNDING FORMULA WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA COMMENTS ON THAT
ISSUE WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ONE
TIME LEARNING WATER MITIGATION
FUNDS FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION I'M CALLING TO
SUPPORT THE LA US PROPOSAL
PEOPLE LIVE TWO POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS BASED ON ON
DUPLICATED PUPIL COUNT. RATHER
THAN BASED ON THE CONCENTRATION
BRAND. WE GREATLY APPRECIATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC YOU TO
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
AS THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NINE ONE THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI KAREN MAKING IT UP
MY NAME IS GETTING FOR ELEVEN
BOB ANSWERS IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER I AS AND MANY COUNT
HOW MANY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
WILL OVER FIFTY HOURS A WEEK
PROVIDING TRADITIONAL
NONTRADITIONAL HOURS I KNOW
THAT ONE PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GO
BACK TO WORK THEY WILL NEED
HEALTHCARE BUT I KNOW AS MANY
OTHERS HEALTHCARE BUSINESSES
WILL NOT BE HERE FOR THEM
EXPECTING. OUR PAY DECREASES
FOR CARING FOR FAMILY WHOSE
CHILDREN YOUTH THAT. HEALTHCARE
THE PAIN A ALREADY DON'T COVER
ACTUAL COST OF CARING FOR
CHILDREN HM COULD CUT WILL. IN
WILL MAKE IMPROPER BECAUSE TO
PROVIDE QUALITY CARE OF THE
CHILDREN DESERVE AND IF THE
COURT MYSELF AND MY FAMILY.
PLEASE CHECK THE GOVERNOR THE
PUBLIC THE CUT. RATE BY 10%
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
IF YOU COULD MEET YOUR- WELL
PLEASE. HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I'M SORRY THE MY LAI YES I'M
SORRY- YEAH KAREN BUT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BECOME DOLLARS. WE ARE
CURRENTLY FUNDED AT THE EIGHT
THE FIFTH THIRD I WANT THE FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY TWO STUDENT
ACROSS THE SITE. WITH THE
INCREASE FROM POP NINETY EIGHT
WE WERE ABLE TO SERVICE MORE
THAN TWO STUDENTS IN THE
NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR YEAR HAVE
YOU ALL KNOW HAVE BEEN THAT
THAT FIFTY FOR ABOUT SEVEN
YEARS LONGTIME WE PROVIDE
COMPLETELY FREE FOR WHICH
INCLUDE ACTED ENRICHMENT AND
BEING PROGRAM. MINIMUM WAGE IS
GOING TO BE INCREASE SO I AM
VERY CONCERNED AND HOW A THE
PROGRAM WOULD BE ABLE TO THAT
INCREASE ALSO THE PUBLIC. TO
WORK AND AFTER BECOMING MORE
MORE STRING. SO HOW DO WE GET
QUALITY AND MAIN C<c.cyan> STAFF</c>
THAT WITH THAT COMING THROUGH
THE EIGHT THE PROGRAM AND ALSO
KNOW NONE OF US KNOW REALLY
WHAT NEW GUY FOR BE THAT WE
WILL HAVE TO IT TO ANSWERING
BACK WITH. A DIFFERENT CONCERN
BUT BUT STAFF AND BE AMONG FACT
THAT WE WILL. NEED TO BE ABLE
TO THEIR STUDENTS AND OUR
PROGRAM ALSO PROVIDE FREE
TRANSPORTATION THE SUPPER AND
MAX PROGRAM TO ALL FOOD TO
PARTS OF THE IN EIGHT THE- WE
HAVE. UNCLE CONSIDERATION SO
PLEASE RECONSIDER YOUR CUT
THROUGH THE EIGHT THE PROGRAM
THANK YOU. MY FORTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
MODOC SMITH I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF HOUSE COMMITTEE
CHARTER. AND WE OPPOSE THE AGE
CAP PER PEOPLES- IN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND HERE'S WHY. OVER
98% OF OUR STUDENTS OKAY FOR
REPRODUCE LUNCHES IN OUR
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS. OVER
90% OF THE STUDENTS WE SERVE.
ARE OVER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
OLDER FROM TWENTY TWO TO TWENTY
SEVEN SO TOP 10% 70% ARE WOMEN
WITH CHILDREN. AND MOST ALL
OVER EXCEPT BANNERS FOR OVER
TWENTY SEVEN DUE TO BEING
JUSTICE INVOLVED. IN OUR VISION
THIS IS ANTI IMMIGRANT ANTI
REFUGEE BUT WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE HARD WORK IN THE
HARD DECISIONS THAT WE SUPPORT
THE CONCEPT OF. KEEPING
EXISTING PROGRAMMING SPECIALLY
THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME FOR
THESE UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS
TO SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY AND
LEARN TO BE ABLE TO HELP THEIR
CHILDREN. IN THE DISTANCE
LEARNING ARENAS BECAUSE NOW
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL THEY CAN HELP
THEIR CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN OR
WHOEVER SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
MY MOM FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS CAPITAL
HALLERAN WITH THE CHARTER
SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT CENTER WE
APPRECIATE THOSE WHO SPOKE
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CHARTER
SCHOOL AGE CAP ISSUE BUT WE
ALSO HAVE CONCERNS THAT SOME OF
THE OTHER TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE- AND BELIEVE THAT
THERE ARE MANY SUBSTANTIVE
POLICY ISSUES THAT ARE SORT OF
PACKED INSIDE THIS BUDGET
LANGUAGE. A PRIMARY CONCERN IN
THE BUSINESS YOU THAT DIDN'T
COME UP TODAY AT THE LACK OF
FUNDING FOR THE NON CLUSTERED
BIG SCHOOLS THAT LIKE MOST
OTHER SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
CURRENTLY OFFERED DISTANCE
LEARNING. BUT UNLIKE OTHER
CALIFORNIA. AND LIKE OTHER
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS THE SCHOOLS
HAD TO SPEND HEAVILY DEPENDENT
THE FULL DISTANCE LEARNING MODE
BUT UNLIKE OTHER CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS NON CLASSROOM THE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT BEING PROVIDED
WITH ANY FUNDING FUNDING TO
TRANSITION TO THE SERVING THE
SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS. AND IN
AN EXCLUSIVELY ONLINE SETTING
AND THIS IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO
OUR ORGANIZATION THE SCHOOLS
NOT ONLY LOST OUT IN THE
INITIAL ONE HUNDRED MILLION
ALLOCATED IN SB ONE ONE SEVEN
BUT ARE NOW LIVING OUT IN THE
FOUR BILLION ALLOCATION OF
FEDERAL FUNDS I'M TED MITIGATE
LEARNING WHAT WE CONSIDER THAT
FACT- AT AND THE FACT THAT
THESE SCHOOLS ARE NOW THEY DO
JUST THE ONLY PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENTS THAT ARE NOT SUPPORTED
IN THE TRANSITION. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE OH THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT CAMPBELL AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF EMPLOYEES.
AND NOT KEEP IT SHORT REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN CHAIR
HERE TODAY AND THEN WE SUPPORT
THE STREAMLINED HARDSHIP
EHRLICH PENSION FOR LOW
PROPERTY WELL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
COLLEGES. OFFICE OF EDUCATION
AND CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE THOSE
THAT CAN DEMONSTRATE HARDSHIP
BECAUSE OF INSUFFICIENT
PROPERTY TAX COURT LIKE A CASH.
LOWER BORROWING TOOL. IF YOU
MUCH FOR YOUR WORK AND IN YOUR
CAN. NINE ONE FORTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MY NAME IS
LINDA GRAY THX TO THE CAMPING
IN HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD
PRESIDENT FOR METROID SILICON
VALLEY CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. WE RUN OUR KEY
CENTER IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY PROVIDING TAKING
EDUCATION VERIFICATION TO
STUDENTS MARKETS FOR
DISSIPATING DISTRICTS.
PERSONNEL CFS FIJI SANDERS HAD
DIRECT FUNDING NOW WE HAVE TO
GO HADN'T HANDED THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT NEVER KNOWING
OUR FUNDING LEVEL FROM YEAR TO
YEAR WERE SENATE-DISTRICT
THINKING BUDGET DIFFICULTY CAN
SIMPLY REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO CAN ATTEND THE
BENEFIT FROM OUR CENTER. WE'VE
BEEN OPEN FOR A HUNDRED AND
THREE YEARS BUT WILL LIKELY
CLOSE IN THE NEXT FEW YEARS IN
THE ABSENCE OF DIRECT FUNDING
AND CERTAINLY IF THE TEACHER
DOLLARS ARE REDUCED CALIFORNIA
HAS ALREADY LOST THIRTEEN OF
ITS TWENTY SEVEN C. D. E.
CENTERS DUE TO THIS PROBLEM. AT
A TIME AT THE TIME WHEN THE
DEMAND FOR SKILLED LABOR HAS
NEVER BEEN HIGHER OUR STUDENTS
ARE DENTURE CERTIFICATIONS AND
TWENTY TWO COURSES MOST OF
WHICH PROVIDE A THREE G.
CERTIFICATION FOR COLLEGE
ENTRANCE IF THEY CHOOSE. OUR
STUDENTS GO TO WORK FOR TESLA
APPLE OKAY ON BECAUSE THE
HOSPITALS IN THE SENATE COLONEL
PLEASE FIRE DEPARTMENTS AMONG
OTHERS NO HIGH SCHOOL HAS THIS
BASIC FACILITY TO TEACH SKILLS
LIKE HEAVY TRUCK MECHANIC'S
GRADUATE TO MAKE SIX FIGURE
INCOMES WITHIN FIVE TO TEN
YEARS ARE THE NORM. PLEASE I AM
TERRIFIED OF BEING THE BOARD
PRESIDENT TO TURN OUT THE
LIGHTS AND LOCK THE DOORS ON
SOMETHING THAT OFFERS SO MUCH
OPPORTUNITY TO STUDENTS AND
EMPLOYERS ALIKE. UNDER THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL THAT IS AN
EXAGGERATION IT WILL BE AN
ADMIRABLE. PLEASE HELP US.
MIGHT WANT TO THREE ONE MY-
NINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR IS OF.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MERRY
IGNATIUS WITH VOICES
CALIFORNIA- I WANTED TO SPEAK
TO A SOMETHING THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AROUND THE 10% CUT
THAT WERE KIND OF ACROSS THE
BOARD AND HOW. THEIR EQUITABLE-
TO ME THEY ARE THEY ARE EQUAL
BUT THEY ARE NOT AFFORDABLE
WHEN YOU CONSIDER HOW
UNDERFUNDED OUR CHILD CARE
SYSTEM WAS GOING INTO THIS
CRISIS THERE IS NO BARRING
THERE NO DEFERRAL- WE- IT'S
JUST IT'S NOT EQUITABLE- AND SO
WE ARE HOLE HEARTEDLY OFF THE
NET YOU REJECT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO- CUT REIMBURSEMENT
RATES BY TEN PERCENT. WE
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS- VALUED AND
PROTECTED FAMILIES WHO ARE
CURRENTLY RECEIVING SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE BY NOT CUTTING ANY
SUBSIDY THAT WE HOPE THAT YOU
WILL CONTINUE TO PROTECT THAT.
I JUST VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
CONVERSATION AROUND THE LA OF
PROPOSAL TO POSSIBLY CUT ANY
FUTURE EXPANSION AND ACCESS TO
CARE IN ORDER TO PREVENT THE
10% RATE REDUCTION- AT THIS
MOMENT DURING THIS CRISIS THE
LAST THING WE NEED TO DO IS
HEAD. WITHIN WHO NEED CARE
AGAINST WOMEN WHO PROVIDE CARE-
THEY ARE BOTH EQUALLY
VULNERABLE AND EQUALLY NEED TO
BE PROTECTED A THREE HUNDRED
AND HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITH SWEPT. IN ON SPEC
DOLLARS BILL DOLLARS COULD BE
USED TO PROTECT THE RATE
REDUCTION AND SO WE JUST REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DO NOT
HAVE CONVERSATIONS EIGHTY. TWO
BONNEVILLE GOOD AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER- AND ALSO UNCLEAR ABOUT
THE EXTENDED CHILD CARE
VOUCHERS THE EMERGENCY CHILD
VOUCHERS AND WHETHER OR NOT.
AND PAST JUPITER YEARS IT WOULD
BE GREAT GET CLARITY ABOUT BACK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MIGHT ONE
SIXTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS MARTHA THEIR
AGO THE DIAZ AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR BILINGUAL
EDUCATION AND CALIFORNIANS
TOGETHER WE RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE INCLUSION MMA
REVISION FUNDING FOR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND OTHER SCHOOL
PERSONNEL. AS WELL AS THE
DRESSING LEARNING LOSS INCURRED
BY STUDENTS ESPECIALLY OUR
VULNERABLE STUDENTS. HOWEVER
ADDITIONAL EMPHASIS AND
LANGUAGE NEEDS TO BE TARGETED
FOR ENGLISH LEARNER STUDENTS
AND DAHLE LANGUAGE LEARNER
CHILDREN BECAUSE THEY HAVE
UNIQUE INSTRUCTIONAL NAY. AS
WELL AS FUNDING OR SUPPORT OF
PARENTS ESPECIALLY NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING PARENTS TO BE BETTER
ABLE TO HELP THEIR CHILDREN
LEARN. LASTLY AN IMPORTANT AND
SIGNIFICANT POINT NEEDS TO BE
MADE ENGLISH LEARNERS REQUIRED
LIVE DIRECT INSTRUCTION AND
INTERACTION WITH TEACHERS AS
WELL AS WITH THEIR PEERS IN
ORDER TO INSURE INSURE THEIR
LANGUAGE DEVELOPMENT THIS IS IN
ADDITION TO THE ONLINE DISTANCE
LEARNING PROVIDED TO THEM. THIS
NEEDS TO BE REINFORCED IN ANY
LANGUAGE- IN. THE OF
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND LAS
LEARNING COMPONENT THANK YOU.
ONE ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND YOU IF I MAY HAV
YOU SPEAK UP A LITTLE. SURE IS
THAT BETTER YES THANK YOU GO
AHEAD PERFECT YEAH. AND YOUR
NUMBER TELLING HER THAT I WOULD
END WITH THE WIDENING GROUP OR
WITH NAY NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
FIRST OFF I WANT TO THANK THAT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER THAT MET THE MAP
O'DONNELL ANYMORE AND FOR THEIR-
THAT TIME THE QUESTIONS AROUND
SCHOOL MEALS AND GOOD
NUTRITION. I HAD. GONE THE OLD
SIDE GOOD INSECURITY HAD BEEN
AN OVERALL PRIORITY FOR NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE DO WANT TO
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION AROUND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SCHOOL
MEAL- ONE THING THAT WE'VE BEEN
DURING THE PANDEMIC INSPECTED
INSECURITY HAS INCREASED. AND
WE'VE SEEN. AT THE WITH THE
GUYS THAT WE THINK THAT BEING A
MAJOR INCREASE IN DEMAND THAT
WE'VE ALSO SEEN THAT ENDEMIC
UCBCP. TAKE GLAZER AND- I
THOUGHT THERE ONLY BECOME SOME
SORT OF. SAFETY NET PROGRAM IN
A LOT OF COMMUNITIES. SO WE
WANT. TO URGE THE COMMITTEE.
THE CONTINUAL COME. DURING YOUR
DELIVERY. YOU KNOW ACTED WITH
BUT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER. A LOT OF
THE STUDENT BODY KIDS THESE ARE
THE ONLY MEAL THAT THEY CAN
COUNT ON. ME AND WHEN THERE ARE
COOL GOOD FOR CLOSURE THAT THAT
MAJOR ISSUE FOR THE FAMILY SO
WE APPRECIATE AND- THE ADVOCACY
AND THE QUESTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MIGHT ONE FIFTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JAN
DIETRICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AFTER SCHOOL
ADVOCACY ALLIANCE AND THE
DOZENS OF YOUTH SERVING AN
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION THAT SENT
A LETTER TO THE SUBCOMMITTEE
TODAY. WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
PRIORITIZING MITIGATING
LEARNING LINE SOCIAL EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT MEAL. FOR STUDENTS THE
END BUT I CARE SO THAT PARENTS
CAN RETURN THE WORK FOR. AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN BUILT
AND PROVEN TO HELP MEET THE
PRIORITIES BUT IT 18% CUT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS WOULD REDUCE
SERVICE TO STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES AND THE HIGHEST
POVERTY COMMUNITY IN
CALIFORNIA. IF THE CUTS GO
THROUGH AS DEAL AFFECT MEN'S
DROPPING THE RATE TO SEVEN
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS PER KID
PER DAY WOULD GIVE ELEAZAR ONLY
TWO DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS AN
HOUR TO PROVIDE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. AND THESE
PROGRAMS WILL BE FINANCIALLY
INSULT AND SHUT DOWN LEAVING
FAR MORE LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES WITHOUT SERVICE
AND CARE AT A TIME WHEN THEY
NEED IT MOST. PLEASE DON'T PAT
PROVEN AND COST EFFECTIVE
DIRECT SERVICE TO STUDENTS
DURING THIS CRISIS. MY MONTH
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
NINA BUT YOUNG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA ARE A STATEWIDE
ORGANIZATION THAT REPRESENT ALL
STATE AND FEDERALLY FUNDED
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE. I
WOULD LIKE Q. ALIGN MY COMMENTS
WITH THE EP COALITION AS WELL
AS THE NUMBER OF PROVIDERS THAT
HAVE BEEN ON THE CALL TODAY
ADDITIONALLY WE WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE MORE DETAILED GUIDANCE
IN WRITING WHICH WITH THE
VENDOR EARLIER THIS MORNING. I
THINK HER KEY DATES HEALTH CARE
AND EARLY LEARNING HAS ALWAYS
BEEN AN ESSENTIAL SUPPORT TO
OUR ECONOMY BUT NOW MORE THAN
EVER CALIFORNIA NEEDS THIS IS.
THE STAIN ACTS BUT THE EARLY
TURN EDUCATION PROGRAMS TO HELP
OUR MOST VULNERABLE THE FAMILY
THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS- AS WE
LOOK AT PROGRAMS- WE ESTIMATE
THAT 75% OR MORE OF STATE
FUNDED ON EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SYSTEM ALREADY
SERVICE SERVICE CHILDREN UP
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. I TOUCH ON
SOME OF THE PROPOSED CUTS BROWN
BE OUR NAY REVISED WILL BE
ABSOLUTELY DETRIMENTAL TO OUR
DOCTOR SPECIFICALLY WE REQUEST
YOU REJECT THE 10% CUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AS WELL AS
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT
RATES. ARE THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATE AS WELL AS THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WE WERE ABLE
TO SURVEY OVER FIVE HUNDRED
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND A 100% OF THEM
SAID THAT THE 10% RATE CUT WILL
CAUSE THEM TO PARTIALLY CLOSE
THEIR PROGRAMS AND REDUCE STOP.
ON AS SUCH AND THE ADDITIONAL
COSTS FOR SANITATION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS CITED WE REALLY
HOPE THAT YOU WILL OPPOSE THESE
CUTS IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT
THE VERY VITAL PROGRAMS REMAIN
OPEN. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY FOR BEING
ADVOCATES EARLY. CARE AND
EDUCATION PROGRAMS. MY SEVENTY
THREE YEAR LINE A OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ALFRED
DIRECTOR PAUL WITH HOW PREFIX I
ALSO LIKE TO MICHAEL BUT THE
COALITION ARE WE WERE PLEASE TO
SEE THAT THE BY PROPOSED USING
CARE DOT DOLLARS TO PROVIDE.
CHILD CARE FOR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND THE OFFER
STATEMENTS TO PROVIDERS TO HELP
PROVIDE A MEASURE OF ECONOMIC
RELEASE HOWEVER WE ARE
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PROPOSED 10% REDUCTION. TO THE
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE AND
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE WE
JUST CAN'T EXPECT TALK YOUR
PROFESSIONAL TO CONTINUE
SERVING ANY DIFFICULT
CONDITIONS FOR LOWER PAY
ESPECIALLY WHEN MANY WERE
ALREADY MAKING UNLIVABLE WAGES
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. I'M IN
ADDITION WITH THE NEW SMALLER
GROUP SIZE IS REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN SOCIAL DISTANCING SOME
PROVIDERS ARE WORRIED THAT WILL
BE FORCED TO SERVE FEWER
CHILDREN WHICH WILL MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO COVER THEIR
OPERATIONAL CLASS OR DON'T NEED
FUNDING TO MAKE FACILITIES
ADJUSTMENT TO DISAPPEARING
MODELED OR DIGITAL BASE. TO
ENABLE THEM TO SERVE MORE
CHILDREN THEY'RE ALSO COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH ADDITIONAL
STAFFING NEEDS AND CLEANING
SUPPLIES IF YOU HEARD THE FOR
THESE REASONS EXTENDING THE
HOLD HARMLESS PROVISION FOR
PROVIDERS IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT SO THEY HAVE THE
FUNDING TO KEEP THEIR DOORS
OPEN AND SERVING OUR- OUR
STATE'S CHILDREN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. MIGHT WANT
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN MY
NAME'S ERIC KAHN FILLED TULARE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION I'M
HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT 10%
REDUCTION TO THE ARM ARE IN THE
US ARE ARE. AT THE NEARLY A IN
THAT TYPE OF CUT WOULD
EVENTUALLY BE DETRIMENTAL TO
THE WRITING COSTS OF MINIMUM
WAGE EARNERS AND THIRD. IN
ADDITION- THE LAST WEEK BEING
THE UNSPENT MONEY FROM NINETEEN
TWENTY- ACTUALLY ALREADY IS A
10% REDUCTION IN DISCONTENT
PERCENT REDUCTION TO THE ARMONK
SLASH A CAR. IS AN ADDITIONAL
10% SO EFFECTIVELY STAY
PRESCHOOL IS REDUCED. BY TWENTY
POINT 5% IN COMPARISON TO
APPROVED NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
FIGURES. SO I SUPPORT THE BI
PARTISAN. EFFORT ON TODAY'S
COMMITTEE TO DO SURGICAL CUT
NOT ACROSS THE BOARD. EQUITY
ARE QUITABLE CUTS- WE NEED TO
BE SMARTER ABOUT WHAT WE DO TO
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THE EARLY
EDUCATION IN OUR STATE. THANK
YOU AND HAVE A WONDERFUL
EVENING. NINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI KATIE
HARTMAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION I'M A TOP
PRIORITY IS TO RE OPEN SCHOOLS
AND THE ECONOMY SAFELY AND I'D
SEATED EARLIER THIS WILL
REQUIRE MORE FINDING NOT LAST.
I'M TO THE NAY REVISION DOES
NOT PROVIDE THE SUFFICIENT
FUNDING FOR SCHOOL TO REOPEN
WITH THE MODIFICATION NEEDED
DURING A PANDEMIC BUDGET LAWLER
CLASS SIZES INCREASE. CLEANING
AND PP. DE THE MAYOR VISION
COULD YOU REDUCTION THE ATTACK
CUT WOULD BE ALL YEAH BACK. AND
THAT THE BE THE EQUIVALENT
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND FUTURE LAYOFFS AND
INCREASING CLASS SIZES BY ABOUT
NINETEEN PERCENT. AND SO THIS
IS NOT FACED DURING A PANDEMIC
AND WE ASK YOU TO LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL REVENUES INCLUDING
TO SPENDING ADDITIONAL TAX
CREDIT IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THEM. FROM THE HAT. I THINK
HE'LL BE SUBMITTING A LETTER
WITH MORE SPECIFIC FEEDBACK ON
THE VERY PROPOSAL BUT THANK YOU.
MINE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON AND A
BIG CHEER MCCARTY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY- I AM SEEKING ON
BEHALF OF THE ADVANCEMENT
PROJECT CALIFORNIA AND I WOULD
LIKE TO ALIGN MY COMMENTS WITH
THE- COALITION. AT CALIFORNIANS
WHO GROUT WE'RE GRAPPLING WITH
THE EVOLUTION OF THE NEW NORMAL
AND THE CENTRAL TO RECOGNIZE
SHELTER SERVICES THAT THE
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO COMBAT
THAT CRISIS AND OUR ECONOMIC
RECOVERY- I HAD A COMMUNITY WE
REALIZE THAT MAYBE TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS BEFORE VACCINE
WITHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
RETURNING NORMAL. SO WITH THAT
IN MIND WE WOULD LIKE TO
PROVIDE YOU WITH OPERATION- AND
OFFER SOLUTIONS. OUR AND AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET HAD FOUND
MORE THAN ONE IN FACT LET ME
HELP OUR CHILDREN HAVE THE
PARENTS WHO ARE DEFINED AS
ESSENTIAL WORKERS. AND WHAT
ABOUT YOUR LIABILITY AND
DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY COULD
NINETEEN AND FLUCTUATING
ATTENDANT TEACHERS MISTER MOORE
DID ELEMENTS AND IMPLEMENTING
SOCIAL DISTANCE EVEN CHILD CARE
SETTING. BUT TELL PROVIDER AND
REALLY DIFFICULT TO. BUT WE
WANTED TO BY THINKING
ADMINISTRATION. FOR THE HER
TWENTY FIVE MILLION ONE TIME
THANK BEEN FOR STATES OF FLIGHT
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS OFFERING
CARE DURING THE NINETEEN-
SEVENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDS WERE INCREASE
ACTED FOR AT RISK. CHILDREN AND
CHILDREN. SOCIAL WORKERS. A
REQUEST THE LEGISLATIVE REJECT.
MAYBE BY TRICKLED WITHOUT
PROPER ONE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION SHORT ALREADY THAT IT
ENDED FOR FAMILY BE WAIVERS AND
PROVIDER PAYMENT PRODUCTION WE
REQUEST THAT YOU DIRECT THAT
MONEY TO ADDITIONAL ATPASES FOR
INCOME ELIGIBLE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS AND CHILDREN AT RISK SH
LOCK WITH THE POOR
APPROPRIATING ADDITIONAL CARE
ACT FUNDS FOR ADDITIONAL PLACE
TO. WHICH WE WANT TO WORK WE
ARE WORKING WITH THE LEAD FROM
THE FINEST DETERMINE AT
ADDITIONAL TRAIL BILL LANGUAGE
THE NECESSARY TO REMOVE THE
INSURGENTS REMOVING THE FENCE
AT THE FIFTY MILLION FACES AND
FIFTY MILLION AND APART TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE THE LEADING.
FAMILY AND PROVIDERS NEEDS SHE-
ULTIMATELY CHILD CARE HAS.
ALWAYS BEEN AN ESSENTIAL. COURT
HARMONY TELL CARE TO WORK AND
NOW MORE THAN EVER. MEET TO
SUSTAIN ACTIVE PATAKI THAT THE
HELP OF MY MIND FORTY IN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MY
NAME'S JAMES MODES OF STARTING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
THE- YOUNG CHILDREN. I THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR RECOGNIZING
THE IMPORTANCE OF CHILD
DEVELOPMENT THE MINISTER I'M
NOT ONLY PROVIDING CARE FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS BUT ALSO
THEIR ROLE IS SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND PRESERVING AND
RESTORING THE ECONOMY THAT WAY
AS WELL- MORE APPRECIATIVE IN
OF THE GOVERNOR'S. PROPOSAL TO
INCREASE- VOUCHERS FOR
ESSENTIAL WORKERS WE APPRECIATE
THE FAMILIES THE WAIVER AND
WERE ESPECIALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
TO SUPPORT PROVIDERS WHO
REMAINED OPEN DURING THIS TIME
ALIGNING WITH OTHER EASY
COALITION MEMBERS. WE ARE-
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO NASH HE
REJECTED THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL OF THE 10% CUT TO THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. FOR MANY OF
THE SAME REASON THAT MY
COLLEAGUES SHARED TODAY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME. MY MOM BEFORE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING MY NAME
IS ERIC HOLIDAY I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STUDENT NUTRITION
SERVICES THE ALPHA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE STUDENTS WE THIRD AND ABOUT
NINE SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS ARE CONTINUE TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS EVERY DAY TO
THE SPENT DENTAL. UNDER ATTACK%
COUNTY WE CAN HUGE NEED AND IT
SERVED OVER SEVEN MILLION MILL
SCHOOL CLOSURES HI MIL CAUGHT
THAT INCREASE AND WE NEED
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PHYSICALLY
RECRUITING LABOR WHICH IS THE
LARGEST EXPENSES FOR. FOOD
SERVICE PROGRAM. IF I NATURAL.
THIS GO COULD SERVE WILL BE
DEVASTATING A MOST DISTRICTS.
SERVICE DEPARTMENT IN THE RED
ALSO NOT KNOWING WHAT SCHOOL
LOOK LIKE IN THE FALL AND
SOCIAL DEFEATING GUIDELINES
WILL BE A CHALLENGE LIKE NO
OTHER IN THE HISTORY OF
CALIFORNIA. AND THE UNITED
STATES. TO SELL PATH BUT IT
WILL TAKE A COLLECTIVE EFFORT
TO THE COURT SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICEAND THE OFFENSE OF ALL
THE PLAY DURING THIS CRISIS.
THANK YOU. MY MOM FORTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS KEY
ESSENTIALLY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CHILD CARE WE TALKED TO
REFERRAL NETWORK AND WE ALIGN
OUR COMMON TO THE EARLY IT
WOULD BE EASY COLLECTION- I
WANT TO THANK CHAIRMAN PARTY
AND THE REST OF THE MEMBERS FOR
ALL OF YOUR STOP FOR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS DURING TODAY'S
HEARING. YOU ARE SO RIGHT BACK
10% CUT TO PROVIDER RATE IT'S
JUST TOO MUCH TO BEAR WHEN SHE
HEALTHCARE IS LOCKED IT'S
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE TO RECOVER-
IN FACT WE HAVE YET TO RECOVER
FROM THE LOSS OF FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES IN THE LAST
RECESSION STILL 30% BELOW RISK
PRE RECESSION SUPPLY. RATES
ALREADY LAGGED BEHIND THE
ACTUAL COST OF CARE REDUCING
THEM FURTHER WE RESULT IN
SLOWER SUPPLY MEANING FAMILIES
WILL STRUGGLE EVEN MORE DEFINED
THE CARE THEY NEED THEM UP AND
BECAUSE MOST HOME BASED
PROVIDERS ARE WOMEN BUSINESS
OWNERS AND BUSINESS OWNERS OF
COLOR AND THOSE CHILDREN WHO
RECEIVE SUBSIDY OUR CHILDREN OF
COLOR THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
UNDERSTAND THAT THE PROPOSED
CUTS ARE NOT EASY PEOPLE CUTS
IN THE BUDGET ACROSS THE BOARD
FURTHER DEEPENS INEQUITIES IN
OUR STATE AND FINALLY PROVIDERS
AND FAMILIES NEED TO CONTINUE
TO BE HELD HARMLESS. TO THE
NEXT FISCAL YEAR THANK YOU.
NINE ONE NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BY NAME IS ADAM
COUNCILMAN AND I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER FOR EAGLE AT RC I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND THE
FRONTLINE SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
WORKERS WERE CONTINUING TO FEED
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS. EVERY DAY
THROUGH THE ENDEMIC WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN INCREASING- FOOD
SERVICE- FUNDING WHICH IS
PROVIDING A CRITICAL SAFETY NET
WHO MILLION CALIFORNIA KIDS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
CRISIS. FROM A RECENT RECENT
SURVEY WITH RESPONSES FROM
TWENTY FIVE SCHOOL FOOD SERVICE
DIRECTORS WHO COLLECTIVELY
REPRESENT FOUR HUNDRED AND FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND SIX
HUNDRED AND NINETY ONE SCHOOLS
WE LEARNED THREE KEY THINGS
FIRST SCHOOL DISTRICT ARE
STEPPING UP. PROVIDING MORE
THAN THREE TIMES AS MANY
STUDENTS WITH MEALS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC- DAN- SUMMER FEEDING
PROVIDES SECOND CONVERGENCE
EMAIL SERVICES CAUSING
SIGNIFICANT BUDGET DEFICITS 80%
OF SCHOOLS REPORTED INCREASES
IN THE OVERALL COST OF SERVING
MEALS DURING THE PANDEMIC. ONE
DISTRICT REPORTED THAT THERE
COULD POSSIBLY TROUBLED THIRD
SCHOOL DISTRICT NEED FLEXIBLE
FUNDING IN ORDER TO STAY OPEN
AND PROVIDE ESSENTIAL MEALS TO
CEDE TO STUDENTS WITHOUT FUNDS
FOR THINGS LIKE PREVENT
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
THAT CAN PROTECT WORKERS AND
KEEP COMMUNITIES SAFE PROGRAMS
RED CLOSURE AND MISSING OUT ON
KEY FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS.
SERVING SCHOOL MEALS HAS NEVER
BEEN MORE DIFFICULT FOR MORE
NECESSARY WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO HELP SCHOOLS
WHICH HAVE BECOME TRUSTED FIRST
RESPONDERS THIS CRISIS TO KEEP
STAFF EMPLOYED TO PROVIDE
ESSENTIAL MEALS THE HUNGRY
CHILDREN AND PROTECT
COMMUNITIES. WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS KEEP THE ISSUE OF
FUNDING SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS UNDER DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
REQUEST. MY NINETY ONE NEARLY
IS OPEN. THANK YOU A LYNCH
SUPERINTENDENT METROPOLITAN
EDUCATION DISTRICT IN SANTA FE
REPRESENTING SIX DISTRICT. MY
COMMENT ADDRESSES THE REDUCTION
FIFTY FIFTY DOLLARS AND THE
OUTCOME THAT WE WILL FACE.
NUMBER ONE- I WANT TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER AND
O'DONNELL FOR ADDRESSING ON
MAKING COMMENTS ON CD EIGHT
POINT NUMBER ONE IS THE
REDUCTION IS IN EQUITABLE.
FIFTY FIFTY IS TAKING A 50% GET
AND OTHER CATEGORICAL ARE
TAKING A 10% IT. THE REDUCTIONS
WILL CLOSE CT CLASSES ON HIGH
SCHOOL CAMPUSES THAT JUST
OPENED FROM SEATED DOLLARS. IT
IS A ROLLER COASTER WITH THE TV
FUNDING. NUMBER FOUR THE
REDUCTIONS WILL FOR CENTER THE
CLOTHES LIKE MINE BECAUSE THEY
HAVE BEEN TAKING REDUCTION
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
HEALTHY AT THAT AND THIS IS
BASICALLY THE NAIL IN THE
COFFIN. BY THE FIFTY FIFTY
EIGHT DOES NOT RECEIVE DOLLARS
FOR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
WHICH IS NEEDED FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING. FIFTY EIGHT DOES NOT
RECEIVE FUNDING FOR PP FROM
FEMA WHEN TRADITIONAL DISTRICT
DO AND SO WHY 50% WHEN WE DON'T
RECEIVE ANY OTHER RESOURCES.
FINALLY FIFTY PROGRAMS TRAIN
ALL OF THE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THE NURSES THE POLICE THE
FIREFIGHTERS THE TEACHERS AND
VETERINARIANS. WE NEED DIRECT
FUNDING BUT FOR NOW RECONSIDER
TO AT LEAST A STEP OUR LOCAL
ECONOMY BECAUSE WE TRAIN THE
PEOPLE WHO WILL GO TO WORK
LOCALLY THANK YOU. MINE TWO
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING CHAIRMAN MCCARTY AND
SUBCOMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
LET'S SPEND CAN AND I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF TOPICS THAT CATCH
HEALER IN SUPPORT AND
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR SPOILED
FOOD NUTRITION PROGRAM DURING
THAT CAN CAN. GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE MEMBER'S
COMMENTS ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THE PANDEMIC IT CREATED
A CRISIS IN WHICH MANY PARENTS
SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE ENOUGH MONEY
TO BUY FOOD AT THE TIME. NOT
IT'S COMPLETELY OVERWHELMED
RIGHT NOW AND ACCESS IF YOU IS
FAR FROM CERTAIN FOR SO MANY
FAMILIES. INITIAL FINDINGS FROM
THE FIFTY BERKELEY STUDY SHOWED
THAT ONLY PRINT VERSION
PROGRAMS OUR STATE IN WRITING
AND FAMILY NEEDS FOR SCHOOL
MEALS AND AT THE SAME TIME.
MAKING AT LEAST SOME OF THEIR
STOCK THEY HOME TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH. OF THEIR EMPLOYEES
THEIR STUDENTS AND THE STUDENTS
FAMILY. PAYING FOR HIGH.
PACKAGING COSTS IN MAKING THE
OLD DELIVERY SERVICE FEASIBLE
AND EIGHT. AND RECEIVING
INSUFFICIENT REIMBURSEMENT TO
RESPOND TO COPE WITH NINETEEN.
EVEN IN DISTRICTS WITH HIGHER
THAN OTHERS BUT GIVE THE
PATIENT REIMBURSEMENTS BUT NOT
ADDRESS ESCALATING COSTS. EVEN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TESTIFIED TODAY. THE
SCHOOLS ARE NOT BEING
REIMBURSED. CURRENT FUNDING
DOES NOT ACCOUNT FOR THE
INCREASE HI. GEN NOT HOW OLD
PROVIDE BASED TRISTAN BUT CORD
DIDN'T EVEN MORE OF A LEARNING
DISADVANTAGE WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK WITHOUT NEEDING TO KEEP IT
IF YOU UNDER DISCUSSION AND
SUPPORT MORE FUNDING FOR THE
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU. MINE TWO
OH ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
AIR NOT THE. LEGISLATIVE COUNTY
WHAT PUBLIC ADVOCATE THE YOUNG
LAWYER THE LEDGE TO HOLD HARM
HI NEW YOU TO LIKE WE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND- GRANT THE
PROPOSED TEMPER CUT OUT THE
BASS. ANY OF THE ABOVE
PRODUCTION BE LIMITED TO BE
GRANTED ONLINE. WITH THE PART
THE PROPOSED INVESTMENT OF MORE
THAN FOUR BILLION FROM CARE
MEDICATE LEARNING A LOT ABOUT
THESHOULD STARTED LEARNING
PROGRAMS AND FULL SERVING HIGH
NEED. WE APPRECIATE DIMINISH.
PROPOSAL DOUBLE DOWN EQUITY YOU
GET THAT RECOGNIZES THAT THE
IMPACT IS NOT THE SAME FOR ALL
STUDENTS. I REALLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CREATE A
STRONG COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
PROCESS. TO ENSURE ALLIOT
TRANSPARENCY ON THE YOUTH THE
STATE AND FEDERAL FINE. LIKE
THE BUILDING VALLEY IS IN THEIR
BUDGETS AND ALL CRAP ADOPTION
THIS YEAR NOT MEANING WITHIN
COMMUNITIES FROM THE VISION OF
MAKING. EVERY FUNDING TO BE
EFFECTIVELY SPENT ON SERVICES
BENEFITING HIGH NEED YOU.
DIDN'T THAN FAMILIES MUST BE
GIVEN OPPORTUNITIES TO PROVIDE
TIMELY AND MEANINGFUL IMPACT IN
THE SERVICES. THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MIND FIVE
YEAR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING
THIS IS WITH A WALK AND I KNEW
EXECUTIVES OF CHILD DEVELOPMENT
FOR SOME OF US ARE CHAPTER CAN
OPERATE IN THE PROVIDE REMOTE
RATE AND GENERALLY. RATE FUNDED
PROGRAMS. FOR THE HUNDRED FORTY
CHILD CARE. CENTER TEACHERS
HAVE BEEN PROVIDING HIGH
QUALITY. EDUCATION IN EUROPE
DURING THE ENTIRE- STATE SHUT
DOWN- PUTTING. THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES AT RISK OF. IN
THE VIRUS- PART OF HIM I WANT
TO REITERATE THE OPPOSITION TO
THE 10% POSITIVE CHANGES IN
PERSONAL RECOMMENDATION GREAT
ACCOMPLISHMENT EIGHT K. RATHER
THAN 10% FUNDING CUT. THE
SCHEDULED MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES FOR SOME OF US ON
JULY FIRST. ANOTHER ON JANUARY
FIRST. HAVE BEEN CALL YOUR-
ACOSTA TAKING TO MAKE SURE THE
CHECK NEVER TURN FOR THE-
NUMBER. CHARTER SCHOOL IN
EXPENSIVE NOT WELL WE WILL NOT
JUST LIKE TECHNICIAN RATE CAPS
THE YOU VERY MUCH. NINE TWO OH
SEVEN. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
EVENING KYLE ISLAND ON BEHALF
OF THE CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY COALITION OF THE
COMMITTEE TO CUT THE 52%
REDUCTION FOR THE CORRECT
TECHNICAL EDUCATION INSTEAD OF
GRANT AND KEEP YOUR TWELVE
STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAM BEING
PROPOSED IN THE REVISION BUT
EQUALLY CONCERNING IT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING TO
ELIMINATE THE CONTINUOUS
APPROPRIATION FOR THE FEET TAKE
PROGRAM BE A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. LIMITING THE AGE THE
ASSURANCE OF ONGOING FUNDS FOR
THAT THE PROGRAM HAVE A
CATASTROPHIC EFFECT ON KIJIJI
ACROSS THE STATE IT COULD LEAD
TO A NUMBER OF THAT NEED A
QUOTE THEIR DOORS THIS FUNDING
SHOULD NOT BE LOOKED AT THAT
THE GRANT FUNDING RATHER THAN
INVESTMENT THAT IT USED TO
DETAIN PROGRAMS THAT TRAIN
STUDENTS FOR EMPLOYMENT THAT IS
VITAL TO THE STATE'S ECONOMY
INCLUDING THE FIRST RESPONDERS
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE COVER
NINETEEN ENDEMIC. WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO NOTE THAT EACH EIGHTY
EIGHT ARE CURRENTLY NOT
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE CODE IN
NINETEEN REALLY FUN WHICH
PROVIDE AT LEAST REPORT THAT
THE PROJECT EP PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING IN CONCERT
WITH. THE DENTIST AND THAT THAT
MORNING WE HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WILL LOOK THE
MODIFY ELIGIBILITY THE FEATURES
OF BEEN REALLY FUN TO INCLUDE
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO
OCCUPATIONAL. LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THE- THANK
YOU. FIND TO TEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. YEAH MY NAME MARIA
SPEAKING AND WE OF CHILDREN
DON'T SOME LET'S GO I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT FOR THE
AND THIS PROCESS SOME HERE
CHECK MCCARTY ALSO SOME NUMBER
ONE OTHER MEMBERS BUT- I
APPLYING WITH THE YOU SPEAK
CHORUS POSITION REJECTING THE
10% CUT. AND INSTEAD WE NEED TO
READING. THINK OF WAYS OF
HELPING OUR CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS FLOAT IN IN THIS-
CHALLENGING TIMES AND WE SHOULD
BE WARY OF BAILING OUT BIG
BUSINESSES BECAUSE AS WE SPEAK
THERE ARE. SOME PLANS. FOR THEM
TO GET SOME OF A REALLY VERY
SCARCE RESOURCES I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS PROCESS THANK
YOU. NINE TO FOURTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MY TO FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NOT MOVE UNTIL
NINE TO FIFTEEN NINE TO FIFTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS ROBERT MAN WEARING- CONTROL
NOW. AND I PERSONALLY TO ALIGN
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS OF THE
IF YOU COALITION AND THEN FOCUS
THE REMAINDER OF MY TIME FOCUS
ON K. TWELVE ISSUES. EIGHT
WHISKEY TOLD FUNDING. DURING
THE LAST GREAT RECESSION- WILL
OCTOBER THIRTY THOUSAND
TEACHERS WE STILL HAVEN'T
RECOVERED FROM THAT TIME PERIOD
AND HAVE CONTINUALLY STRUGGLED
TO RECRUIT AND RETAIN TEACHERS.
NOW IS NOT THE TIME TO ATTEMPT
TO SUBSTITUTE ONE TIME FEDERAL
FUNDS THAT HAVE TO BE IT. USED
TO NEEDS SPECIFIC ADDITIONAL
PROGRAMMATIC NEEDS AND SOMEHOW.
THINK THAT THAT'S REPLACING
BOTH THE 10% CUT DEL CHECKED
OUT AS WELL ON TOP OF
DEFERRALS. I WANTED TO RAISE
ONE OTHER KEY POINTS AND THAT
IS AROUND. THE TRANSPARENCY IN
ENSURING THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION DOLLARS ACTUALLY
BENEFIT THE KIDS. WHO GENERATE
THEM- ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
SEARCHING YOUR COLLEAGUE SAID
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA.
HAVE BOTH COMMITTED TO THIS
ISSUE- AND HAD TO BILLS A. B.
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FOUR NINETEEN
THIRTY FIVE. THAT ARE WORKING
THEIR WAY THROUGH THE PROCESS
TO A DRAFT- FINING MADE BY THE
STATE AUDITOR. ON THE CONCERNS
AROUND SUPPLEMENT ON
CONCENTRATION FUNDS WE BELIEVE
THAT IMPLEMENTING THESE
TRANSPARENCY MECHANISMS WILL
ENSURE. THAT THE CASE DOLLARS
THAT ARE PROVIDED THROUGH
ALTERNATE FAT ACTUALLY GET TO
THE STUDENTS. THEY ARE INTENDED
TO SERVE. MINE TO SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD EVENING I'M
JAN OCCURRED THERE ARE PART.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
STICKING NUTRITION SERVICES AT
TEMPERATURES CAN UNIFIED SCHOOL
THERE'S- I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE FRONTLINE SCHOOL FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS WORKING CHANGES
HE CALIFORNIA'S KIDS EVERY DAY.
AT THE- WE UNDERSTAND THE STATE
CURRENTLY FACES AND THE
PRESIDENT BUDGET CRISIS NOW WE
URGE YOU TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING
FOR NUTRITION PROGRAM. SO THAT
WILL DISTRICT CAN CONTINUE THE
QUIRK WHO DID THE BASIC HUMAN
NEED IN OUR SCHOOL THE FACT
THAT IT BE HUNGRY CHILDREN.
SCHOOLS HAVE BECOME EFFECTIVE
ACCESSIBLE FAMILIAR HAVE BY THE
YOU KNOW IN A SAFE AND HEALTHY
MANNER. HOWEVER THE ADDITIONAL
EXPENSE OF EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
COUPLED WITH A LOT OF
TRADITIONAL REVENUE IN THE FOR
THE POTENTIAL DEBT BURDEN ON
BOTH THE FEDERAL FUNDS. WHAT
PROVIDE. I THANK INDEED. MAKING
BUT ONLY A GRAND YEAH BUT THE
SORT OFFER AT THE VERY PEOPLE
HE A- BILL. BUT MEANT THAT THE
FIVE CONTINUOUS FREE ME ALL
THROUGHOUT THIS CRISIS. WELL
COLLEAGUES AND I AM. THE
FEDERAL BILL A BIRTH. WITHOUT
BOTH I HAVE TO KIDS BETWEEN
BALANCED BUDGET AND PROVIDING
MAIL FOR CAL WHO NEED IT MOST.
WE WERE ASK THAT THE- MEMBERS
THE ISSUE OF. ONLY CHRISTIAN.
UNDER DETACHED THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- MIND ONE SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE TERM MEMBER
WITH THE COUNTRY CONTRACTUAL
WITH THE ANNUAL UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. JOIN THE COALITION OF
FIVE OTHERS URBAN SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND WHAT WE WOULD
OFFER THAT THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF STUDENTS REMAINS A
TOP PRIORITY. AND WE BELIEVE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PRIORITY
EMPATHIZE THAT YOU'RE
CONSIDERING CONFEDERATION THE-
EIGHT BUDGET I WILL WE WOULD
RECOMMEND IF YOU CAN THINK
RAINY DAY FUND TO FUND SCHOOLS.
EVENT OUR UNDERSTANDING THAT
THAT HASN'T BEEN USED YET AT
THE REVENUE SOURCE. AND WE ALSO
KILL THAT FEDERAL FUNDS ARE
THERE TO. SUPPLEMENT AND NOT
THE PLANNING THIRTEEN REVENUE
AND THAT'S WHY WE OFFER. IN THE
NATION ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO
OFFER RECEIVING AN ALLOCATION
FOR SPECIAL ED. SOME MODERATE
AND SEVERE DISABILITY STUDENTS.
TOO OFTEN FOR TOO LONG IT HAS
BEEN- THE FUNDING STREAM THAT
HAS BEEN AN EQUITABLE AND WE
FEEL THAT THAT WOULD HELP.
PARTS OF THE BODY THANK YOU.
ONE TWO NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BUT AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
BUT YOU HAVE AG OUT ON BEHALF
OF THE TOWN OF AL UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT K. TWELVE. THE
COUNSELOR INTERVENTION I. I AM
COMPLETELY AND TOTALLY
ADVOCATING AGAINST ANY CUTS FOR
EDUCATION. A GREAT CUTS THAT
ARE GOING TO AFFECT THE FLOW SO
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING OF OUR
STUDENTS. A GOOD PROGRAM FOOD
NUTRITION SERVICES. ANYTHING
THAT IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT THAT KIND OF AND THEN
MAKE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO NEED
MORE INTERVENTION. INSTEAD OF
THAT INTERVENTION IS IMPLICATED
THEIR- TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
SO MANY THINGS THAT ARE GOING
TO AFFECT OUR STUDENTS ONE OF
FOLK SO AN EMOTIONAL LEVEL.
CANNOT BE TAKEN FROM US AT THIS
TIME AGAIN ONCE AGAIN I TOTALLY
AND COMPLETELY. OPPOSE. ANY BUT
THAT YOU CAN AND THANK YOU.
MINE TO TWENTY. YOUR LINE OF
OPEN. IF THE CABINET MEMBERS
THE JOHN ACROSS THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES ABOUT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND ALCHEMY COLLEGES.
THANK YOU KNOW OUT WITH THIS
LOOK AT THE ALREADY ON THE
FRONT NINE JUNE CHILDREN
FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS TO MUCH
NEEDED NHI<c.cyan> CHILD. BROWN'S</c>
AND- OKAY THIRTY AND MAKING
LOOK GOOD HOW MUCH TO THE- AND
MAKING OUT IN COLLEGE IT KEEP.
ALCHEMY SAFE. ON THE DAY THE
BOND CAT BEFORE YOU WE HOPE
THAT YOU'LL FIND A WAY. TO GET
AROUND THE TEN CUT. MORE THAT
MAY NOT LAST TO ME STAFF LEVEL
THE LOCAL NOT. AS YOU KNOW
CLASSIFIED CLICK ON THE A SHORT
I KNOW. IF GET UP THERE ANY
KIND OF MEAT YOU CUT. WE WILL
AND WE WON'T KNOW WHAT IT
FEDERAL FUNDS WITH MUCH BY TO
COVER THE TEN AND CUT. IT MEANS
THAT THE LOWEST CUT EMPLOYEES
COULD BE AT RISK. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THE ADMINISTRATION
BUILD THE BEST POSSIBLE BUDGET
WHAT STUDENTS AND STAFF. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
TWENTY TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE THAT THE TOPIC
OF OUR FELLOW WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY FIRST
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND ENDING CHILDHOOD
HUNGER- AND HUNGER ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES YOUR- YOUR VOICE ON
THIS ISSUE IS. SO VERY
IMPORTANT- AS WE ENTER INTO THE
THIRD MONTH NOW AND THE OTHER
COMPANY CRISIS- ENDING THE
THIRD MONTH OF THE COVER
CRISIS. THE NUMBER OF THE CHILD
HUNGER AND PARENT HUNGER ARE
INCREDIBLY HIGH- AND TAKE THEIR
THAT REALLY HARROWING EVEN FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE ME WHO'S
EXPERIENCE HUNGER AND WHO HAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
A LONG TIME- SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO- SECOND THE
RECOMMENDATION BY- ARE GREAT
AMONG MANY MANY HEROES-
JENNIFER LOVE OUR CONTENT
BECAUSE OF THE CHECK- AND HER
RECOMMENDATION TO FULLY FUND
THE SCHOOL NUTRITION PROGRAMS.
BUT MORE THAN THAT WE- WE WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO THE TO
EXPAND OUR PROGRAM AND EXPAND
THE REACH OF OUR PROGRAM. BY
MAKING SURE THAT ALL SCHOOLS.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE AT FIND AT TO
ACCEPT COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY-
ARE AT FOR THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AND WE WOULD WE WILL BE ABLE TO
LOCK IN. COMMUNITY ELIGIBILITY
FOR SCHOOL FOR FOUR YEARS BASED
ON THE SCHOOL NUTRITION OR-
SORRY ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL
NUTRITION ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
SNAP OR CALPERS NUMBERS- OF
ELIGIBLE HOUSEHOLDS IN JUNE. SO
IF OUR SCHOOLS TAKE ACTION-
THEY CAN USE THE SNAP NUMBER IN
JUNE TO LOCK A COMMUNITY
ELIGIBILITY FOR FOUR YEARS
WHICH IS BASICALLY ALLOWS THEM
TO- UTILIZE UNIVERSAL FEEDING
PROGRAMS. FOR THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS AS YOU KNOW THAT THE
BUILDING OUT OF THE RECESSION
IT'S CAUSED BY THE CLAIM THAT
CRISIS- WILL BE A LONG AND
ARDUOUS AND REALLY GET THE TO
POOREST MAYES HAVE. A UNIVERSAL
MEAL PRO AT THE SCHOOL OF THAT
HAVE HIGH NOT PARTICIPATION
RATES IN JUNE WOULD BE REALLY
BENEFICIAL SO WE'RE GONNA BE
ASKING- THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THEN AND
CVD CONTINUE BEATING IN THAT
AREA- ADDITIONALLY THEY'LL
THEY'LL HOPEFULLY BE MORE.
OPPORTUNITIES IN THE- IN THE
HEROES ACT IF IT'S PASSED BY
THE U. S. SENATE AND I REALLY
HOPE EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
WILL WEIGH IN WITH THEIR LET
WITH THEIR- MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
AND SENATOR- BOTH OF OUR
SENATORS. AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE PASSING THAT THAT PUT
THE IN THE U. S. SENATE BUT
THERE WOULD BE SOME ADDITIONAL
ABILITY TO REACH OUR LOW
INCOME. CHILDREN WITH SCHOOL
WITH ASSISTANCE FOR SUMMER
LUNCH THROUGH PANDEMIC U. P. T.
ECONOMIC UNITY CARTER GOING OUT
TO FAMILIES- LAST WEEK THIS
WEEK. AND OVER A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS WILL BE GIVEN
OUT. IN PANDEMIC UCBCP TICKET
TO LA MEAL- DURING THE CLOSURES
WE WANT EXTEND THAT TO-
CHILDREN WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT THE A. C. F. P. PROGRAMS
THE CHILD AND ADULT CARE FOOD
PROGRAM BUT ALSO- WHO ARE
MISSING FROM OUR LUNCHES. AND
IF THE HEROES ACTED PASSED WITH
THOSE PROVISIONS WILL BE MORE
WORK FOR TV EITHER DO- ANKLE
DISTRICT TO PARTICIPATE IN. AND
SO AS MUCH AS WE CAN FIND AT
THE POINT THAT WORK AND THEN
FINALLY AT THE ROUND THE CORNER
INTO THE NEXT YEAR. SOME
FAMILIES HAVE HAD UNPAID THE
SCHOOL LUNCH THAT THAT THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO PAY THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
LOOK AT HOW. THEY RECONCILE
THAT DEBT AND WHETHER OR NOT
THEY GO AFTER YOU KNOW THEY GO.
TO THE FAMILY TO COLLECT THAT
THAT OR IS THERE SOMETHING WE
CAN DO TO- TO DEFEND OF. THE
BOOKS OF BACK DEBT FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR- YES THESE ARE
OUR REQUEST AND LUKE FORWARD
WITH THE BUDGET WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU. IN
TWO TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD EVENING THIS IS
JERD CALL WITH CALIFORNIA-
POLICY AT SOMEONE I THINK-
CHAIR MCCARTY AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THE
COMMENT TODAY- WE APPLIED-
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT HAVE BEEN
REALLY AT THE FRONT LINES OF
RESPONDING TO THE CALL THE
NINETEEN PRACTICE BY CONTINUING
TO SERVE MEALS THE BIKE ON
PRESIDENTE CHALLENGES AND
UNCERTAIN FUNDING. FOR CHILDREN
AT RISK OF LOSING SECURITY AND
HUNGER SUMMER HAS ALWAYS BEEN A
PARTICULARLY HARSH TESE THAT
WE'VE BEEN UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES THE NUMBER OF
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS TO SERVE THREE
MALE DURING THE SUMMER BUT
THOSE PROGRAMS YOU CAN
TYPICALLY GETS MORE THAN 85% OF
LOW INCOME CHILDREN. WHO WOULD
BE SERVED DURING THE ACADEMIC
YEAR AND NOW WITH THE ECONOMIC
HARDSHIP INCLUDING SECURITY ON
THE RISE EXTENDED EXPANDING THE
REACH OF EMAIL PROGRAM. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS THE LOOMING
SUMMER NUTRITION GAP WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT STATE
BUDGET LEADERS WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ESTABLISH A
STATE WIDE EXPECTATIONS THE
ONLY A CONTINUE TO SERVE NON
CONGREGATE MEAL DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY INCLUSIVE OF SUMMER
SCHOOL BREAK. AND FURTHER THAT
THE STATE ESTABLISH A CLEAR
DISASTER REIMBURSEMENT FOR
MEALS SERVED DURING COPA
NINETEEN RELATED CAP CLOSURES
TO PROVIDE ELLIE GATES WITH THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO OFFER
MEALS IN A MATTER OF THE
SUPPORT EIGHTY STUDENT FAMILY
AND PERSONNEL. AND FINALLY THAT
THE STATE DID YOU CAN USE THE
SUMMER MEAL WAIVER PROCESS
DURING THE COPA BANK IN
RESPONSE AND RECOVERY FOR ELLIE
EIGHT OPERATE NUMBER SESSION
GET THE LEARNING OR OTHER
MODELS. I ALSO WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS MADE JUST NOW FROM
JESSICA BAR HELLO BUT FEDERAL
NON POVERTY RELATED EXPANDED
THE UPTAKE OF UNITY ELIGIBILITY
PROVISION WHICH ALLOWED SCHOOL
SERVE MEALS YOUR FIRST WEEK
FREE WHICH IS REALLY THE GOAL
GOLD STANDARD FOR SCHOOL BILL
SERVICE AND DOES- DRAWDOWN
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL FUNDING.
AND FINALLY WE JUST DO ONE
THING THAT OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
COMMENT BY THE EARLY AND
EDUCATION. COALITION THANKS
AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND FOR CONSIDERATION
OF OUR- MY MOM NINETY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YOU MAY BE ON
MUTE NINE ONE NINETY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE NINETY
TO YOUR LIFE. AND WE'LL MOVE
ON. WILL MOVE ON TO MINE TO
TWENTY EIGHT ONE MOMENT. NINE
TO TWENTY EIGHT LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS ANDREW CHAIN WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT- AND
JUST A REALLY UNDERSCORE WHAT-
FAMILY INCLUDES YOUR DROP
AGAIN- THE RESEARCH GIPSON
COVERED THIRD IT SHOWS THAT
ONLY FORTY PERCENT. OF
HOUSEHOLDS WITH KIDS UNDER
TWELVE ARE INCLUDED TO CARRY
AND ATTACK ONE IN FIVE HOW OLD.
THE CHILDREN ARE EXPERIENCING
PUTTING SECURITY SO TRULY
SHOCKING LEVELS OF HUNGER- AND
THAT EVEN WORSE AMONGST
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR THAT
CONTINUE EXPERIENCED THE WORST
INEQUITIES- I WANT TO LET
MYSELF WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MISS THE BAR AND I'M JUST
BROKE LOW AND BY. YOUR CALL ALL
THIS TIME AND THAT HE HAS
REALLY BEEN UP AND THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVE BEEN A BRIGHT BUT
LOOK WHAT THE BANKS WHO ARE
REALLY ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THIS CRISIS TRYING TO CO
LOCATE- PANTRY THEN TRY TO MAKE
SURE THAT ENTIRE FAMILY ARE
BAD. ON THAT INCLUDES AN
AMAZING EFFORT TO TRY AND
ENSURE THAT ADULT OTHER MEMBERS
COULD BE REIMBURSED WHICH YOU
IT HE REJECTED WHICH IS THE
POINT IN THE CURRENT CRISIS. WE
APPRECIATE THE NEED LEADERSHIP
AND CONTINUING TO TRY TO ENSURE
THAT ALL THE MEMBERS ARE BAD-
BUT AGAIN WE NEED TO CONTINUE
THE POLICY AND THE RESOURCES
NEEDED TO ENSURE THAT. STUDENTS
ARE FED OVER THE SUMMER- AS
WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
ELIGIBILITY WITH A PROVISION.
MATCHING PREVIOUSLY THANK YOU.
MIND FORTY. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY TWO FORTY YOU MAY BE ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
AND OR COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THAT CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING TODAY THIS WAS A-
CERTAINLY A VERY IMPORTANT AND
LONG HEARING BUT- CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS OF OUR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS ARE EARLY
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND- WE TAKE ALL
THIS INFORMATION TESTIMONY VERY
SERIOUSLY AND- WE'LL BE WORKING
REALLY HARD- TRYING TO COME UP
WITH IDEAS TO. MITIGATE THE
HARSH IMPACT ON OUR KIDS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND- COME
BACK IN THE NEXT- WEEK OR SO
WITH THE ASSEMBLY PLAN THAT
HOPEFULLY A MEMORIALIZES THESE
THESE VALUES IN THESE VISION
AND THESE VISIONS- THANK YOU SO
MUCH SO THAT WE ARE. WE WILL
ADJOURN.